Das ist eine Bombe, die da heute geplatzt ist in Zürich.
In Zürich sind sechs Funktionäre des Fußball-Weltverbandes verhaftet worden. Die Verhaftungen erfolgen am frühen Morgen vor dem Zürcher Nobel-Hotel Burola.
We are here to announce the unsealing of charges and the arrest of individuals as part of our long running investigation into bribery and corruption in the world of organized soccer.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost. Ich bin der Genetzer bei Twitter. Und heute, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werden wir uns mit einem komplexen, aber wichtigen und spannenden Thema beschäftigen, nämlich dem FIFA-Prozess. Ihr habt es gerade schon im Intro gehört. Das war eine juristische Bombe, die da geplatzt ist. Schon vor einigen Jahren, aber das ganze Ding ist immer noch am Laufen. Wie, warum, weshalb und was das jetzt eigentlich alles heißen könnte, das möchte ich besprechen. Mit einem Gast, den ich mir nicht besser hätte schnitzen können, Jürgen Kalwa, freier Journalist, er hat unter anderem für den Deutschlandfunk, die FAZ und die Neue Zürcher Zeitung auch zu diesem Prozess berichtet. Er lebt vor Ort in den USA, heißt auf Twitter at American Arena und ist hiermit herzlich willkommen geheißen im Rasenfunk. Hallo Jürgen.
Ja, herzlichen Dank für die Chance, ein komplexes Thema durchzukauen und hoffentlich Leuten, die sich dafür interessieren, auch nahe zu bringen. Weil es ist, wie ich glaube, eines der wichtigsten Themen im Sport und wird leider durch viele andere Dinge immer wieder an den Rand gedrängt.
Ja, und es liegt halt auch so ein bisschen an der Komplexität. Mir ist das jetzt auch wieder aufgefallen bei der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung. Man muss sich da reinwühlen und man steht immer wieder vor dieser Mammut-Aufgabe. Meine Güte, wie soll ich das irgendjemandem erklären? Ich hab's jetzt gerade verstanden, nachdem ich zweieinhalb Bücher zum Thema gelesen habe. Wie soll man das in eine Sendung packen? Aber da hoffen wir jetzt einfach auf Podcastmagie, Jürgen. Wir haben hier Zeit. Das ist ein bisschen anders als dann vielleicht auch die Dinge, die du dann für Deutschlandfunk machst. Da ist es ja noch viel, viel schlimmer. Da musst du das irgendwie in zehn Minuten reinpressen. Schauen wir mal, wie wir uns da reinwühlen, heute in die Komplexitätsschichten.
Oh ja, also ich bin sehr zuversichtlich, aber ich fange natürlich immer erst mal mit niedrigen Erwartungen an.
Das ist vielleicht nie so ganz schlecht, vor allem, wenn man mit der FIFA zu tun hat, sind niedere Erwartungen eigentlich auch das, was dann auch erfüllt werden kann. Bevor wir loslegen, möchte ich noch schnell ein paar Leuten danken, und zwar Pina, ganz liebe Grüße, Christoph, der Fan der Eintracht aus Frankfurt ist, da soll ich dazu sagen, Wunderheiler Antje und Bettina, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter, der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und paywallfrei. Wer wissen möchte, wie man uns unterstützen kann, kann das herausfinden auf rasenfunk.de. Und ich hoffe, dass wir irgendwann eine Marke erreicht haben, wo wir dann auch Honorare zahlen können. Du Jürgen, bist auch ein ganz großartiger Unterstützer, weil du mir unentgeltlich hier deine Zeit, deine Superradio-Stimme und dein Wissen zur Verfügung stellst. Deswegen auch herzlichen Dank an dich.
Aber ich würde gerne einflechten wollen, dass es sich eigentlich gehört, jemanden, der so gute Arbeit macht wie dich, zu unterstützen. Erstmal egal in welcher Form. Mein Kompliment an dich und vor allen Dingen die erstaunliche Ausdauer, Energie und Intelligenz, mit der du das alles zusammenbringst. Ich glaube, wir haben hier ein Format, also mit dir und deinen Ideen ein Format, das wahrscheinlich auch länger halten wird. Wir haben ja andere Phasen gehabt aus der neuen Gruppe von ambitionierten jungen Medienleuten. Ich hoffe doch sehr, dass du das packst, dass du das durchziehen kannst.
Ach Mensch, Jürgen, das ist ja, als wäre ich Sepp Blatter und du wärst einer von den vielen gekauften Funktionären, die mich dann Lob hudeln nach meiner Präsidentschaftswahl. Vielen herzlichen Dank. Aber das ist ja fast zu viel des Lobes. Es passt aber ganz gut zu diesem ganzen Themenkomplex der FIFA. Das sind ja auch Herrschaften, die sich gerne Lob preisen lassen, die allerdings vielleicht ein bisschen einen anderen Bezug zu Geld haben als wir hier im Rasenfunk. Was mich vielleicht zu der Einstiegsfrage bringt. Jürgen, mal in ein paar Worten, bevor wir es dann länger ausführen wollen. Was ist denn eigentlich der FIFA-Prozess und warum geht es da?
Na ja, es geht um eine Organisation, die wir andere im Sport auch unglaublich unkontrolliert schalten und walten kann, wie sie möchte, die nicht demokratisch ist, obwohl es immer so aussieht. Das sind einfach Seilschaften, wo Leute von oben nach unten, nein, von oben herausgesucht werden und nach oben gezogen werden. Und wo es keine Kontrollmöglichkeiten von außen gibt, außer wenn die Medien wirklich mal versuchen, reinzuleuchten. Das ist schwer genug. Oder wenn dann, wie jetzt bei diesem Prozess, tatsächlich Staatsanwälte mit unglaublicher Akribie und Ausdauer an so etwas rangehen und dann auch natürlich die rechtlichen Möglichkeiten haben, Zeugen und Beschuldigte zu zwingen, sich entweder nacken zu machen oder aber die Möglichkeit haben, an Unterlagen zu kommen wie Konto, Auszüge, Bankinformationen andere Dinge und das ist unser großes Problem, dass wir im Unterschied zu dem, was in der Industrie oder in der Wirtschaft bei großen Unternehmen, die solche Milliardenumsätze haben, alltäglich ist, dort wird genauer hingeschaut, da gibt es interne Kontrollmöglichkeiten und es gibt zwar auch dort hin und wieder irgendwas wie Bestechung oder es gibt andere Es gibt auch andere Kriminelle Aktivitäten, nennen wir nur als Stichwort das, was unter dem Label Volkswagen mit Dieselmotoren passiert ist. Das gibt es natürlich dort auch. Aber die Selbstverständlichkeit, wie das dann angepackt wird, wie zum Beispiel die Amerikaner mit ihren Aufsichtsmöglichkeiten, dann Volkswagen zumindest in den USA in die Knie zwingen, das ist modellhaft, so sollte unsere Gesellschaft heutzutage funktionieren. Das, was im Sport passiert, ist eben völlig atypisch, aber für den Sport ganz normal. Und Leute wie Sepp Blatter haben das jahrelang immer wieder betont. Alle möglichen Dinge, die intern Probleme aufwerfen, die müssen intern gelöst werden.
Klar, in der FIFA-Familie.
Genau, und warum wurde das alles so gehandhabt, wie man es handhaben wollte. Weil man eben diese Kontrolle, die es braucht, nicht haben wollte.
Ja, das macht schon ein weites Fass auf und ist aber ganz gut, um alle Hörerinnen und Hörer darauf vorzubereiten, womit wir es bei der FIFA zu tun haben. Es ist eine Organisation, die sich transparent auf die Fahnen schreibt und alles andere als transparent handelt. Und die vielen, vielen Dinge, die da zusammenlaufen, faktischer Natur, die dann mühsam aufgearbeitet werden von tollen Investigativjournalisten, von Staatsanwaltschaften, das sind immer kleine Mosaiksteinchen, die so einen kleinen Einblick erlauben in diese Organisation hier rein. Hinein aber ganz viele wichtige Dinge, unter anderem zum Beispiel, wie viel verdient eigentlich der FIFA-Präsident so genau, die wissen wir gar nicht. Und das, obwohl die FIFA immer nach außen hin so tut, als wäre man ein gläserner Sarg-Fassstorben. Aber so ist es eben nicht. Aber worum geht es jetzt denn dann in diesem FIFA-Prozess in ein paar Worten?
Na ja, eine der wichtigsten Einnahmequellen heutzutage überall im Sport sind Fernsehrechte. Und das auch, weil es inzwischen eben hochkommerzielles Fernsehen gibt und nicht unbedingt der Rest der Welt hat anders als Deutschland und Großbritannien mit der BBC hat eben fast nur kommerzielles Fernsehen. Und Sport ist dort wahrscheinlich das reizvollste, das teuerste Gut überhaupt auf diesem Markt. Und natürlich haben das auch die Funktionäre begriffen. Erstens, weil sie Schwierigkeiten hatten, sich zu finanzieren. Das ist in der FIFA- Geschichte auch verankert, als Joao Avalanche antrat, war die FIFA ziemlich kränkelnd, was das Geld anging. Und dann haben die schnell gemerkt, dass wenn sie diese Maschine wirklich ans Laufen kriegen, dass da ganz viel Geld fließt. Und dann haben sie alle gemerkt, aber wir sind doch die, die hier die Entscheidung treffen, die die Regler umlegen. Warum sollten wir jetzt nicht daran beteiligt sein, dass dieses Geld dann in die große FIFA-Kasse zum Beispiel fließt. Und da sind halt diese Begehrlichkeiten entstanden und das hat schon früh begonnen. Und die Geldquelle, fernsehrechte Gelder, die ist der Ausgangspunkt. Und wenn man dann halt überall sieht, wer da seine Finger dran kriegt, der versucht halt mitzuverdienen. Und das verstößt außer in der Schweiz. Verstößt das eigentlich fast überall in den westlichen Demokratien gegen das Wirtschaftsstrafrecht. Aber das ist, glaube ich, immer wieder zu betonen, weil diese wichtigen Verbände wie die FIFA, wie das International-Olympische Komitee in der Schweiz sitzen und die Schweiz eben ein gelasches Wirtschaftsrecht hat, wurde das eben auch weiter nicht behandelt und nicht beachtet und damit entstand einfach eine riesige Blase an Dingen, die aufgearbeitet gehören. Deshalb ist das auch so groß geworden. Wenn man das früh klein anfängt zu bearbeiten, kommt es ja gar nicht zu solchen spektakulären Geschichten.
Und dann muss man dazu sagen, die Besonderheit der FIFA ist noch, ohne jetzt zu sehr in die Historie der FIFA einsteigen zu wollen, aber die Korruption, die das aneinanderknüpfen von ich kriege von dir die Vermarktungsrechte für ein Turnier und dafür zeige ich mich dir gegenüber, aber noch mal direkt erkenntlich, indem ich dir eine Kickbackzahlung, nennt man das dann, zukommen lasse. Das ist schon in der Historie der FIFA verankert und das Sportsponsoring, das vor allem über Adi und dann Horst Dassler etabliert wurde im Sport und der Fußball und damit auch die FIFA sind so eng miteinander verzahnt, dass es kaum zu trennen ist und weil aber dann so wahnsinnig viel Geld in den Fußball hinein gedrückt wurde fast schon durch die steigenden TV-Werbepreise, durch das wachsende Interesse am Sport, wurde das immer, immer mehr Geld und von Anfang an war es immer so, das Geld, das hier verteilt wird, da fließt auch immer etwas zurück an die Funktionäre, die damit zu tun haben und darum geht es dann letztlich auch in diesem Prozess, der jetzt dann in New York ja schon am Laufen ist und noch eine Weile laufen wird, dass man da eben dann anhand von Zahlungen mühsamer Ich glaube, dass ich in meiner jahrsamer und jahrelanger Kleinstarbeit ein paar Leuten Dinge nachweisen konnte, nämlich dass sie genau diese Bestechungszahlungen angenommen haben, dass es da unlautere Absprachen gab, dass es zum Teil Erpressungsversuche gab, Korruption im Gesamten ist das Thema dieses Prozesses. Und das hat man eben einer Reihe von Leuten, aber nicht allen nachweisen können. Und da laufen jetzt dann die Urteile. Und das alles, obwohl Sepp Blatter das hier sagt, das wird, glaube ich, so ein Running-Gag, dass ich diesen O-Ton immer wieder einspielerhaltig festjürgen.
Man kann doch den Fußball nicht verkaufen.
Ja, hat er gesagt. Der Sportschau gegenüber, jetzt gerade erst bei der Weltmeisterschaft 2018. Das ist der größte Witz aller Zeiten. Der Fußball wurde verkauft, wird verkauft werden. Und da hat er auch Sepp Blatter mutmaßlich zumindest in seiner Amtszeit ist da sehr viel passiert. Wie genau er da drin hängt, da reden wir gleich noch drüber. Sollen wir mal tiefer ins Thema reingehen, Jürgen? Jetzt sind wir, glaube ich, ein bisschen warm und auf Betriebstemperatur. Dann lass uns mal damit beginnen, dass wir die wichtigsten Personen und Verbände kurz vorstellen. Denn, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dieses Thema ist so komplex unter anderem, weil da so viele Leute dran beteiligt sind, von denen ihr vielleicht noch gar nicht so viel gehört habt. Das macht es für euch wahrscheinlich etwas anspruchsvoller, euch die ganzen Namen zu merken. Und wir wollen jetzt mal versuchen, euch ein bisschen ein akustisches Bild zu zeichnen von den allerwichtigsten Personen, damit später, wenn die Namen dann immer wieder fallen, ihr dann vielleicht ein Bild vor Augen habt und sagt, ach ja, richtig, darüber haben wir ja vor, sagen wir mal, eine halbe Stunde im Rasenfunk schon etwas gehört. Bei den Verbänden führ ich mal kurz durch, denn das ist das einfache. Die FIFA ist aufgeteilt in mehrere Verbände. In Konfederationen nennen die sich einen, davon kennen wir sehr gut. Das ist die UEFA. Darüber hinaus gibt es da noch den Ozeanischen Fußballverband, den Asiatischen Fußballverband und den Afrikanischen Fußballverband. Und jetzt zwei Verbände, auf die es im FIFA-Prozess besonders ankommt. Also jetzt gut zugehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und zwar zum einen gibt es den Südamerikanischen Fußballverband, bzw. da sind die einzelnen Nationen drin organisiert. Der heißt Comnebol. Das ist die Abkürzung dafür. Und geht einem etwas leichter über die Lippen. Es gibt den CONCACAF. Und das ist der Zusammenschluss der nordamerikanischen Staaten und der karibischen Staaten dazu. Dazu zählen im Fußball übrigens auch drei Staaten, die eigentlich auf dem südamerikanischen Kontinent liegen. So, kleiner Fun-Fact am Rande für ein absolut nerdiges Fußballquiz, den ich bei der Recherche dann aufarbeiten musste. Das war mir nämlich selber nicht klar. Jürgen, kannst du vielleicht mal ganz kurz erklären, diese Struktur der Verbände, warum hat das eine Bedeutung? Wie laufen denn Entscheidungen in der FIFA ab? Warum ist es da so interessant, dann zum Beispiel auf diesen nordamerikanischen und karibischen CONCACAF-Fußballverband zu gucken?
Die CONCACAF selber ist ein sehr seltsames Gebilde. Wenn man die Landkarte nicht ausbreitet, sieht das alles sehr logisch aus, aber in der inneren Struktur überhaupt nicht. Weil Nummer eins, die USA sind heute auch wirtschaftlich das gewichtigste Glied in diesem Ganzen. Sie haben ja auch als Schlepper die WM26 zugeteilt bekommen mit Mexiko und Kanada als kleine Begleitungsmusik. Diese ganze Geschichte ist total unausgewuchtet. Also USA riesengroß, dann die mittelamerikanischen Länder eher arm, aber Fußball begeistert seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Und die karibischen Länder relativ junge Staaten, klitzekleine Inseln, teilweise mit Einwohnern von 100.000, 200.000, 300.000, aber auch an Fußball interessiert. Und wenn man nun all diesen kleinen und großen Organisationen gestattet, dass sie nun als pseudodemokratische Einheit in einer sogenannten Konföderation sich zusammenschließen dürfen und damit Einfluss bekommen auf das große Gebilde, nämlich die FIFA, dann kann man vielleicht schon erkennen, dass vieles nicht einfach zusammenpasst. Ich bin kein Freund von Homogenisierung, das heißt, auch in der UEFA wird so ein Land wie Andorra oder Luxemburg oder Liechtenstein repräsentiert, aber da sind die Verhältnisse auch klar. Also kaum jemand aus diesen Ländern würde sich jetzt irgendwie anmaßen, über das große Ganze viel mitreden zu wollen. Die sind froh, wenn ein Spiel, was weiß ich, San Marino, wenn die Gäste kommen, oder jetzt das neueste Unding, ist ja Gibraltar oder so. Das ist alles okay, wenn man nur über den Fußball spricht und über das Durchziehen von Veranstaltungen oder von Turnieren. Aber wenn es um das Organisieren des ganzen Apparates geht und wer hat da welches Gewicht, wer hat da welche Stimmen, wer kann da Einfluss nehmen, dort wird es natürlich sehr wichtig zu verstehen, dass wenn sich viele Kleine in irgendeiner Weise ohne große eigene Kraft an etwas beteiligen können, dann entstehen eben auch mitunter Wünsche. Das Beispiel ist halt die Karriere von Jack Warner, den haben wir jetzt noch nicht erwähnt, aber der war lange dann FIFA-Vize-Präsident und hat sich hochgearbeitet von Trinidad und Tobago über die Conca Cuff und von der Conca Cuff aus in die FIFA-Spitze. Und er hat alle möglichen Karten gespielt in dieser Zeit, in der er diese Karriere gemacht hat, von als dunkelhäutiger Mensch zu behaupten, dass jede Kritikerin ihm rassistisch sei, als Angehörige eines kleinen Landes, dass die aus den großen Ländern immer auf die Kleinen runtergucken. Er hat immer diese komischen emotional angehauchten Überlegungen mit eingebracht, die nichts mit Fragen von Kompetenz, Sachverstand und auch Sauberkeit, ethischer Sauberkeit zu tun hatten. Und da ist diese Bühne Conca Cuff wirklich sehr viel einfacher nachzuvollziehen heute. Man wird das auch in anderen Konfederationen nachzeichnen können, aber man kann das heute aufgrund der Rolle der USA und dieser Verantwortung zu sagen, hier muss mal ein Strich gezogen werden, kann man das heute eben besser darstellen anhand der Conca Cuff.
Genau. Und das Wichtige dazu zu wissen ist eben, warum haben diese kleinen Länder überhaupt eine solche Bedeutung innerhalb der FIFA, weil unter anderem die FIFA-Präsidentenwahl so abläuft, dass jeder Fußballverband eine Stimme hat. Das heißt, die Cayman-Inseln haben das gleichwertige Stimmrecht zu den USA oder zum DFB oder zum spanischen Fußballverband. Und das hat natürlich die Auswirkung, dass man zum einen versucht, die Verbände hinter sich zu scharen, also in dem Fall, wenn man jetzt FIFA-Präsident werden möchte, in denen viele Länder sind, die viele Stimmen auf sich vereinen. Also Conca Cuff hat zum Beispiel 40 Mitglieder und insgesamt gibt es 202 Stimmen. Das heißt, das ist dann schon ein ordentlicher Brocken. Und hat aber natürlich den Subtext, das an sich wäre ja noch nichts schlimm, man könnte sagen, das ist gelebte Demokratie, dass der kleine Staat Montserrat oder Lichtenstein genauso viel Mitspracherecht hat wie eben zum Beispiel Brasilien. Das Problem ist aber natürlich, dass bei so kleinen Staaten es noch einfacher ist, durch Gefälligkeiten, durch politische Vorteile, durch finanzielle Vorteile eben die wesentlich zu beeinflussen. Also wenn eben eine kleine Insel aus dem FIFA Development Program 1, 5 Millionen Dollar zugeschanzt bekommt innerhalb von wenigen Jahren und die gleiche Summe landet auch beim DFB, dann ist dem DFB das nicht so wichtig wie diesem kleinen Land. Und deshalb ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass man sich da Stimmen kaufen kann. Und das wurde jetzt auch schon genügend dokumentiert, dass man das so stehen lassen kann und spielt auch in diesem FIFA-Prozess dann eine Rolle.
Wenn ich vielleicht versuche, mal noch eine kleine Verbindung herzustellen. Wir haben bei der Conker Cup die interessante Situation gehabt. Der Generalsekretär kommt aus den USA, Chuck Blaser, jahrelang. Der Präsident kommt aus Trinidad, Jack Warner, jahrelang. Und die spielen sich die Bälle zu. Und es sind im Grunde zwei einäugige, zwei einbeinige, die USA mit einer nicht ausgeprägten Fußballkultur, in der solche Leute wie Chuck Blaser nach oben kommen können, weil sie verdienstvoll sind in den Augen der Amerikaner. Und jemand wie Jack Warner, der sicherlich sehr viel schlitzohriger ist und war als Chuck Blaser. Aber die beiden haben sich da wirklich gut verstanden. Und Blaser, deutlich kann man also heute sehr gut nachvollziehen, sein Interesse war überall mitzuverdienen. Das war der Mr. 10%. Der kriegte von jedem Deal, den er einfädelte, was ab. Und Jack Warner machte seine eigenen Geschäfte, können wir noch drüber reden. Und die anderen haben einfach nur zugeschaut. Im Vorstand der Conker Cup zu jener Zeit, als es am schlimmsten zuging, saß ein Mann namens Sunil Gulati. Der war dann jahrelang Präsident des amerikanischen Fußballverbandes und hat sich hochgearbeitet und ist heute in dem Council, dem Rat, dem obersten Aufsichtsorgan der FIFA und hat Infantino geholfen, im zweiten Wahlgang durchzukommen. Hat ihm geholfen, Leute rauszuschmeißen, die auf Infantinos komische Geschäfte achten sollen. Nicht ein neues Fass aufmachen, aber ich will nur sagen, da lässt sich wirklich einiges ganz gut dran erklären oder auch illustrieren.
Genau, an diesem Verband des Conker Cuffs. Dazu ist auch noch wichtig zu wissen, das haben wir vorhin schon angedeutet, als ich diesen Transparenzpunkt bei der FIFA gemacht habe, das kann man auch zum Beispiel auf einen Verband wie den Conker Cuff übertragen und das ist jetzt inzwischen nachhaltig dokumentiert. Da wusste zum Beispiel auch die Führung des Conker Cuffs, die wussten jahrelang gar nicht, wie viel Geld eigentlich Chuck Placer sich als Generalsekretär rauszieht. Die wussten gar nicht, um welche Summen es da eigentlich geht. Es war Jack Warner möglich, dass er FIFA-Gelder, die an den Conker Cuff gehen sollten, auf ein Konto überwiesen wurden, das zwar die Abkürzung Conker Cuff hatte, das aber sein privates Konto war. Das heißt, man weiß dann bei manchen Stellen nicht so genau, was wussten sie, was wussten sie nicht, wo gab es dann vielleicht doch wieder eine versteckte Zahlung. Aber diese ganzen Gebilde sind so intransparent, also solche Sauhaufen, ehrlich gesagt, dass es auch wirklich dann möglich war überhaupt, dass da einige wenige sich an die Spitze bereichern konnten und dann etablieren sich Strukturen, in denen Schmiergelzahlungen, Korruption zum Tagesgeschäft gehören und zwar insofern zum Tagesgeschäft, dass wir einen brasilianischen Fußballverbandspräsidenten zum Beispiel haben, bei dem dann im Laufe des FIFA-Prozesses rauskam. Der hat durch Schmiergeldzahlungen mehr Geld monatlich verdient über eine 5-Jahresperiode als über sein normales Gehalt. Und es wird aber von allen Akteuren in dem Bereich mit eingepreist. Man kann jetzt nicht glauben, wir zwei könnten jetzt den Rasenfunk-Fernsehsender gründen und könnten sagen, wir kaufen uns jetzt die WM-Rechte. Ohne Schmiergeldzahlungen ist das einfach nicht mehr möglich. So funktioniert nichts mehr in der FIFA, nicht im ConquerCraft, nicht in allen Verbänden. Und der ConquerCraft wird uns jetzt beschäftigen. Also merkt euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da geht es um den Nordamerikanischen Fußballverband mit den Karibischen Inseln mit dazu. Das heißt, merkt euch einfach grob Nordamerika und die lustigen Inseln, die da so liegen. Und da werden wir jetzt noch viel drüber sprechen. Und der zweite wichtige Fußballverband im Zuge dieses FIFA-Prozesses ist der Comnebol. Das sind die südamerikanischen Länder, also Argentinien, Brasilien und wie sie alle heißen, sind da mit drin. Jetzt haben wir schon angefangen, Jürgen, dass wir schon mit Namen um uns geschmissen haben. Es war auch völlig klar, dass wir mit vielen Namen reden wollen. Über einen würde ich jetzt gerne am Anfang sprechen, weil ich nicht weiß, wie häufig wir im weiteren Verlauf der Sendung noch überentsprechen werden. Nämlich Sepp Blatter. Ist der denn von dieser Untersuchung eigentlich betroffen?
Wir haben alle spekuliert, als die inzwischen zwei Anklageschriften, die das amerikanische Justizministerium und die Staatsanwaltschaft in Brooklyn rausgegeben haben. Da taucht dann leicht anonymisiert, tauchen bestimmte Figuren auf. Die sollen im Stil dieser amerikanischen Anklageschriften erklären, wer mit wem, wer gegen wen, wer wusste was. Aber die, die nicht angeklagt werden, werden auch nicht namentlich genannt. Und in der Tradition dieser Anklageschriften werden sie einfach durchnummeriert. Das heißt, wenn sie immer wieder neu auftauchen in einer Anklageschrift, werden sie als Nummer immer wieder mit abgerufen. Und es gibt eben zwei Personen, die als sogenannte unindicted co-conspirators, als nicht-angeklagte Mitverschwörer eingestuft wurden in dieser großen Verschwörung, die dort ja aufgeblättert wurde. Und man kann einfach anhand der Anhaltspunkte, die da gesetzt werden, davon ausgehen, dass es sich in einem Fall um Sepp Blatter handelt und in einem anderen Fall um Jerome Walck. Und das heißt, in dem Moment, in dem diese Feststellung von der Staatsanwaltschaft getroffen wird, nur, okay, in dem Moment sind sie nicht angeklagt. In dem Moment hat man nichts gegen sie vorzubringen, was viele Dinge bedeuten kann. Es kann bedeuten, dass das umkippt, dass es auch in dieser großen Gemengelage passiert. Da wurde eine Frau, die in der ersten Anklageschrift noch als anindeitet, als nicht angeklagt geführt und nummeriert war, die wurde in der – das Puzzle wurde in der zweiten Anklageschrift aufgelöst, da war sie mit angeklagt und hatte aber schon bereits gestanden. Man muss allerdings, nachdem wir vom Zeitrahmen her – wir reden ja jetzt von Dingen, die 2015 aufgedeckt und ausgelöst wurden und jetzt haben wir 2018 und wir haben auch ganz viele Geständnisse und wir haben einen Prozess gehabt, in dem Leute, die gesagt haben, nein, wir sind unschuldig, versucht haben, sich zu verteidigen. Wir haben im Grunde diesen Teil – nennen wir es mal Beweisaufnahme, das ist jetzt sachlich nicht ganz korrekt, Juristen werden das hoffentlich verzeihen – aber diesen Teil haben wir jetzt quasi hinter uns und man muss davon ausgehen, dass Blatter, was die USA angeht und die Geschichten, die dort gelaufen sind, erstmal vom Haken ist. Wobei ein Faktor sicherlich ist – und ich bitte wieder um Entschuldigung, es wird kompliziert – wir haben noch einige sehr heiße Typen, die wehren sich gegen die Auslieferung aus ihren Heimatländern. Das ist Jack Warner aus Trinidad und das ist Nicolas Leos in Paraguay. Die waren sehr nah dran an Blatter. Das heißt, wenn irgendetwas, was die jetzt gestehen würden, wenn sie tatsächlich mal irgendwann in die Fänge der amerikanischen Justiz geraten, wenn die etwas gestehen würden, das Blatter belastet, dann wäre ich ganz sicher, dass Blatter auch noch dran kommt. Aber wir reden ja auch von relativ alten Herren. Leos war schon öfter im Krankenhaus. Blatter ist auch schon über 80. Er sieht auch schon etwas wackeliger aus. Jetzt die Bilder aus Russland. Theoretisch, der ist, glaube ich, nicht vom Haken. Und die andere Sache ist die, da haben wir es noch gar nicht gesprochen, in der Schweiz läuft seit 2015 OVONNE, ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Aktivitäten aus der FIFA. Da wurden also Computerdateien beschlagnahmt und mitgenommen und ausgewertet, hoffentlich inzwischen. Und was dort dokumentiert ist, kann nach dem milden Schweizer Wirtschaftsstrafrecht allerdings auch in Anklageform führen. Das kann ich nicht so gut abschätzen. Blatter selber hat ja jetzt angedeutet, dass er wohl glaubt, da kommt er irgendwie gut bei rum. Kann ja sein. Es gibt ja das Konzept, bitte hilf mir mit der deutschen Übersetzung, plausible deniability. Also diese Aktivität, wo du als Vorgesetzter immer versuchst, klar zu machen. Also ich habe davon nichts gewusst, ich habe nichts mehr zu tun gehabt, das haben andere gemacht.
Nachvollziehbare Unkenntnis, würde ich jetzt mal so übersetzen.
Und wenn man das also als Chef von irgendeiner Geschichte konsequent durchzieht, dann kann man natürlich über diese Art von Dummheit durchkommen. Es gibt zwar den Grundsatz, Dummheit schützt vor Strafe nicht, aber wenn es darum geht, das Wirtschaftsstrafrecht da in der Schweiz, das sagt an einigen Stellen, dass man dir nachweisen muss, dass du mit Absicht, also mit Vorsatz, mit Plan gehandelt hast. Und wenn du das nicht nachweisen kannst, alle irgendwie die mit der Achsel zucken, dann kommt natürlich nichts dabei rum. Und insofern kann es sein, dass Blatter Recht hat, dass er als Person nichts mehr befürchten muss.
Ergibt sich zumindest nach außen hin sehr entspannt und mit der üblichen Lamor Jans, die man von Sepp Blatter über die Jahre hinweg schon gewohnt ist. Der ARD hat im gleichen Interview, aus dem ich vorhin schon zitiert habe, auch das hier gesagt.
Etwas ist schiefgelaufen, ist auch mein Fehler. Wer nie etwas macht, macht keine Fehler.
Wer viel macht, macht ab und zu Fehler.
Das ist natürlich gut, wenn Bestechungszahlungen im Wert von über 100 Millionen Franken, wie es dann zum Beispiel rund um den ISL-Skandal, das war der Sportvermarkter der FIFA, mit dem man eng zusammenarbeitet, der im Grunde an seinen eigenen Schmiergeldzahlungen dann zu Grunde ging, insuvent ging und da wurde ganz viel aufgedeckt. Wenn man so etwas, bloß noch die Dinge, über die wir sprechen, als kleinen Fehler beschreiben kann, dann ist man vielleicht auch ein in sich ruhender Mann. Das muss man Blatter zumindest zugute halten. Ja, wollen wir vielleicht noch kurz reinhören, was er dem Channel 4 Interviewer Alex Thompson gesagt hat? Was fällt dir denn als Beobachter von diesen Prozessen und auch von Sepp Blatter mit einem profunden Wissen rund um die Geschehnisse in der FIFA? Was fällt dir ein zu solchen Aussagen von Sepp Blatter?
Der letzte Satz, ich hoffe, den haben jetzt auch alle auf Englisch gut verstehen können. Also er behauptet, er hat nichts falsch gemacht. Er hat also im Grunde gegen keine Regeln verstoßen und sagt, dass die Schweizer Justiz die Sache jetzt zum Ende bringen wird. Das ist so ein bisschen an der eigentlichen Thematik immer vorbei geredet. Also das gehört so ein bisschen in die Wolkenschieberfraktion. Im Grunde geht es nicht um diese Fragen, so wie du es ja auch schon gesagt hast. Also große Straftaten werden zu kleinen Fehlern runtergerechnet und hier wird einfach Nebel erzeugt. Er könnte sagen und hat sich also Thompson in dem relativ ausführlichen Interview aber auch nachgefragt. Dabei hat er natürlich auch nicht immer genau auf den Punkt gefragt, sondern der wollte ihn auch zum Reden bringen. Das merkt man ja auch, ist auch eine Okay-Geschichte mit Fernsehkamera oder mit Radiomikrofon. Wir kriegen von Blatter eigentlich nur immer so ein Gerede. Das ist kein greifbares Zeug. Ich nehme mal an, ich kenne ihn ja noch nicht seit all diesen ganzen Jahren. Ich nehme mal an, er hat noch nie anders gearbeitet. Er hat immer versucht, den Charmeur zu geben. Es gibt genug Aufnahmen von ihm, wie er da auftritt. Er hat immer versucht, ein bestimmtes Image zu kreieren und zu porträtieren. Er hat sich natürlich in den ganzen kleinen Kämpfen rund um seine Position und seine Wiederwahl und hat sich natürlich immer wieder als relativ kaltblütiger Taktiker mit einem Lächeln im Knopfloch gezeigt. Das heißt unter anderem, warum wir an irgendeiner Stelle an eine bestimmte Gemengelage kommen, wo der Druck größer wird, das aufzuklären, liegt auch an Blatter. Das ist seine Wiederwahl 2011, als er ursprünglich angedeutet hatte, nein, er macht jetzt Schluss, er will nicht mehr. Und dann gibt er plötzlich wieder seinen Hut mit rein.
Er hat einen Seehofer gemacht, wie wir es hier in Bayern nennen.
Und dann ärgern sich Leute, die denken, sie sind langsam mal dran. Sie haben immer gewartet und in Ruhe gelassen. Und dann kommt ein Gegenkandidat wie Mohammed bin Hammam aus Katar. Und der muss nun erkennen, was sind jetzt für Mächte und Kräfte am Werk? Wie kann ich nun diesen Blatter schlagen? Und der findet in Jack Warner in Trinidad einen Partner. Und dort kommt es dann zu einer Aktion in der Karibik 2011 im Rahmen dieses Wahlkampfes, wo Leute bestochen werden sollen.
Moment mal, Sie haben doch nur Umschläge mit 40.000 Dollar in Cash bekommen. Das ist doch einfach nur ein Gastgeschenk gewesen.
So wird es natürlich immer wieder auch verkauft. Wobei, da sind schon allein Trinidad Gesetze verstoßen worden. Weil wie kommt dieses Geld ins Land? Mit welchen Koffern? Natürlich war dieser Jack Warner auch Politiker und hatte also in Trinidad wieder Möglichkeiten, beim Zoll und bei der Einreisebehörde darauf zu achten, dass Binnenheim mit seinem Flugzeug ganz anders behandelt wird als ein normaler Besucher. Jedenfalls ist im Grunde das, was in vielen kriminellen, sich entwickelnden Prozessen immer wieder der Fall ist. Irgendwann wissen diese Leute ja nicht mehr, wann sie aufhören sollten. Sie könnten ja gehen. Herr Löw könnte ja zurücktreten. Der Bihoff könnte ja zurücktreten. Sie könnten ja alle sagen, okay, danke, ich habe einiges geschafft, ich habe was geleistet, ich höre auf. Das sollen jetzt die nächste Gruppe von Leuten machen. Nein, das ist irgendwie nicht eingebaut im Denken dieser Leute. Sie haben bestimmte Ansprüche. Also muss Herr Blatter weitermachen, denkt er. Also kommt es zu einer Opposition, die sich aber nicht anders zu helfen weiß, weil sie kennt ja das System Blatter. In dem System Blatter wurde mit Geld gearbeitet. Also muss man wohl auch mit Geld arbeiten, um Blatter zu stürzen. Und dann passiert eben etwas, was nicht vorgesehen ist, dass jemand das aufnimmt, wie Jack Warner in dieser karibischen Fußballfunktionärskonferenz den Leuten erklärt, hier gibt es jetzt Geld und wenn jemand da was gegen hat, dann soll er das halt quasi ihm zurückgeben.
Genau.
Und das wird aufgenommen von jemanden, ich tippe mal so iPhone Qualität und wird an die Öffentlichkeit gespielt. Und das ist dann der erste klitzekleine Stein oder der Teil, der diese Lawine ins Rollen bringt. Und in dem Moment ist es nicht unwichtig, darauf aufmerksam zu machen, welche Personen spielen eine Rolle. Aber ich glaube, es ist genauso wichtig zu verstehen, ja, es gibt in unseren frei organisierten gesellschaftlichen Prozessen, es gibt auch andere Kräfte, die da wirken können. Und es ist nicht unbedingt die Moral, die Ethik, die Ehrlichkeit, sondern es ist wieder, okay, jemand hat eigene Interessen und will gegen die Interessen der anderen vorgehen.
Es ist Politik durch und durch.
Ja, es ist Politik. Aber natürlich muss man trotzdem, glaube ich, immer auf die Personen zu sprechen kommen. Ich will das jetzt nicht ins Abstrakte reinreden. Man muss ja aber auch was zu beißen haben.
Ja, vor allem das Interessante wäre, wenn wir jetzt komplett weg von den Personen gingen ins Abstrakte, dann würden wir genau das Gegenteilige von der Argumentation machen, die Sepp Blatter selber immer aufmacht. Also die Argumente, mit denen er sich als unwissender, nicht von diesen ganzen Skandalen Befleckter stilisiert, die hat er auch unter anderem in diesem Channel 4 Interview nochmal zusammengefasst. Wir hören mal kurz rein.
Ist es eine honeste Organisation?
Ich denke, dass die Organisation immer ehrlich ist.
Ja, die Organisation von FIFA.
Aber die Individuen sind nicht ehrlich.
Also das war das Problem.
Und das war das Problem.
Aber du warst für 17 Jahre in Befehl, als diese Individuen nicht ehrlich waren?
Also genau das Gegenteil von dem, was wir gerade gesagt haben. Sepp Blatter wiederholt mantraartig nicht die Institutionen, nicht die Verbände, nicht die FIFA selbst ist korrupt, sondern nur einzelne Personen innerhalb der FIFA. Und da könne er ja dann als Präsident auch nichts dafür. Und ich glaube, wir können das einfach mal so stehen lassen und den Hörern und Hörern dann den Hörauftrag geben. Hört euch jetzt einfach den Rest dieser Sendung an und erinnert euch dann noch mal kurz, vielleicht spiele ich es auch noch mal ein, an dieses Zitat zurück und dann, wie glaubhaft kann das wirklich sein? Und ist das richtig oder überhaupt noch nachvollziehbar, wenn man sagt, das waren jetzt ganz, ganz viele bedauerliche Einzelfälle, die es da innerhalb der FIFA gab. Aber der Verband hat damit natürlich nichts zu tun. Schwierige Argumentationen. Ich würde sagen, Jürgen, wir machen mal weiter und kommen zu einem Namen, den wir gerade auch schon genannt haben, nämlich Chuck Blazer. Was ist denn zu dem zu sagen? Wie würdest du den einführen, hier in dieses Kriminalstück?
Also erst mal rein über die Optik ein übergewichtiger Herr, der nur noch auf Scootern durch New York gefahren ist. Also der konnte gar nicht mehr richtig laufen. Auffällig auch sein wuscheliger, graumilierter, lockiger Kopf. Und der, glaube ich, sich selber auch als Typ gesehen hat. Der hat so eine extrovertierte Note gehabt, sicherlich immer sehr charmant, sehr freundlich und kommt aus bescheideneren Kreisen, hat sich aber dann in der frühen Phase des amerikanischen Fußballs – es gibt ja diese Periode, die für uns immer mit dem Namen Beckenbauer und dieser Operettenliga verbunden ist und Cosmos New York – da kommt Chuck Blazer so in den kommerziellen Fußball mit rein. Da ist ja noch keine große Nummer, aber da wird er so langsam einer der Mitstricker und der dann in der nächsten Phase, als es darum geht, so langsam den amerikanischen Fußball doch noch weiterzuentwickeln, da ist er halt schon mal in einer etwas besseren Position und kommt dann über den amerikanischen Verband eben in diese Generalsekretärs Rolle einer Föderation, Konfederation, Konkerkampf, die eben zu dem Zeitpunkt auch im Grunde so gut wie gar nichts ist. Also außer Mexiko ein wirklich ernsthaftes Fußballland, das ja nun auch zwei Weltmeisterschaften ausgerichtet hat, oder habe ich mich erzählt, also außer denen sind da wirklich nur Anfänger, aber die kommen halt miteinander irgendwie zurecht und Blazer wirkt wohl seriös und so weiter und so fort und ist halt dann jahrelang in der Lage, sich über diese Position der wachsenden Einnahmen, weil die Fernsehrechte im Konker-Kaff-Bereich werden immer interessanter, die Vermarktungsmöglichkeiten werden interessanter, weil die USA eben immer mehr mitspielt, Klammer auf, amerikanische Firmen wie Coca-Cola, wie McDonalds, wie Budweiser sind ja heute wahnsinnig wichtige Sponsoren weltweit für die FIFA, das heißt nichts für den amerikanischen Fußball, aber es zeigt, dass es in den USA Leute gibt, die sehr wohl den Wert von Fußball als Das ist ein Thema, das wir als vermarktungswürdiges Gut erkennen können. Aus diesem Milieu kommt eben jemand wie Blazer und kann sich dann da erst mal gut einrichten. Innerhalb dieses Rahmens wirkt er total wichtig und seriös und wird dann auch etwas später ja auch sogar Mitglied des Exekutivkomitees und hat damit auch eine Rolle bei der Vergabe von Weltmeisterschaften und so weiter.
Genau, das Exekutivkomitee ist das entscheidende Gremium innerhalb der FIFA, das eben zum Beispiel über WM-Vergaben entscheidet und auch alle finanziellen Entscheidungen absegnet in seiner Finanzkommission. Früher hatte das 25 Mitglieder, das heißt, hatte man da die Mehrheit aus irgendwelchen Gründen bekommen, dann konnte man die WM bei sich ausrichten. Inzwischen gibt es einen FIFA-Rat, der ein bisschen größer ist. Das war eine der in Anführungszeichen Reformen, die Gianni Infantino zur FIFA gebracht hat. Chuck Blazer, also stellt ihn euch wirklich wie einen riesigen Luftballon vor oder wie den Weihnachtsmann auf Diabetes 2, was insofern ein etwas bitterer Witz ist, weil Chuck Blazer tatsächlich Typ 2 Diabetes hatte, unglaublich rund dieser Mann, um es sozusagen – Spitzname TheBelly. Das heißt, immer wenn wir von Chuck Blazer reden, denkt ihr euch einfach einen ganz, ganz aus der Form geratenen Weihnachtsmann. Dann seid ihr, um es sozusagen, sehr nah dran an der Wahrheit. Chuck Blazer hat eine unglaubliche Erscheinung. Es gibt ein paar Bilder mit ihm zusammen, mit Sepp Blatter. Da wirkt es fast, als wäre Sepp Blatter als Maßstab für einen gewöhnlichen Menschen neben Chuck Blazer gestellt worden, so wie man sich vor eine große Statue stellt, um zu zeigen, wie groß die eigentlich ist. Also unglaublich dick, um es sozusagen, der dicke Mann des Fußballs. Und du hast es schon angesprochen, von Anfang an hat er ganz gut gewusst, wie auch Geld in seine eigene Tasche fließt. Er war Mr. 10%, das heißt von allen 100 Dollar, die der CONCACAF eingenommen hat, also der nordamerikanische karibische Fußballverband, hat er zehn bekommen. Das wussten die ganz lange auch nicht, ist natürlich auch ein sehr guter Deal. Und an der Stelle müssen wir vielleicht einmal kurz einen Mechanismus einführen, wie man im Fußball eigentlich Geld verdienen kann. Wir haben schon über TV-Rechte gesprochen und dazu gehört aber auch, dass Erfinden oder Vermarkten von Turnieren. Im Fall von Chuck Blazer, er hat den Gold Cup damals erfunden, wo eben die die entsprechenden Verbandsmitglieder gegeneinander in ein Turnier gehen und dann die Rechte an diesem Gold Cup, die werden dann vermarktet. Das heißt die Übertragungsrechte, die Sponsoringrechte, die Marketingrechte und so weiter und so fort. Und für diese Rechte, deren Wert exorbitant gestiegen ist – am Anfang war es noch überhaupt kein Erfolg dieser erste Gold Cup – aber innerhalb der 90er, mit der ganzen Werbeentwicklung im Fernsehmarkt, sind dafür die Einnahmen in Unsummen eigentlich reingestiegen. Und damit waren immer Schmiergerzeitungen verbunden. Das darf man nie vergessen. Und wenn ihr euch mal irgendwann fragt, warum wurden zum Beispiel die Weltmeisterschaften ständig erweitert, das waren ganz oft oder eigentlich fast immer, war das, weil gerade eine FIFA- Präsidentenwahl anstand und jemand musste gewinnen und hat dann den kleineren Verbänden gesagt, hey, aber ihr habt da mal die Chance auf die Weltmeisterschaft. Das ist doch klasse und es gibt noch mehr Geld für euch. Und so ist das auch bei diesen Turnieren. Also egal, ob es die Copa America ist, die Copa Libertadores, der Gold Cup. Immer das war das Vehikel, die Vermarktungsrechte daran, um richtig, richtig viel Geld zu verdienen und das hat Chuck Blazer, dieser überdimensionierte Weihnachtsmann, auch gemacht. Ja, nach der Kirchbleitate hat er übrigens auch ganz gerne die UEFA ein bisschen beraten und hat auch den Konfett Cup erfunden. Habe ich zumindest in einer Quelle gelesen. Da geht aber so die Geschichtsschreibung ein bisschen auseinander. Also, den haben wir ihm auch noch zu verdanken. Lass uns über Jack Warner sprechen. Was ist zudem noch zu sagen, außer dessen, was wir schon angesprochen haben?
Ja, dass er eigentlich überall, wo er aktiv geworden ist, im Fußball für sich selber abgegriffen hat. Er hat die Trinidad Nationalmannschaft, die 2006 die WM-Qualifikation geschafft hat, was ja eine sehr große Leistung war für so ein kleines Fußballland. Er hat die Spieler abgezockt, denen wurde also Geld versprochen, weil die FIFA schüttet ja aus an den Verband, je nach Leistung, und da hätte den Spielern einiges zugestanden. Dem mussten sie teilweise vergeblich jahrelang nachrennen, diesem Geld, was er schriftlich zugesagt hatte. Er hat beim Verkauf von Eintrittskarten bei Weltmeisterschaften schon früh angefangen, die Hand drauf zu halten und zu gucken, dass er da immer mitverdient. Weil es gibt natürlich auch Kontingente zu kriegen. Das kann man bei der FIFA irgendwie einrichten, wenn man da oben mitmischt. Dann hat er sich die Fernsehrechte als Makler, quasi die Fernsehrechte von Sepp Blatter für einen symbolischen Dollar zuschustern lassen und sie dann weiter verhökert.
Und zwar an WM-Spielen, also nicht irgendwelche U17-sonstigen Turniere, sondern es ging da um Weltmeisterschaftstv-Rechte, die nie im Leben einen diesen geringen Wert haben. Also völlig absolvus.
Aber der Clou im Fall von Jack Warner ist wirklich, und das wurde dann, nachdem die Conker Cuff angefangen hat, zumindestens also nach dieser einen Aktion mit Hermann und den Briefen voller Geld, voller 40.000 Dollar, als dann also mit etwas Verzögerung versucht wurde, intern aufzuräumen, da kam heraus, dass Jack Warner in seinen Rollen als Präsident der Conker Cuff die Organisation jahrelang belogen hatte. Er hat es geschafft, fertig zu bringen, ein Gelände in Trinidad zu besitzen, dass also unter Scheinen, also auch dort werden ja Immobilienbesitz wird ja öffentlich notiert, das gibt es ja in irgendwelchen Ämtern, kann man ja nachgucken, wem gehört hier was, aber das wurde alles verschleiert von ihm, es gehörte ihm also das Gelände und auf diesem Gelände wurde mit Hilfe von ConkerCuff-Geld, aber hauptsächlich mit FIFA-Geld, wurde da ein Sportzentrum mit Hotel eingerichtet, das qua Realität jetzt ihm gehört, obwohl er also immer intern so getan hat, als wäre es eine ConkerCuff-Veranstaltung. Also haben die in der ConkerCuff alle geglaubt, naja, also die hat die ConkerCuff, baut sich jetzt quasi eine Immobilie auf Trinidad.
Du hattest auch immer gesagt, das war quasi seine DFB-Akademie, um so ein bisschen den Vergleich zu ziehen, ohne dass ich sagen will, dass die DFB-Akademie ähnlich dubios aufgebaut wäre, aber dass diese Bedeutung hatte, dieses, dieses Gebäude innerhalb des kompletten Verbandes.
Ja, aber das ist nun wirklich, wenn man das möchte, also so sehe ich das auf jeden Fall, das ist wirklich der verkommenste und der geschickteste Schachtzug überhaupt in der ganzen Geschichte von, von FIFA Betrug, also bis, dagegen sind ja diese, weiß ich nicht, Bargeld unterm, unterm Tisch in irgendeiner Bar in Miami oder so, das sind ja fast schlichte Geschichten, ja, der Motto, okay, wir müssen nicht drüber reden, aber hier, da muss ja richtig viel kriminelle Energie aufgewendet werden, um das zu schaffen. Da müssen Bruchhalter eingeweiht gewesen sein und bestochen worden sein, die also hauptsächlich Freunde von Warner auf Trinidad. Da müssen Leute in der FIFA alle ihre Augen, inklusive ihrer Hühneraugen, zu gehabt haben, um zu erkennen, dass sie irgendwas falsch läuft. Und da kommt auch eigentlich Sepp Blatter nicht aus der Nummer raus, denn spätestens in dem Moment, in dem feststeht, dass die FIFA von Warner betrogen worden ist, müsste ein Anwalt in Trinidad, in Port of Spain, vor Gerichten auftauchen und sagen, hallo, ja, wir sind betrogen worden. Das ist auch ein Verbrechen nach trinidadischem Recht. Wir müssten das entweder das Geld wiederbekommen oder wir müssten diese Anlage bekommen. Das ist nicht passiert.
Ja, aber Jürgen, Jürgen, du weißt doch.
Etwas ist schiefgelaufen, ist auch mein Fehler. Wer nie etwas macht, macht keine Fehler.
Wer viel macht, macht ab und zu Fehler.
Jetzt bitte, kleiner Fehler. Es ist wirklich abstrus. Und um das kurz, also du hast ja gerade fast schon deinen Hut gezogen vor der kriminellen Energie von Jack Warner, um das kurz zu illustrieren anhand eines Beispiels. Wie hat er zum Beispiel all die Zahlungen der FIFA für dieses Gebäude, das angeblich dem Verband gehört, aber ihm gehört, wie hat er die bekommen auf ein Konto, das hat Andrew Jennings aufgedeckt in seinem Buch Dirty Game. Das hatte die initialen CONCACAF, also CONCACAF, aber war halt gar kein CONCACAF Konto, sondern es war nur danach benannt. Also er war auch sehr kreativ in der Art und Weise, wie er da Geld verdienen konnte und hat die Hand aufgehalten, wo es ging und war aber immer schon neben den Dingen, die du vorhin schon angesprochen hast, von wegen, dass er auch, also wir haben ja, sie sind ja alle nicht schlecht darin, sich zu verteidigen und du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, Jack Warner hat dann gerne auch mal Rassismuskarten oder sonstige Karten auf den Tisch gelegt, damit er sich Kritik erwehren kann. Er war aber auch zeitweise dann Minister für nationale Sicherheit in Trinidad und Tobago, hatte damit dann diplomatische Immunität. Ein ganz, ganz interessantes Kapitel innerhalb dieses FIFA-Prozesses ist diese Phase, als er eben diesen Ministerprosten innen hatte. Das ist in sofern dann auch noch nicht verwunderlich, dass er zwar angeklagt ist, aber noch nicht ausgeliefert wurde. Das verwundert einen, je länger man sich mit dieser Figur beschäftigt, immer weniger. Der Mann lebt im Grunde auf seinem eigenen Planeten, hat sich seine Insel, also für ihn ist die Insel riesig groß, weil er da alles hat, Geld, Reichtum, Macht und dementsprechend kann ihm die Welt außen rum eigentlich ziemlich egal sein.
Ja, nur vielleicht zum aktuellen Stand. Die Regierung, also seine Partei, hatte eine Koalition und so konnte er da auch Minister werden. Diese Koalition wurde abgewählt vor einer Weile, aber schon vorher war klar, dass das Auslieferungsabkommen zwischen den USA und Trinidad und Tobago davon ausgehen muss, dass so jemand ausgeliefert werden kann. Es ist unüblich, dass Länder, die ihre eigenen Staatsbürger ausliefern, etwas, was Sepp Blatter, wenn er in der Schweiz bliebe, nicht passieren kann. Die Schweizer liefern nicht aus an andere Länder, die Deutschen liefern ihre Staatsbürger nicht an andere Länder aus, es sei dann innerhalb der EU unter ganz bestimmten sehr, sehr engen Gesichtspunkten. Aber das Auslieferungsabkommen zwischen den USA und Trinidad und Tobago ist völlig klar. Aber das läuft jetzt gerade noch durch den internen Trinidad-Gerichtsweg, weil sich natürlich Warner dagegen wert ausgeliefert zu werden. Und solche Verfahren sind auch sehr mühsam und lang und werden wahrscheinlich bis zu einem höchstrichterlichen Punkt gebracht werden, weil da gibt es natürlich auch eine Menge Präzedenzaspekte, also wie die Auslegung dieses Abkommens, was die betrifft und so weiter. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir das alle nicht erleben, das er ausgeliefert ist, ist relativ hoch. Aber die Hoffnung, glaube ich, stirbt als Letztes. Und deshalb kann es sein, ja, dazu kommt, eines hat nicht geklappt, also seine beiden Söhne waren auch mit involviert. Waren auch involviert in in seine Machenschaften und wurden in den USA festgesetzt, weil sie, Warner-Familie, ist auch Besitzer einer, mehr oder mehr, glaube ich sogar Immobilien in Florida. Und die haben halt dort immer mal wieder nach dem Rechten geschaut und bei der Gelegenheit, weil das FBI schon sehr weit war mit den Ermittlungen, haben sie die halt festgesetzt und haben auch da Kooperationsbereitschaft gefunden. Und auch das hat leider nichts geholfen. Also dieser Jack Warner sah nun seine Rolle als Vater gegenüber seinen Söhnen nicht so, dass er sich da in irgendeiner Weise nett zeigt oder so und die vielleicht dann aus der Podcastshow holt. Der Mann sitzt auf seiner Wolke. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du dich daran erinnerst, wir hatten ja eine großartige Sendung von John Oliver, Last Week Tonight, auf HBO, wo er sich mit Jack Warner beschäftigt hat und ihn veräppelt hat. Und dann sieht man in der nächsten Folge, wie Warner auf so etwas eingeht. Oliver hat nicht nur jetzt in seiner Sendung über etwas gesprochen, sondern hat auch noch eine Anzeige oder einen Werbespot geschaltet in Trinidad. Also im Grunde sein Terrain betreten. Und das hat Warner natürlich nicht gepasst. Also hat er das Gefühl, er muss antworten.
Mal kurz reinhören, was John Oliver da an Jack Warner gesagt hat. John Oliver dürften ja auch einige Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen.
Ich bete dir, alles zu verlassen, denn hier ist mein Argument.
Und das hat dann Jack Warner zum Anlass genommen, den Otto habe ich jetzt nicht mit dabei, aber in einem langen und dramatischen Video hat er sich vor die Kamera gesetzt und gesagt, er lässt sich nicht von irgendeinem Comedian-Fool sagen, was er zu tun habe. Und das wiederum hat dann schon Oliver sehr humoristisch verarbeitet. Aber das zeigt ganz gut die Geisteshaltung, deswegen hast du ja auch, glaube ich, dieses Beispiel genannt. Also Jack Warner, stellt ihn euch vor als denjenigen, der ganz, ganz nah dran und ganz lange schon mit dabei ist, an Sepp Blatter auch zum Beispiel, der wirklich an allen Ecken und Enden innerhalb des Conker Cuff Geld sich abgezweigt hat und der es tatsächlich auch geschafft hat zum Beispiel eine, nennen wir sie jetzt einfach die Conker Cuff Akademie zu bauen, die komplett ihm gehört. Mit Geld von der FIFA, mit Geld von den Verbänden und so weiter. Also das, ja, ich würde fast sagen der Godfather auf Dreck am Stecken, Jack Warner in dieser Geschichte.
Diese Akademie hat übrigens einen offiziellen Titel, Joao Avalanche Center of Excellence. Womit wir also einen der Korruptions-Erfinder der FIFA und Center ist auch ein guter, griffiger Begriff und Excellence halt die Qualitätsstufe, mit der man unter dem Dach der FIFA das Geld, das da rumfließt, abgreifen kann.
Ja, und Joao Avalanche, natürlich, du hast es gesagt, mit der Erfinder der korrupten FIFA hat damals gegen einen Briten 1974 den Präsidentschaftswahlkampf gewonnen. Und Horst Dassler, der Sohn von Adi Dassler, hat das ganz kurz vorher noch von jemanden erfahren, vielleicht werde ich da später noch kurz zwei Sätze zu sagen und hat es dann noch rechtzeitig geschafft, mit Avalanche ein Deal zu machen, das komischerweise dann die ISL, also eben jene Vermarktungsfirma, die Vermarktungsrechte für alle FIFA-Events bekommt und die beiden haben dann auch Sepp Blatter als Generalsekretär zu FIFA geholt. So schließen sich innerhalb dieser Folge, werden sich immer wieder Kreise schließen. Wir haben noch ein paar Akteure, über die würde ich gerne kürzer sprechen, von Jürgen. Der eine davon ist José Jota Javilla. Er ist insofern wichtig, weil das ein Name ist, den man, also ich kannte ihn vorher nicht und ich war fasziniert im Negativen wie im Positiven von seiner Lebensgeschichte. Ich habe einen CNN-Bericht gefunden, wo das ganz kurz in ein paar Sekunden zusammengefasst wird. Dann haben unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer ein Bild vor ihm vor Augen. Das muss man noch mal sacken lassen. Also dieser Jose Javilla, der Hotdog-Verkäufer war eigentlich Sportjournalist, dem innerhalb von ein paar Jahren dann die Rechte an Copa America, Copa Libertadores und so weiter zugefallen sind. Im Nachhinein wusste man alles über Schmiergezahlungen sich rangeholt. Ein stinkreicher Mensch, er warb mehrere TV-Sender, Zeitungen, Farmen, Immobilien, unglaublicher Reichtum, hat sich dann im Verlaufe des Prozesses schuldig bekannt und 151 Millionen US-Dollar an den US-Staat gezahlt. Das zeigt, welche unglaublichen Summen da im Umlauf waren. Und dieser Name war mir nicht geläufig, war aber für die Ermittlungen ganz, ganz wichtig. Die werden wir später noch dazu kommen. Also total interessant, wie so etwas auch an einem vorbei laufen kann, obwohl man sich auch für Sportpolitik interessiert.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wir hatten das ja schon mal in einem unserer Gespräche, die Optik, wenn man zum Beispiel aus deutscher Sicht sich fragt, wie wurde der Skandal dargestellt oder ab wann gibt es Geschichten und Berichte, die versuchen, der Öffentlichkeit klar zu machen, was da los ist. Diese Optik ist natürlich immer verjüngt. Also ich glaube, du hast erwähnt, dass wenn man Google aufruft heute deutschsprachig, wie da die Bewertung von Google in den Algorithmen abläuft, kannst du dir vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären, weil du hast es ja selber gerade recherchiert.
Ja, also das ist mir aufgefallen bei der ganzen Vorbereitung zu dieser Sendung, dass die ersten 40, 50 Google-Treffer, die behandeln alle von den aktuellen Geschehnissen im FIFA-Prozess. Es ist aber ganz, ganz schwierig, sich ein umfassendes Bild darüber zu machen, wo steht man jetzt innerhalb dieses Prozesses, wer ist da eigentlich alles noch mit angeklagt, der jetzt noch nicht genannt wurde. Die Antworten findet man dann tatsächlich erst auf der Seite des Departments of Justice, da kann man nämlich sich die ganzen Indictments, also die Anklagen, runterladen und netterweise haben sie auch immer so kurze Abstracts gemacht, wo dann mal alle Namen drinstehen, die jetzt eigentlich angeklagt wurden und das fand ich sehr bemerkenswert, dass zwar dieser FIFA-Prozess in der deutschen Medienlandschaft stattfindet, aber eher so rund um den Prozess selbst und das große dahinterstehende Bild. Man merkt bei den Artikeln, dass die Autoren, die die Artikel verfassen, dieses Bild kennen und immer wieder andeuten, aber vielleicht weil es zu komplex ist, irgendwie wird es nie ausgemalt und man muss dann tatsächlich, also ich habe jetzt zur Vorbereitung hierauf, mehrere Bücher gelesen werden, auch am Ende noch ein paar Empfehlungen geben für alle, die sich da selber noch tiefer reinarbeiten wollen. Aber das zeigt, wie schwierig es ist, dieses große Bild zu zeichnen und da hilft einem dann tatsächlich auch Google nicht weiter. Bei Wikipedia sind die deutschen Einträge zu diesen ganzen Sportfunktionären grotesk. Also wenn ich mal eine Woche Zeit habe, dann setze ich mich da jetzt mal als nächstes ran. Die Englischen sind dann oft besser, man muss aber auch häufig zum Beispiel ins Portugiesische wechseln oder ins Spanische, um dann richtig tiefergehende Dinge zu erfahren. Es ist erstaunlich, wie dieser ganze große Komplex dann doch nur so auf kleine Dinge reduziert in der Berichterstattung hier stattfindet.
Ich tippe mal, das hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun. Also wo ist man auf dem Planeten? Wo fühlt man sich wohl? Wo glaubt man, dass das Publikumsinteresse, worauf das abzielt? Und natürlich ist das immer erst der DFB und dann der DFB in seiner Rolle in der FIFA. Da gibt es ja nun auch einige interessante, teilweise auch strafrechtlich wichtige Details. Und da hat man dann schon sehr viel auf dem Teller und dann wird das andere eben doch mehr zu so einer ganz groben Gemengelage. Und je nachdem, wer von den ganzen Brüdern öffnet gerade den Mund oder schweigt sich aus. Also ich meine, in der Zeit, als es rund um Michael Garcia ging und also seine Arbeit und dann als der Report vorgelegt wurde, aber nicht veröffentlicht und so weiter, dann gibt es wieder Dinge, die damit zu tun haben. Aber auch da war die Aufgabe für Michael Garcia, er sollte eigentlich ja nur Russland und Katar aufklären, also auch sehr verjüngt, also keine komplette Aufgabe. Also bleibt man auch dort in der Berichterstattung natürlich relativ nah an dem Thema und es endet aber dann immer wieder in so einer mysteriösen Bewertung von Persönlichkeitselementen. Also wer ist dieser Garcia, wer ist dieser Eckart, kommen die miteinander klar oder nicht und warum sind die überhaupt, wo die sind und so und dann da werden immer so ein paar Dinge mit angesprochen, die sind nachvollziehbar, aber sie führen nicht notwendigerweise zu dem, was du jetzt gerade mal als Wunsch geäußert hast. Also das größere Bild, das klarere, nachvollziehbare Bild. Aber das fängt, glaube ich, wenn wir jetzt gerade mal so kurz diese Pause machen und so ein bisschen über Medienarbeit reden, das hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen. Wie kommen überhaupt solche Aufklärungsansätze zustande? Also ohne die Arbeit von Journalistenkollegen wie besonders Andrew Jennings, lässt sich gar nichts passieren. Also das ist ein Mann, der akribisch und manisch fast Dokumente sicher zuspielen lassen und immer signalisiert hat, Leute, mir könnt ihr vertrauen, der zum Glück auch immer wieder mithilfe der BBC eine Plattform hatte mit dem Sendeformat Ponorama und dort mit der Kamera rumlaufen konnte und andererseits auch dann Bücher machen konnte und teilweise Artikel schreiben konnte. Das wirkte aber immer in der frühen Phase, das wirkte immer so wie so ein Einzelkämpfer, der irgendein Anliegen hat. So ein rechthaberischer alter Mann, der den Frieden stören will.
Sehr sarkastisch, auch zynisch zum Teil.
Der aber diesen schönen Frieden da stören will. Und ich glaube erst in dieser einen Situation, in der das passt nur jetzt für mich gedanklich hierhin, vielleicht passt es für sonst niemand, in dem ein Komiker oder ein Komödiant in dieser FIFA Pressekonferenz diese Dollarnoten da ausschüttet über Blatter und wo ein Foto entsteht, dass das Ganze ja doch viel umfänglicher und globaler dokumentiert oder signalisiert. Ich glaube erst in dem Moment erreicht das diese Dimension, dass man erkennen kann, ok, darum geht's. Es geht um Blatter, es geht um die Organisation, es geht um Geld und es geht darum, dass es niemand ernst nehmen möchte oder so. Vorher wird die Arbeit von Journalisten verdienstvoll, aber doch immer verkleinert. Und wenn man dann jetzt zu unserem Zeitpunkt, wo wir jetzt darüber reden, dann über das Ganze sprechen möchte, dann wird das eben zu einer riesigen Veranstaltung und es wird ganz ganz schwierig, das auch nur griffig jemandem zu erklären. Das erspart einem nicht die Arbeit und nicht die Mühe. Aber ich glaube, dass das wiederum mit dazu beiträgt, dass viele Kollegen dann einfach die Arme hoch werfen, sagen, ja das geht nicht, das kann ich keinem erklären, das lasse ich lieber sein. Danke, dass du das eben anders machst.
Ja, na gut, jetzt schauen wir erstmal, wie erfolgreich das überhaupt sein wird. Vor allem, ich bin ja so ein bisschen ein Schmarotzer der journalistischen Arbeit anderer. Also klar, ich habe jetzt die Arbeit gemacht, hier alles zusammen zu tragen, aber das ist ja wie ein Schulreferat. Ich war nicht derjenige, der den Kontinent entdeckt hat. Ich erkläre jetzt nur, wie jemand diesen Kontinent entdecken konnte, weil jemand anderes es getan hat. Also das muss man schon auch klar sagen. Und an der Stelle habe ich mir auch häufiger jetzt schon gedacht, also darüber denke ich sowieso relativ viel nach im Sportjournalismus. Mir fehlt auch ein bisschen die Haltung und der Zusammenhalt der Sportjournalisten untereinander. Also ich kann völlig verstehen, wenn nicht jeder sich feulig in Themen wie Doping, diese ganzen FIFA-Machenschaften und noch andere sehr komplexe Themen einarbeiten will. Das kann kein Mensch leisten und es muss immer Spezialisten geben und auch nicht jeder muss ein Investigativjournalist sein. Aber wenn man dann Erkenntnisse von diesen anderen Kollegen vorgesetzt bekommt, dann muss man sich damit auseinandersetzen und wenn man dann sieht, dass zum Beispiel Andrew Jennings schon seit Jahren von FIFA-Pressekonferenzen und FIFA- Veranstaltungen verbannt worden ist, wenn man sieht, wie andere Journalisten seit Jahren übergangen und mundtot gemacht werden sollen vonseiten der FIFA, dann müsste man sich da solidarisch zeigen mit den Kollegen und müsste sagen, wenn ihr das macht, dann werden wir jetzt nicht mehr über den FIFA-Kongress berichten, sondern wir werden nur noch darüber berichten, wie ihr mit kritischen Journalisten umgeht. Also das fehlt mir ein bisschen und das ist mir auch im Zuge der Recherche hier wieder aufgefallen, dass diese Einzelkämpfer, wie du sie benannt hast, auch manchmal von der eigenen Gilde, Garde etwas allein gelassen werden.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein wichtiger Aspekt und ein anderer ist. Und ohne jetzt zu viel über mich zu reden. Ich gehöre auch nicht zu den Leuten, die irgendetwas aufgedeckt haben. Ich gehöre auch nur zu denen, die das aufgreifen, was von anderer Stelle aus aufgegriffen wird. Aber ich glaube, das Besondere, was jemand einbringen kann aus meiner Warte, ist, dass er sich erstens da wirklich für interessiert, dass er sich dafür so interessiert, dass er sich rein vertieft und dass er aber auch bei den Menschen, die als Auftraggeber, Schrägstrich Abnehmer von solchen Themen agieren, auch dafür sorgen kann, dass sie bereit sind, das auch umzusetzen, weil sie das Gefühl bekommen, okay, also über diesen Weg lässt sich das Thema zumindest begleiten. Das heißt also, eine der Schwächen, die ich ausmachen würde, ist, dass es braucht auch den Typ Sportsjournalist, der schon ein bisschen ein paar Mal um die Ecken rumgekommen ist und der sagen kann, okay, ich verstehe zu einem Großteil, vielleicht nicht jedes Detail, ich bin kein Jurist, ich bin kein Biologe, kein Pharmakologe, aber ich verstehe das Problem, ich verstehe, dass das rausgepult werden muss. Und ich glaube, da sehe ich eine gewisse Schwäche in dem Milieu, in dem ich mich jetzt schon seit einigen Jahren tummle. Ich bin da keindeutig weiter als die Kollegen, die ich verehre, die wirklich die harte Arbeit leisten, die Ärmel aufkrempeln. Aber ich denke, man muss sich daran erinnern, okay, auch du kannst was leisten, du musst dich nur ein bisschen vielleicht ein bisschen mehr anstrengen, ein bisschen mehr reinarbeiten. Und das Internet ist heute wirklich sehr viel ergiebiger als alle anderen Möglichkeiten, die wir früher hatten, weil wir können wirklich jede Menge Material finden. Natürlich muss man eventuell gucken, dass man mit der Fremdsprache klarkommt. Man muss gucken, ist denn das wirklich glaubwürdig, was man findet, oder ist das alles nur irgend so ein zusammen gedrehtes PR-Zeug oder so?
Klar, du musst halt journalistisch arbeiten, wenn du Journalist bist. Also das ist es ja im Grunde. Das ist halt anstrengend. Und ich kann auch verstehen, das kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen daher, dass du Sportjournalist, glaube ich, nicht aus dem Wunsch herauswirst oder sehr selten aus dem Wunsch herauswirst, da jetzt die sportpolitischen großen Themen im Hintergrund anzugehen, sondern ich würde vermuten, die Hauptmotivation Sport- Journalist zu werden, ist eine Faszination für den Sport und man möchte darüber berichten. Und es gibt eben immer diese zwei Ebenen. Du hast das Spiel auf dem Feld, auf dem Rasen, auf dem Asphalt, auf dem Parkett, welche Sportart auch immer. Und du hast das drum herum. Und ich glaube, der Hauptgrund für viele in den Sport-Journalismus zu gehen, ist das Spiel. Das ist auch völlig okay. Also ich hätte auch nicht mit 18 Jahren gesagt, ich möchte das hier mal Wettbetrug aufdecken. Da habe ich jetzt richtig Lust drauf. Na natürlich nicht. Und deswegen fehlt aber dann diese Komponente und man muss sich dessen aber dann irgendwann bewusst werden, dass das eine nicht vom anderen zu trennen zu ist, ohne dass du jetzt die ganze Zeit den moralischen Zeigefinger heben musst, bei jedem drei Punktewurf oder bei jedem direkt verwandelten Eckball, den du kommentierst.
Ich glaube, dass die Stichwort moralischer Zeigefinger, ich glaube, dass das gar nicht mal die Herausforderung ist. Ich denke, es geht nicht um mehr als um das Einfordern von Transparenz von Informationen und den Versuch, die Dinge so darzustellen, wie sie sich tatsächlich abspielen. Das heißt auch, das, was hinter den Kulissen passiert, in irgendeiner Weise so darstellen zu können, wie es tatsächlich passiert ist. Und natürlich gibt es da einen Spannungszustand, weil wenn die Leute, die da kriminelle Energie entwickeln, die wollen ja nicht, dass das bekannt wird. Also wird schon ganz früh darauf geachtet, dass Dinge möglichst unterm Deckel bleiben. Und garantiert haben die kein Interesse daran, das Journalisten zu erzählen, wie das geht. Ich denke, der Anspruch ist zwar am Ende, wir wollen eine Gesellschaft oder wir wollen leben in Ländern, in denen es fair zugeht, in denen auch Ethik eine Rolle spielt, aber der Journalist ist eigentlich erst mal nur aufgefordert, das abzubilden, das darzustellen, was tatsächlich passiert ist. Und nicht so zu tun, als fallen WM- Organisationskomitees vom Himmel und Turniere wie die ja sehr gut organisierten FIFA-Turniere. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt aus Russland nicht mitgekriegt, dass da irgendwas, außer dass da manchmal der Rasen ein bisschen gerutscht war oder so, was die Teilen angeht.
Wie immer das beste Turnier aller Zeiten.
Das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt dann so wahnsinnig interessant, aber es ist Teil von dem, was wir eigentlich angucken müssen und worüber wir uns artikulieren müssen. Ich bin ein bisschen unfroh über so eine Selfie-Kultur zum Beispiel, wie die jetzt da im Journalismus dank Instagram eine Rolle spielt. Ich meine, da aus Eppern, da habe ich Bilder gesehen auf Instagram, da fallen mir die Haare raus. Weil es geht nicht darum, dass ich als Journalist mit irgendeinem Nationalspieler von 2018 an einem Tisch sitzen darf, wofür ich sowieso nichts kann. Das habe ich nicht selber geleistet, da hat mich jemand hingeschickt. Das bezahlt vielleicht sogar noch jemand anderer, das bezahle ich nicht selber. Ich ahle mich in dieser komischen Stimmung von, oh guck mal hier, das ist alles bedeutend und wichtig und das sind Stars. Da habe ich doch meine Aufgabe verfehlt, wenn ich das mache. Aber das sage ich jetzt nicht mit einem moralischen Zeigefinger, ich hoffe, das kommt nicht so rüber. Das sage ich mit dem Anspruch, was ist denn journalistische Arbeit? Aufklären, berichten und das beschreiben, was ist. Und nicht das, was ich mir darunter vorstelle oder ausmale.
Ja und deswegen ist es auch dann mir auch wichtig gewesen, diese Sendung hier im WM-Rahmen stattfinden zu lassen, obwohl es ja durchaus gerade auch andere Dinge zu besprechen gibt. Weil ich eben finde, das, was wir gerade beim WM-Turnier erleben, das ist die perfekte Inszenierung und das ist der Grund auch für alles, was dahinter steht, weil wir so gebannt nach Russland gucken, egal welche Meinung wir zu Russland haben, zur WM-Vergabe, welche Meinung wir zu Katar und zu anderen Dingen haben, weil wir das tun. Deshalb hat das alles eine solche Macht. Wir können uns als Sport-Fans, sag ich jetzt mal, als Sportinteressierte, können wir uns nicht von der Faszination dieses Spiels lösen und deshalb bekommt diese glitzernde Oberfläche, die wir da präsentiert, bekommen, mit perfekten WM-Stadien, einer tollen Inszenierung, alles sieht gleich aus, überall die gleichen Sponsoren und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen hat die ja auch überhaupt eine solche Wirkmacht. Deswegen fließt da so viel Geld hinein, weil wir alle hingucken. Und deswegen fand ich es, obwohl es jetzt zeitlich eigentlich nicht ganz so gepasst war von der Vorbereitung auf diese Folge, aber fand ich das wichtig, dass während der WM jetzt auch noch zu veröffentlichen, selbst wenn es vielleicht auch noch der ein oder andere oder die ein oder andere erst danach hören wird, weil das beides eben miteinander zusammenhängt. Weil wir alle diese vier Wochen uns dann doch sehr intensiv mit der WM auseinandergesetzt haben, ich hier ja auch, hat das überhaupt auch so eine Strahlkraft, dass da so viel Geld in diesem ganzen Kosmos-Fußball kursiert und dieses Geld fließt dann eben auf ganz viele Arten und Weisen in ganz ganz viele Taschen, wo es eigentlich gar nicht hingehört hätte. So, jetzt haben wir einen großen Bogen geschlagen, Jürgen. Gut, dass ich ein Kapitelmärkchen gemacht habe, in dem Moment, wo du gesagt hast, lass uns da mal ganz kurz noch mal drüber sprechen. Wir waren ja eigentlich bei den Personen. Ich versuche noch mal kurz das Bild zu zeichnen, wen wir jetzt besprochen haben. Also wir haben einmal kurz euch erklärt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es gibt den südamerikanischen Verband Comnibol, es gibt den CONCACAF, das ist in Nordamerika plus die karibischen Inseln und wir haben jetzt schon vier Personen besprochen, zum einen Sepp Blatter, den kennt ihr alle, Chuck Blazer, der aufgeblähte Weihnachtsmann. Wir haben Jack Warner, das ist der Godfather of Tricksereien mit der eigenen Trinidad und Tobago CONCACAF Akademie und wir haben Jose Javilla, das ist der Hotdog-Verkäufer, der dann 150 Millionen US-Dollar Strafe gezahlt hat. Also stellt ihn euch einfach in Zukunft vor wie einen sehr, sehr gepflegten, älteren, weißhaarigen Mann, der einen Hotdog in der Hand hat. Vielleicht könnt ihr ihn euch so merken. Wird vielleicht langsam Zeit, dass wir zum einen dann auch mal zum Prozess kommen, aber noch ganz kurz über diejenigen Personen sprechen, die auch diesen Prozess ins Rollen gebracht haben. Und da haben wir zum einen Loretta Lynch. Jürgen, magst du uns mal sagen, wer das ist?
Ja, Loretta Lynch ist natürlich in der zweiten Phase der Obama-Präsidentschaft ein bisschen prominenter geworden, wurde Justizministerin und hat in dieser Funktion dann auch einen Auftritt gehabt, der interessanterweise etwas abbindet, weil sie hatte als zuständige Staatsanwältin in Brooklyn dafür gesorgt, dass diese Abteilung des amerikanischen Justiz sich überhaupt mit diesem Thema beschäftigt. Das ist schon schwierig genug, weil die Interne einer solchen Justiz in einem Land mit über 300 Millionen Einwohnern da passieren viele Dinge auch nicht. Also die Tatsache, dass irgendeine Staatsanwaltschaft sich darum kümmert, so etwas aufzuklären, ist schon ungewöhnlich genug, weil die wägen immer ihren eigenen Aufwand und ihre Zeit ab. Lohnt sich das überhaupt, solchen Fußballern hinterher zu laufen und zu gucken, was da los ist oder so? Und die war aber im Prinzip daran interessiert, weil die Staatsanwaltschaft in Brooklyn ist, so in dem internen, es gibt sehr viele District- also Bezirksstaatsanwaltschaften in den USA, aber sie ist so ein bisschen durch ihre geografische Lage im Bereich Mafia und Korruption geimpft. Das heißt, die haben auch dann Fachleute in dem Haus, Staatsanwälte, die sich so ein bisschen mehr mit solchen Dingen wie den Konspirationsstrafgesetzten, also dem, was wir unter Racketeering bezeichnen. Das ist ein Kunstwort, wo man also die Netzwerkkriminalität, die Bandenkriminalität in Amerika unter zusammenfasst. Da hat man also die Spezialisten im Haus und wenn die dann schon mal die Ohren aufstellen, sagen ja gut, das klingt aber eher komisch, da kommt ja vielleicht noch viel mehr raus, dann kommt sowas vielleicht als mal überhaupt nur intern ans Laufen. Wir wurden insgesamt nur davon informiert, dass das FBI ermittelt. Das war mal so ein Nachrichtenleck vor ein paar Jahren. Und das geht wahrscheinlich auch auf Andrew Jennings zurück, der nun irgendwann wirklich Besuch bekam von FBI-Beamten, die mitgekriegt hatten, dass er eine Menge weiß und auch eine Menge Dokumente gesammelt hat.
Diesen Leck endete dann übrigens auch die Kooperation. Also er hat es wohl angeblich so gemacht, dass er dann im Nachgang zu diesem Treffen noch einen Stapel an Dokumenten rübergeschickt hat ans FBI und direkt danach kam der Artikel von Andrew Jenkins. Das FBI beschäftigt sich übrigens mit diesen Themen, was ja stimmte, weil er ihnen die Dokumente geschickt hat. Und das war aber, wie man jetzt im Nachhinein ein paar Jahre später nachlesen kann, einer der Gründe, warum dann das FBI gesagt hat, ok, an der Stelle wird es dann auch schwierig, da weiter zusammenzuarbeiten.
Ich wollte nur, dass ich das nur deshalb erwähnen wollte, weil wir haben so ein bisschen, wenn man sich in den Interna in den USA nicht so auskennt, wir haben so ein bisschen ein schiefes Bild davon. Das FBI ist wirklich nur die Polizei. Die hat natürlich bestimmte Befugnisse und bestimmte Aufgabenbereiche und da gehört eben Geldwäsche zum Beispiel dazu. Da gehört auch bestimmte Korruptionsdelikte dazu. Aber das FBI ist im Prinzip Ausführung des Organs, wenn es um Ermittlungen geht. Die entscheidende Stelle ist tatsächlich die Staatsanwaltschaft in dem Moment, wo sie sagt, wir ermitteln und das kann in den USA auch verdeckt anlaufen. Das muss nicht unbedingt ein veröffentlichter Akt werden, dass man sagt, wir ermitteln jetzt gegen irgendjemanden, wegen irgendwas, sondern das kann eben verdeckt laufen. Nur weil an der Stelle, also in der Zuständigkeit von Loretta Lynch als Staatsanwältin, als Chefin dieser Staatsanwaltschaft an dieses Thema geglaubt hat und darauf Leute angesetzt hat, konnten dann unter diesem Dach bestimmte Fahnder, wie vom FBI oder eben auch von der Steuerfahndung, was ja auch noch ganz wichtig ist in diesem Fall, konnten anfangen tiefer zu gehen. Weil die müssen alle immer irgendwie sich rechtfertigen. Alle Vorgesetzte, die können nicht alle irgendwie darum telefonieren. Also wir als Journalisten telefonieren einfach mal rum. Aber das können die nicht. Die müssen erklären, was sie da machen.
Ja, vor allem über Jahre hinweg. Das liefert man seit 2011 bis 2015.
Und das braucht eben diese Logik, die nur funktioniert, wenn wirklich an der Stelle, an der Ermittlungen losgetreten werden können. Wenn die Stelle mitmacht, dann geht es nur weiter. Und das sollten wir eben an diese Dame knüpfen, die auch wieder eine körperliche Auffälligkeit, eine ungeheuer kleine Person – ich weiß nicht genau wie groß, aber wahrscheinlich keine 1, 60 und dann sind dann schon noch irgendwie Hacke bei den Perms dabei oder so. Aber eine sehr selbstbewusste Frau, die zeigt, dass auch Frauen in dieser Welt der Justiz selbstbewusst antreten können und sagen, okay, wir kennen unsere Gesetze, wir kennen die Präzedenzurteile unserer höchsten Gerichte, wir sagen, das ist gerechtfertigt, dass wir das jetzt angehen und wir versuchen alle Mittel zu benutzen und dazu gehört dann am Ende auch, dass man es schafft, die Schweizer Polizei bzw. sicherlich auch über die Staatsanwaltschaft in Bern dazu bitten kann, ihr müsst uns jetzt helfen. Da ist diese Veranstaltung, da kommen ganz viele Leute zusammen, es gibt keinen besseren Ort, um Leute festzusetzen. Bitte tut, was ihr könnt. Ich bin sicher, dass Loretta Lench nicht gesagt hat, das sollte bitte folgendermaßen aussehen, frühmorgens im Bauer-O-Lac und dann brauchen wir noch Leute mit Betttüchern. Das ist sicherlich dann die Zufälligkeit dessen, was da passiert. Aber gleichzeitig ist ein Kollege von der New York Times im Hotel und sitzt da in der Lobby auf der Couch und hat sicherlich gehört, da passiert was. Das kann nur ein Tipp gewesen sein, der wiederum aus Brooklyn gekommen ist. Damit kommt eben eine Medienwirksamkeit ins Spiel und das ist das, was die US-Staatsanwälte besser verstehen. Sie halten oft die Klappe, aber dann gibt es den Moment, da muss der Deckel aufgemacht werden und das muss auch richtig BUMM machen. Das kann nicht einfach nur da haben wir so ein paar Leute, sondern das muss richtig zu einer Show werden. Dadurch haben wir heute diese Bilder im Kopf, wie da Leute abgeführt werden und von Leuten mit Betttüchern abgeschirmt werden. Und Loretta Lynch steht dann ein paar Stunden später in Brooklyn. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo es war. Wahrscheinlich war es in Brooklyn. Er steht dann da auf dem Podium und gibt dann der ganzen Veranstaltung den Sinn, den wir alle brauchen, um zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Ja, da gibt es gleich einen Ton zu und da gab es noch einige Probleme, damit in Schweizer Behörden weiter dieser New York Times Journalist in der Lobby saß. Aber wir hören uns mal an, was sie da gesagt hat und stellt euch dazu eine eben sehr kleine, mit kurzen Haaren, quirlige, dunkelhäutige Staatsanwältin vor, die hinter dem Mikrofon fast versinkt, weil später noch mit James Comey jemals kam, der ungefähr doppelt so groß ist wie sie und das ist fast bildlich gesprochen.
Die 14 Verwaltungen, die heute in der Befehlung des Entschließungsverfahrens beteiligt sind hochgründende Offiziere der FIFA, die Regionen und andere Regierungskommissionen unter der FIFA-Ambrella und Sportmarketing-Exekutiven, die, nach der Befehlung, Millionen Dollar in Verschleißungen und Höhepakete bezahlt haben, um die rückwürdigsten Medien und Marketingrechte für internationale Fußball-Tournements zu erhalten.
Das waren die Worte, mit der sie diese viel beachtete Pressekonferenz dann eingeleitet hat. Wir haben sie auch schon im Intro gehört und werden später, denke ich, auch nochmal da von der Pressekonferenz etwas einspielen können. Du hast ja schon gesagt, diese Show, also dann im Buch von Ken Bensinger zu diesem ganzen FIFA-Prozess heißt das Kapitel The Take Down. Das ist dann das, wo dann die vierjährigen Ermittlungen kulminieren in diesen Verhaftungen in der Schweiz. Das war tatsächlich perfekt inszeniert von den US-Amerikanern. Und vielleicht erinnert sich ja auch der oder die ein oder andere der Hörerinnen und Hörer noch daran. Das ging damals schon durch die Presse und man konnte das fast im Live-Ticker mitverfolgen. Hier ist gerade etwas passiert, was man im FIFA Kosmos lange nicht für möglich hielt. Nämlich, da wurden Leute wirklich festgenommen und das in der Schweiz.
Und dann glaube ich, in dem Moment merkt man auch allen Beteiligten, die nicht festgenommen wurden, ein wachsendes Maß an Nervosität an. Unter anderem auch dem FIFA-Presse-Sprecher, der dann zwar immer so tut, als sei eine kalte Hundeschnauze, aber man merkt ihm dann an, dass er nicht mehr so einfach so wegreden kann, weil bestimmte Fakten lassen sich dann eben nicht mehr wegdiskutieren.
Und bestimmte Betten, die zum Schutz der Privatsphäre dieser hohen FIFA-Funktionäre hochgehalten wurden, das ist ein so mächtiges Bild, dass schon viele Fußballfans sich daran erinnern werden. Und das ist natürlich fatal für die FIFA.
Und auch alle Versuche, also Blatter hat das dann versucht, ziemlich schnell wegzureden, als naja, das sind die Amerikaner, die waren sauer, dass sie gegen Katar in der Bewerbung verloren haben. Das ist jetzt sozusagen die Retourkutsche. Das versickert dann alles, weil das ist natürlich albern, weil in dem Moment, wo man höchstpersönlich die Anklageschrift durchlesen kann und erkennen muss, auf was die basiert, die basiert nicht einfach nur auf Animositäten und Ressentiments. Die basiert darauf, dass diese Leute Kontounterlagen haben, Indizien. Ich meine, zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon die Mitarbeit von Chuck Blazer gewonnen hatten, der ja nun als Kronzeuge einiges geleistet hat. Das kann man nicht einfach dann kleinreden. Und insofern ist das sicherlich der Punkt, an dem alles umkippt. 2015 ist diese gespielte Naivität der, was kann man hier schon machen? Wir machen ja Fehler, wir regeln das alles intern. Willst du das nochmal einspielen? Etwas ist schiefgelaufen, das ist auch mein Fehler. Wer nie etwas macht, macht keine Fehler.
Wer viel macht, macht ab und zu Fehler.
Aber das war eben anders. Und dieses Gegenstück, dieser, wie will ich das jetzt nennen?
Der Antagonist, die Antagonistin.
Ja, sehr schön. Und dass einfach dieses Material und dann schon ziemlich verdichtet Gewicht hat. Und nicht einfach nur umgepustet werden kann, wie so ein Garcia-Report. Ich meine, das muss man sich doch mal reintun. Garcia versucht, die Bewerbung von Russland zu analysieren. Und er bekommt gesagt, ja, diese Computer, die haben wir nicht mehr, bzw. wir haben das gelöscht. Das waren auch Leihcomputer und sonst was alles. Also wir können ihnen nicht helfen, tut uns leid. Und so haben wir die Sache erledigt.
Ja, das war eine interne FIFA-Ermittlung. Darin sind sie sehr, sehr gut. Die FIFA macht auch sehr gerne Ermittlungen zu. Wenn dann der Druck so groß wird, dass der Betroffene zurücktreten muss, dann sagt die FIFA-Ethikkommission. Und das Ethik müsst ihr euch einen dicksten Anführungszeichen der aller Zeiten, obwohl es alle Zeiten ja nicht gibt, denken. Dann sagt die Ethikkommission gerne, ach so, ja, nee, dann können wir ja auch hier unsere Untersuchung schließen, dann ist ja alles cool. Er hat es ja zugegeben und generell ist ja sowieso das Ding die ganze Zeit.
Ich denke, die Organisation hat immer ehrlich sein müssen.
Die Organisation von FIFA. Aber die Individuen sind nicht ehrlich.
Genau, also wir erinnern uns an dieses alte Argumentationsmuster. Loretta Lynch, also die jetzt Justizministerin damals, ganz ganz wichtig, ganz kleine Person, sehr quirlige Person mit einem starken Auftritt, die das Ganze dann öffentlichkeitswirksam ins Rollen gebracht hat. Du hast mir noch einen Namen mitgebracht, mit dem hatte ich gar nicht gerechnet, als wir uns besprochen hatten, nämlich Richard Blumenthal. Warum war der dir denn in diesem Komplex des FIFA-Prozesses noch wichtig?
Naja, weil auch intern in den USA gibt es immer wieder die Frage, gibt es Deckung, gibt es Unterstützung, zum Beispiel von Seiten der Politik, weil zwar hat ein Staatsanwalt oder ein Justizminister unglaubliche Freiheiten, aber auch nur im Rahmen einer bestimmten Auffassung des Jobs. Und wenn aus der Politik Gegenwind kommt, weil zum Beispiel die Sorge entsteht, das haben die Amerikaner manchmal, das ist so schwer zu erklären. Einerseits mischen sie sich gerne in alles ein, was im Rest der Welt passiert und haben da auch über 100 Militärbasen überall auf der Welt. Andererseits sind sie natürlich auch nicht unsensibel, wenn es darum geht, ihnen vorzuwerfen, ihr mischt euch in alles ein und das hat euch doch gar nichts an. Und in diesem Spannungsfeld ist es nicht unwichtig, wenn zum Beispiel in diesem Fall im Rahmen einer Senatsanhörung dann ein Senator, der dort als zweiter Mann in dem Ausschuss amtiert, dann mal richtig so seine Artilleriegeschütze ausfährt und dokumentiert. Also das ist hier alles total richtig, sondern hier geht es um einen unglaublichen Sumpf. Er war derjenige, der das Ganze dann auf die Formel Mafia gebracht hat. Das ist natürlich interessant, dass jemand so semantisch mit der Mafia umgeht nach dem Motto, einiges die Mafia noch die bessere, die sympathischere Organisation. Der Mann ist selber Jurist und war Generalstaatsanwalt des Staates Connecticut, bevor er Senator wurde. Der weiß das natürlich auch selber. Natürlich kannst du die Leute viel besser kriegen, die so blatant, also quasi ins Gesicht, overt, offen und arrogant sich verhalten, die anderen hast du große Schwierigkeiten und sowas wie zum Beispiel eine Mafia-Familie, wie die ja in Amerika gerne genannt werden, also eine Mafia-Organisation zu kriegen. Dazu braucht man Kronzeugen umdrehen, die selber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, zehn Leute umgebracht haben und man muss denen dann also eine billige Strafe geben, damit sie dann anfangen als Kronzeugen auszusagen. Das ist natürlich, wenn man es genau anguckt, relativ bedenklich. Der Zweck heile ich die Mittel. Also das ist eben das Beispiel innerhalb der Mafia, wo viele Zeugen einfach umgebracht werden und also gar nicht erst aussagen können. Die kann man nicht sympathischer finden. Aber es ist sein rhetorischer Trick hier in dem Moment zu sagen, Leute, glaubt mal ja nicht, das ist hier so eine einfache Nummer. Das ist übel. Das ist von übelster Sorte.
Absolut. Und wenn du es schon sagst, bei Mafia-Prozessen werden Personen umgebracht, das ist auch im Laufe des Auftaktes zu diesem FIFA-Prozess geschehen. Dass da bei einem Fahrradstall auf merkwürdige Art und Weise ein hochrangiger Fußballfunktionär, der schwer belastet wurde, im Prozess von seinem eigenen Leibwächter in den Bauch geschossen wurde und daran verstarb. Ein zweiter Anwalt aus Argentinien hat Selbstmord begangen, unter nicht ganz genau geklärten Umständen. Alles kurz nachdem sie schwer belastet wurden im FIFA-Prozess. Dieser Mafia-Vergleich, über den man ja vielleicht erst ein bisschen lacht, vor allem wenn Blumenthal hier sagt, das tut mir fast ein bisschen leid für die Mafia war, die wäre nie so bescheuert und arrogant, wie die FIFA das gemacht hat. Der ist nicht so weit weg, nicht von den Dingen, wie das Ganze hier ablief und auch nicht vom juristischen Herden. Das ist auch noch eine Besonderheit des US-amerikanischen Rechts, dass du, wenn du zeigen kannst, dass Einzelverbrechen innerhalb einer Organisation so fest mit der Organisation selbst verwoben sind, dass es quasi gar nicht mehr voneinander zu trennen ist, dann kannst du die ganze Organisation eben als Mafia-ähnliches Gebilde bezeichnen und hast dann andere rechtliche Möglichkeiten, um da Anklagen vorzunehmen. Das war jetzt ein bisschen juristisch und ich habe sicherlich auch streng verkürzt, aber das war für die US-Behörden ein wichtiger Schritt, als sie irgendwann an dem Punkt angelangt waren, innerhalb ihrer Untersuchung, dass sie sagen konnten, okay, das ist jetzt eine Untersuchung nach RICO, so nennt sich das Gesetz, was in den 70ern zur Bekämpfung der Mafia tatsächlich eingeführt wurde.
Ja und das war auch der Grund, warum die Spekulationen begonnen haben, dass die FIFA als Organisation auf diesem Wege auch in den Kragen gehen konnte. Nun habe ich schon von Anfang an, als ich gesehen habe, wie sich das hier auffächert, das Gefühl gehabt, das geht Loretta Lynch und ihren Staatsanwälten nicht darum, die ganze FIFA lahmzulegen. Es gibt hier immer auch so Versuche, Leute mit dem Schuss vor den Bug und ein paar rauszugreifen und so. Also so bestimmte taktische Verhaltensweisen auf Seiten der Ermittlungsbehörden gegenüber einer verbrecherischen Welt, die man nicht komplett aufklären kann, aber immer so bestimmte taktische Momente anzubringen, um die Leute dann zu verhalten, zu führen, das einem helfen kann. Und das ist auch im Fall der FIFA ja passiert. Also einerseits hat man es eben geschafft, eine amerikanische Kanzlei mit einzubinden, die nun als Rechtsvertreter der FIFA arbeitet. Aber die Interessen der FIFA im Sinne von, wir müssen jetzt auch zeigen, dass wir in Brooklyn mitmachen, das war sehr wichtig. Und das andere ist sicherlich auch die Rolle, die man die Schweizer gedrückt hat. Dass die nicht länger so tun konnten, als ginge sie das alles, obwohl das in ihrem, in ihrer Welt passiert, als ginge sie das alles überhaupt nichts an. Und das ist interessanterweise im Umgang zwischen den USA und der Schweiz, das ist jetzt schon mehrfach passiert. Also wir hatten den Fall, das liegt schon einige Jahre zurück, da ging es um Schweizer Bankkonten, die eingerichtet worden waren von jüdischen Deutschen, von deutschen Juden, die teilweise nicht überlebt haben, aber Angehörige haben, die Rechte an diesen Konten hatten. Und die Schweizer Banken stellten sich auf den Standpunkt, naja, also jeder kann zu uns kommen, wer uns findet oder so, ja, kein Problem. Aber wir müssen uns hier nicht weiter anstrengen, wir haben hier keine moralische Verpflichtung. Da kam der Druck aus den USA und es hat also bis hin zu einer Kommission und allen möglichen Bemühungen gegeben und es wurden hunderte von Millionen Dollar auf diesem Wege gefunden und verteilt an Menschen, die ihren Anspruch auch dokumentieren konnten. Das Zweite war die Situation um die Steuerfragen von Amerikanern, die in der Schweiz Geld deponiert hatten. Und die das dann nicht versteuert hatten, weil das Schweizer Bankgeheimnis ihnen dabei half, das zu verschleiern. Und da wurde halt auch mit Hilfe der amerikanischen Justiz, da wurde ein Stein aus der ganzen Mauer rausgebrochen erstmal. Und da muss man jetzt auch nicht im Detail drauf eingehen. Und dann wurde das gesamte Schweizer Bankenrecht und das gesamte Schweizer Bankgeheimnis wurde geknackt über einen Weg. Und da spielte zum Beispiel Amnestie eine ganz große Rolle. Leute konnten bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt erklären, okay, wir hatten hier Geld, wir melden das jetzt an. Dorthin wurde eine bestimmte Geldbuße auferlegt, aber die konnten danach wieder mit einer weißen Weste weiterleben. Und alle, die das nicht gemacht hatten, standen unter dem Risiko, dass diese Banken gezwungen werden, irgendwann mal ihre Kontoinformationen aufzudecken. Und da wurden eben auch inzwischen Tausende von Amerikanern belangt. Und so arbeiten die eben hier oft. Und ich glaube, wenn man das weiß, dann kann man auch erkennen, warum der Fall jetzt von den amerikanischen Ermittlungsbehörden so abgewickelt und weitergeführt worden ist seit 2015, wie das jetzt gelaufen ist. Also nicht direkt eingreifend in alle möglichen anderen Rechtshoheitsgebiete. Aber wir hatten ja glaube ich noch nicht Bundesanwalt Michael Lauber erwähnt, der kam dann eben ab 2015 in dieser Aufgabe, undankbare Aufgabe in dieser sauberen Schweiz doch mal doch nach dem Rechten zu sehen. Und er hat das dann ja mit einer bestimmten Art und Weise versucht zu beschreiben.
Also ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht am Gängelband der USA. Das ist eine völlig unabhängige Untersuchung, die gelinkt wird mit Rechtshilfe, so wie in vielen anderen Fällen auch. Und was die Amerikaner machen in ihren Verfahren, das werden sie uns soweit sagen, als es für unsere Ermittlungen wichtig ist. Und wir werden fragen, was wir brauchen.
Ja, nun wissen wir sehr wenig über das, was die Schweizer, die haben halt ein anderes Verständnis davon, wie man arbeitet. Also möglichst alles unterm Deckel behalten. Das kann man auch akzeptieren, wenn denn dann irgendwann mal wirklich eine vernünftige Anklageschrift oder eine Erklärung, was sie gemacht haben, passiert. Lauber hat auch schon damals gesagt, also das kann man nicht. Er hat dann die Fußballmetapher benutzt. Das kann man also nicht in 90 Minuten machen. Dazu kommt auch, das ist ja eine nicht besonders große Behörde und die können ja nun nicht anfangen, sich komplett nur noch auf FIFA-Akten umzustellen. Aber man muss davon ausgehen, dass die Schweizer, um ihr Gesicht zu wahren, das ist auch ein Teil, so wie so ein bisschen die Schweizer Mentalität so funktioniert, um ihr Gesicht zu wahren, werden sie schon irgendwas auf die Beine stellen. Die werden jetzt nicht einfach da sich dahin stellen und sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt hier drei Jahre gearbeitet oder vier oder fünf, ja, nee, also nach unseren Gesetzen ist hier nichts passiert oder so. Das würde nicht gut aussehen. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, auf was es wirklich hinauslaufen wird. Ich würde mal tippen, dass so Geschäftsaktivitäten wie die von Walke mit dem Südafrika-Geld und Jack Warner, dass die am ehesten am plastischsten doch mal ein Thema werden. Weil da sind Sachen gelaufen, das lässt sich sehr gut nachweisen, dass das einfach nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist. Und die andere Sache ist also dieser Misswirtschaftsvorwurf, der geht natürlich an die Adresse von Blatter. Möglicherweise eine Geldstrafe wäre mal so meine Vermutung. Ich glaube nicht, dass er sich also auf irgendwelche Tage in einem Schweizer Gefängnis einrichten muss.
Er scheint ja auch schon mehr zu wissen. In diesem Channel 4-Interview hat er interessanterweise gesagt, dass er glaubt, die Schweizer Ermittlungen würden bis zum Ende dieses Jahres abgeschlossen sein oder es gäbe einen neuen Stand. Und das war meines Wissens nach eine neue Information. Das hatte ich vorher noch nirgendwo gelegen.
Aber man muss der Blatter auch vorsichtig sein. Nicht, dass man ihn nur als Taktiker einstuft. Er hat auch schon Dinge falsch interpretiert. Er wurde auch schon mal vor einer Weile von seinen eigenen Rechtsanwälten korrigiert, weil er Dinge nach außen so dargestellt hat, wie sie effektiv nicht der Fall waren. Also deshalb bin ich da auch ein bisschen vorsichtig bei dem, was er sagt.
Es ist aber definitiv wichtig zu wissen, wir sprechen jetzt dann über die ganzen US-amerikanischen Ermittlungen im FIFA-Prozess. Es gibt aber noch eine Untersuchung der Schweizer Behörden, über die ganz, ganz wenig nur bekannt ist und zu der die Schweizer auch ein bisschen getrieben werden mussten, über die wirklich umfassenden Anklageschriften der US-Behörden. Wir haben dazu diesen wunderbaren O-Ton von Michael Lauber gerade gehört und würde sagen, an der Stelle, unglaublich wie viel Zeit wir jetzt schon in Anspruch genommen haben, haben wir die wichtigsten Leute eingeführt. Es gäbe noch so, so viel mehr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber wir belassen es mal bei diesen paar wichtigen Personen und widmen uns jetzt vielleicht, würde ich sagen, dem Ganzen, wie kam es eigentlich zum Prozess und dann, dass du, Jürgen, uns dann mal erklären, wie lief das jetzt alles ab, oder? Sollen wir mal langsam weitermachen?
Können wir gerne machen. Ich wäre aber dafür, dass wir versuchen, den Ablauf so knapp wie möglich zu halten, weil wir ja, wir sind ja schon so viel weiter. Es ist immer interessant, nachzuvollziehen, okay, was braucht es eigentlich an Elementen, an Protonen, Neutronen, um irgendeine chemische Reaktion zustande zu bekommen. Aber das sind eben sehr, sehr kleine Sachverhalte, die erst dann in die zusammenkommen. Aber ich glaube, mit der wichtigste, weil es geht in der Arbeit der Justiz oft darum, ob sie einen Hebel in die Hand bekommen. Und oft auch sehr simpel, wenn ich eigentlich ohne Schwierigkeiten jemanden nachweisen kann, dass er einen Verbrechen begangen hat oder auch nur ein Vergehen. Das muss ja nicht immer das Schwerste sein. Dann kann ich diesen Mann in die Enge treiben oder diese Frau. Dann kann ich sagen, okay, du hast zwei Möglichkeiten, weil wir haben hier die Dokumente. Du hast zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder du gestehst und hilfst uns jetzt, dann können wir gucken, ob du billiger davonkommst, oder aber du akzeptierst die antagonistische Situation. Du holst den Rechtsanwalt und sagst, ich habe nichts damit zu tun, ihr müsst mir alles beweisen. Dann kann es aber teuer werden. Und was wir erleben konnten oder erfahren haben später, ist, wie die Person Chuck Blazer – den haben wir ja rausgearbeitet – wie der nun aufgrund einer ganz simplen Verfehlung – muss man sich mal vorstellen, ein Mensch, der sehr viele Millionen irgendwann zu dem Zeitpunkt ja verdient im Jahr – schafft es nicht, eine vernünftige Steuererklärung abzugeben. Es mag Gründe dafür geben, warum er sich das überlegt hat, wie man das am schlauesten macht. Weil bei ihm ist Geld über die Keime an Inseln gelaufen, das kann gefährlich sein, wenn das rauskommt. Er hat sicherlich auch Sachen gemacht, da gab es kaum Belege dafür, das war schwierig zu rekonstruieren, weil er hat nicht sehr, sehr ordentlich gelebt und gearbeitet. Also kann es sein, da wird jemand so trödelig und sagt, na ja, es wird schon irgendwie alles gut gehen. Es ist aber nicht nur die Person Chuck Blazer plötzlich in Gefahr, sondern auch in seiner Rolle als der Geschäftsführer der Conker Cuff, die auch in den USA domiziliert war zu dem Zeitpunkt. Genau. Also auch, obwohl eigentlich steuerbefreit, aber nicht steuererklärungsbefreit. Das heißt, er hat also auch keine Steuererklärung für eine steuerbefreite Organisation abgegeben, was deren Status als steuerbefreite Organisation gefährdet. Der hat also mehrere Sachen einfach falsch gemacht. Und in dem Moment, wo die Finanzfahndung – und da gibt es ja wohl bei der IRS, wie die heißt, Internal Revenue Service, also das Finanzamt mit all seinen vielen Ausbuchtungen – da gibt es eben einen Mann, Steve Berryman, der kommt von der Ecke an das Thema ran. Und aus der Ecke kommt man an Chuck Blaser ran. Und aus der Ecke kommt man daran, Chuck Blaser zu bitten, doch zu helfen. Und Chuck Blaser sieht einem keine andere Möglichkeit als zu helfen.
Zu bitten, zu helfen, finde ich einen schönen Euphemismus an der Stelle. Also sie sind da mit den gesammelten Erkenntnissen zu ihm hin und haben gesagt, so das alles wissen wir über dich. Die Sache ist jetzt so, entweder du holst dir einen Anfall und dann geht es vor Gericht, dann wird es richtig, richtig teuer. Oder du arbeitest jetzt ab jetzt für uns Undercover und wir geben dir eine mildere Strafe, das was du schon skizziert hast.
Ja und das gehört nun mal zu den Dingen, die ich meine, es gibt ja den berühmten Fall, bei der Mafia, auch dort wurden Leute wegen anderer Delikte überführt, also wegen Steuergeschichten oder so, weil man eben die anderen Dinge nicht belegen kann oder keine Zeugen dafür hat oder so. Aber hier in unserer Geschichte handelt es sich wirklich nur erst mal um den Hebel, mit dem man oder dieser Hammer, mit dem man unter irgendeiner Tür reingeht, um etwas anzuheben oder so. Da kommt man dann weiter und mit diesen Schritten kommt man dann auch näher an den Punkt, der ja dann bis zu dieser riesigen Verhaftungsaktion 2015 in Zürich abläuft. Aber wir wissen auch, dass alles braucht unglaublich viel Zeit. Und deshalb, ja.
Wir versuchen da mal ein bisschen durch die Zeit hindurch zu fliegen, so schwierig es ist, weil es sehr viel passiert ist. Aber du hast es ja gerade schon das Wichtigste genannt. Es gibt im Grunde zwei Untersuchungen, die erst getrennt voneinander liefen und dann auf einmal haben sich zwei US-Behörden zusammengetan. Nämlich einmal die Steuerfinanzbehörde mit diesem Steve Barryman in Kalifornien, der sich für Fußball interessiert und dann irgendwie auf den Namen Jack Blaser kam, also unseren großen Weihnachtsmann. Ihr erinnert euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und festgestellt hat, ach, der hat ja nicht mal Steuererklärungen eingereicht. Und das ist nun wirklich sehr verdächtig, wenn man gleichzeitig weiß, unser Weihnachtsmann wohnt im Trump Tower.
Und hat nicht nur ein Apartment, sondern zwei.
Genau, das zweite.
Und das zweite ist nur für die Katzen.
Unglaublich. Unglaublich. Also er hat einen sehr, sehr modernen Lebensstil geprägt. Es gibt bis heute noch, kann man das im Internet finden, Jack Blaser and his Friends. Das ist ein Reise- und Foodblog, würde ich es nennen, wo er sich damit schmückt, dass er eben Nesemandela, Wladimir Putin und andere Größen getroffen hat und immer sehr ausgiebig darüber schreibt, wo man was gegessen hätte. Und wir erinnern uns, dieser Mann ist einfach dick wie ein Zwei-Mann-Zelt, also fast schon grotesk. Also auf den wird eben die Steuerbehörde an dem Punkt aufmerksam und denkt sich, Moment mal, das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen, der Lebensstil und das Nicht-Einreichen von Steuererklärung. Und es läuft aber gleichzeitig noch eine FBI- Untersuchung erstmal wegen anderer Dinge. In der Abteilung für organisierte Kriminalität im eurasischen Raum ist man auf Informationen gestoßen, die rund um die WM-Vergabe 2018 nach Russland zu tun hatten. Damit wie da eventuell über Schmiergeldzahlungen die Stimmen erkauft wurden. Und diese beiden eigentlich voneinander getrennten Behörden arbeiten dann ab einem gewissen Punkt miteinander zusammen. Und dann bekommt auch diese ganze Ermittlung eine ganz andere Wucht. Denn über die Möglichkeiten der Steuerbehörden kann man Finanzströme aufdecken. Weil es eben ganz oft so ist, selbst wenn wir zwei jetzt Offshore-Konten hätten, du in Panama, ich in den Cayman Islands. Und ich sage, Jürgen, als Dank für die Folge jetzt, kriegst du von mir, ach komm, mach mal eine Million. Die schicke ich dir einfach von meinem Cayman Islands Konto zu deinem panamaischen Konto. Dann läuft das in ganz, ganz vielen Fällen über eine Vermittlerbank, wenn diese beiden anderen, kleineren Banken nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Und sobald diese Bank auf US-Grund steht oder eine Dependance in den USA hat, dann kann sich die Steuerbehörde da Auskünfte erfragen, die sie dann auch bekommen muss, qua Gesetz.
Allerdings auf der Basis von schon vorher erarbeiteten Grundverdachtsansätzen.
Genau, also nicht einfach so.
Sie kann nicht einfach so überall nachgucken, es gibt da nicht den gläsernen Steuerzahler. Es gibt aber noch eine andere Informationsstütze. Banken – und dazu sind sie im Rahmen internationaler Abkommen inzwischen in fast allen Ländern verpflichtet – haben zu melden Beträge, die eine Größenordnung haben, die einen bestimmten unerklärten Verdacht generieren. Sie müssen das nicht an die Polizei oder an das Finanzamt melden, sie müssen es an eine zentrale Stelle melden, wo diese Informationen gesammelt werden und sie werden auch nicht ständig durchleuchtet. Aber in dem Moment, wo Informationsbedarf besteht, kommt die Ermittlungsbehörde ohne Probleme und ohne richterliche Hilfe an diese Dateien heran und kann also schauen, gibt es da irgendwelche Meldungen, die für sich nichts erklären, aber die zumindest weiter Verdachts- und Anhaltspunkte liefern. Und so kann das Bild eben ganz langsam zusammenkommen. Aber auch hier wieder der Faktor Zeit, das geht teilweise nicht einfach nur über eine schnelle Internetschaltung und ein Passwort irgendwo in den Computer. Da müssen wieder bestimmte Leute auch wieder ihr Platzet geben und sagen, ja okay, hier ist die Information und so weiter. Also nur damit man nochmal versteht. Sowas ist eben unglaublich zäh. Und wenn man sich dann gleichzeitig aber vorstellt, es kann durchaus sein, dass dann irgendwann mal jemand die Reißleine zieht und sagt, also Leute, das ist mir alles zu lang hier, das ist alles so detaillierter Scheiß, wir haben doch hier ganz andere Verbrecher, was soll das? Nur dann kann auch sowas versickern und dann ist der ganze Anfang, den wir gerade versuchen zu beschreiben, der ist für die Katz. Da wird nichts draus. Und ich glaube, dass eben dieser Termin – du hast ja netterweise so eine wunderbare Zeitleiste auch zusammengestellt – 2013, wo Havilla ins Bild kommt.
Also unser Hotdog-Verkäufer mit den TV-Sendern.
Ich glaube, da passiert was Spezielles, weil das ist dann mehr die Arbeit der Polizei, also der Steuerfahnder oder der FBI-Leute. Die müssen auch verstehen, wie sowas funktioniert. Die machen manchmal auch Systemtests, da müssen dann alle Friseure ihre Steuererklärung ganz genau erklären, damit sie wissen, wie bescheißen Friseure. Das wissen die ja nicht, das müssen die ja erst mal rausarbeiten. Und in dem Moment, wo sie jemanden finden können, der ihnen erklären kann, wie geht das System aus der Fernsehecke, da haben sie nicht nur jetzt eine Person, der möglicherweise dann weitere benennen kann. Sie haben auch zum ersten Mal bekommen sie auch ein Bild. Also das, was Loretta Lynch dann am Ende 2015 in ihrer Pressekonferenz erklärend anbietet und sagt, also unter dem Dach der FIFA, unter dem Dach von so und so laufen folgende Geschichten ab. Dazu braucht es die Ermittlungsarbeit von Leuten, die das einfach erst mal so, was wir jetzt heute auch machen, die das alles erst mal zusammensetzen. Und da finde ich, ist eben dieser Termin 2013, der ist schon sehr wichtig. Also du hast es ja in deinem fantastischen Papier hier erklärt, den Behörden, die Bestechungssysteme.
Und denen sind die Augen übergegangen, weil die an dem Punkt, also erstmal war es so Chuck Blazer, also unser Weihnachtsmann, hat erstmal den Behörden, den Namen Jose Havilla, unser Hotdog-Verkäufer mit den TV-Sendern, hat denen erstmal den Namen erstmals genannt. Und die wussten damals gar nicht, obwohl die da schon über anderthalb Jahre in den Ermittlungen hingen, der Name hatte ihnen erstmal gar nichts gesagt. Und so erst kamen sie auf ihn und dann wurden sie seiner irgendwann habhaft. Anfang 2013 konnte er dann eben zum Kronzeugen überzeugt werden, weil man so viel gegen ihn in der Hand hatte, dass er sich da beim besten Willen nicht mehr gegenwähren konnte. Und dann hat er ihnen im Nachhinein ganz viel von den Dingen, die sie schon recherchiert hatten, dann quasi miteinander verknüpft und hat ihnen die Mechanismen erklärt. Wie funktioniert Bestechung im Fußballumfeld rund um TV-Rechte?
Ja, und ich bin auch sicher, dass das ungefähr der Zeitpunkt ist, wo die überlegt haben, okay, wir haben jetzt hier so viel Zeug, jetzt können wir den Rest der Welt auch vergessen. Jetzt können wir mal uns wirklich beschäftigen mit Nordamerika. Die Logik ist Sitz von Conker Cuff in den USA, viele Banken in den USA, viele Meetings in den USA. Also das ist die Rechtslogik, warum greift der amerikanische Staat da ein? Und welche Leute kommen denn jetzt für dieses Ganze in Frage? Und ich glaube, dass die nächste Phase bis 2005 dann wirklich darum gegangen ist, rauszukriegen, wen müssen wir jetzt wirklich einsammeln? Und das kann man auf verschiedene Arten machen. Wenn man eben mit anderen Ländern zu tun bekommt, kann man nicht einfach die Leute, alle Eichmann, irgendwie da einfangen und exportieren, sondern dann muss man halt gucken. Und wenn die nicht dauernd in den USA sind, ist es schwer, sie zu kriegen. Und das Geschick dieser, oder die besondere Leistung dieser staatsanwaltschaftlichen Arbeit besteht darin, die Schweizer Behörden dazu zu bringen, dass sie sagen, okay, ihr Rechtshilfe, wir möchten, dass ihr die festnehmt und ausliefert. Und dazu musste natürlich jede Menge Zeug auf den Tisch gebracht werden, weil das lässt in der Schweiz, da sagen die nicht, oh, ihr seid die Amerikaner, nett, dass ihr euch meldet. Ja, wir hätten hier so ein paar FIFA-Leute. Weil das geht ja auch um bestimmte Leute und es geht nicht um jeden und es geht um bestimmte Sachverhalte. Und da ist jemand wie, das ist also jetzt in dem Fall Jeffrey Webb, der wurde dann auch in der ersten Anklageschrift als der Mann ganz oben, dessen Name kam als erster, der dann also zu dem Zeitpunkt der Nachfolger von Warner bei der CONCACAF und der Nachfolger auch auf seinem Stuhl in der FIFA Exekutive als FIFA Vizepräsident und auch sogar von Blatter schon verkauft als der mögliche Blatterner Nachfolger, den wollte man haben. Und da gibt es wieder interessante Details, die sind für das, was wir heute besprechen, relativ unwichtig, aber vielleicht illustrativ. So Jeffrey Webb ist mit einer Amerikanerin verheiratet. Jeffrey Webb lebt sehr oft in den USA. Jeffrey Webb hat Immobilien in den USA, in Georgia. Das heißt, er ist als Person viel plastischer auch zu erklären. Ich kann jetzt plötzlich dem Schweizer Rechtshilfe ersuchen, kann ich unterfüttern und sagen, Leute, es geht mir nicht um irgendjemanden, es geht mir um den. Und wenn der nicht in den USA auftaucht, habe ich Schwierigkeiten. Also das ist, glaube ich, 2013, Havilla und dann die Kulmination. Da kommt Tempo ins Spiel.
Ja, absolut. Und man darf sich über den Umfang dieser Ermittlungen keinerlei Illusionen machen. Allein in dem laufenden aktuellen Prozess in Brooklyn wurden 340.000 Seiten an Beweismaterial durchgesprochen in den Untersuchungstagen. Also eine unglaubliche Masse an Beweisen, die da zusammengetragen werden mussten. Um kurz mal zu beschreiben, was eigentlich damit gemeint ist, wenn wir sagen, ein Chuck Blaser, unser dicker Weihnachtsmann oder José Havilla, der Hotdog-Verkäufer mit den TV-Sendern, die haben mit den Behörden zusammengearbeitet, gezwungenermaßen. Was bedeutet zusammengearbeitet? Es bedeutet zum einen, dass sie sich der Verbrechen einiger Verbrechen schuldig bekennen müssen und dafür dann hohe Strafen zahlen. Also Chuck Blaser hat dann irgendwann zwei Millionen US-Dollar zahlen müssen und José Havilla, da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, 151 Millionen US-Dollar. Davon 25 Millionen US-Dollar in dem Moment, in dem er sich schuldig bekannt hat vor der Richterin. Also unglaubliche Summen, die auch klarmachen, was für Geldsummen da eigentlich im Umlauf waren, dass man sowas überhaupt als Strafe festmachen kann. Das wird ja errechnet aus den Vermögenswerten und so weiter, die da unrechtmäßig erworben wurden von den Grundzeugen. Und die müssen dann ausführlich nicht nur Geständnisse ablegen, sondern eben auf alle Fragen antworten. Wenn ihnen nachgewiesen wird, dass sie bei irgendetwas die Unwahrheit gesagt haben, dann drohen hohe Strafen. Denn das ist dann das Belügen einer Ermittlungsbehörde. Das sind in den USA sind da hohe Strafen drauf. Grad Javier hat sich da nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert, aber das ist jetzt auch ein Detail. Und was eben auch passiert ist, und das war ganz, ganz wichtig für die Ermittlungen, war, die konnten auch von den US-Behörden dazu gezwungen werden, ihre Komplizen, ihre Mitarbeiter, andere Funktionäre auszuheusen. Also Chuck Blazer wurde da mit einem Schlüsselband, der präpariert war, unter anderem bei den Olympischen Spielen in London, vom FBI quasi von Tisch zu Tisch fast schon dirigiert und sollte dann versuchen, die Leute zu Aussagen zu bewegen, die dann wiederum aufgenommen wurden und als Beweismittel im weiteren Verfahren eingesetzt werden konnten. Und so konnte man auch an Javida rankommen, der eigentlich ja gar nicht auf dem Plan stand, aber den hat man mit solchen Aussagen dann die Beweise so erdrückend ihm gegenüber gemacht, dass er dann gesagt hat, okay, gut, er macht dasselbe Spiel auch und Javida selbst hat das dann auch getan. Also die haben eben auch, haben Leute angerufen und haben im Grunde versucht, die dazu zu bewegen, dass die on tape, also während die Aufnahmerekorder des FBI liefen, sich verbrechensschuldig bekennen und so ging das dann Stückchen für Stückchen weiter. Das heißt, das ist so richtig, also da wird es dann von schon fast Agentenroman mäßig, wenn man sich mit diesen einzelnen Teilen des Prozesses auseinandersetzt. Kurze Zwischenepisode da noch vielleicht, wie man versucht hat, Jack Warner zu bekommen. Auch weil wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, Jack Warner so der Mastermind, derjenige der es wirklich fast schon zur Perfektion getrieben hat, wenn es da eine Perfektion gibt, der wäre ein ganz ganz wichtiger Kronzeuge gewesen, gerade weil er so eng mit Sepp Blatter verbandelt war und die beiden einen gemeinsamen Weg teilen und das schon seit vielen vielen Jahren und das hat man nicht hinbekommen. Man hat es versucht, indem er hatte diplomatische Immunität, weil er eben dieses Ministeramt innehatte in Trinidad und Tobago, seine Söhne, aber nicht.
Und auch Abgeordneter war.
Genau, er war Abgeordneter und generell mit sehr vielen Wassern, nicht nur den reinsten, gewaschen und dann war das Ziel, man kriegt ihn über die Söhne. Wir haben es vorhin kurz angesprochen, aber ich wollte es noch mal hier in Erinnerung rufen, was da passiert ist am, das war glaube ich sogar Thanksgiving, da waren sie alle in Miami zusammen, die haben alle haben die tolle Apartments auf der ganzen Welt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer und einige davon auch in den USA und das war natürlich dann der Zugriffsmoment für die US-Behörden und dann hat man eben die Warner Brothers, Darien und Darrell festgenommen und hat im Zuge dieser Festnahme haben die US-Behörden versucht, Jack Warner zum Auspacken zu bewegen und er ist aber der Einzige, zumindest nach dem, was man weiß, der, der diesem Druck standgehalten hat und gesagt hat, nee ich sag euch gar nichts, ihr könnt mal versuchen mir was nachzuweisen, ich sitze jetzt gleich wieder auf meiner Insel, der ist dann direkt danach nach Trinidad und Tobago zurückgeflogen und nie wieder in die USA Du bist in die USA eingereist und da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie ihr mich kriegen wollt. Und das wäre vielleicht der eine Grundzeuge gewesen, der diese ganzen Ermittlungen noch mal auf die Ebene Blatter hätte heben können. So im Nachhinein würde ich sagen, das war die gläserne Decke, an die man gestoßen ist.
Ja, weil, aber das wäre jetzt wirklich nur, auch um dieses Argument von Blatter zu entkräften. Also es sind immer nur einzelne Personen und die Organisation, die ist natürlich hochedel und hochsehend. Das ist bisher nicht wirklich passiert. Natürlich haben Kollegen auch wie Thomas Kistner und andere das natürlich schon sehr gut dargestellt. Ja, das stimmt natürlich alles nicht. Aber von der Seite der Arbeit der Ermittlungsbehörden, wie korrupt ist eigentlich die FIFA? Dass sie korrupt ist, ist ja völlig klar. Aber uns geht es inzwischen darum, festzustellen, wie korrupt sie ist. Und damit sind auch bestimmte Verhaltensmuster sehr viel besser zu erklären. Ich spreche noch mal ganz kurz von dieser Transaktion, Stichwort 2006, Deutschland, Sommermärchen, wo Geld über die FIFA kanalisiert wird, um dann beim Adidas-Chef zu landen. Es ist schier unverständlich, dass so etwas möglich ist. Und da kann man nicht behaupten, ja, das gibt es manchmal. Aber die FIFA selber ist nicht korrupt. Natürlich ist sie korrupt, weil sie zeigt an diesen Stellen, also an den Stellen, wo es darum gehen würde, das zu verhindern, an diesen, oder auch bei der Aufklärung dann zu helfen, an diesen Stellen zeigt sie ganz genau, dass sie korrupt ist. Aber das Ausmaß dieses Korruptions, dieses korrupten Verhaltens, das kennen wir jetzt nicht. Und ich glaube, da wäre wirklich Warner. Aber der hat auch immer viel den Mund voll genommen, was er alles immer auspacken würde und so.
Die Welt würde ein Fußball-Tsunami erleben, hat er gesagt, nachdem er von seinen Ämtern zurücktreten musste im Zuge dieser 40.000 Dollar in Umschlägen-Affäre und so wirklich. Also wenn, dann war es nur ein kleines Welchen, was davon ankam.
Ja und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass – also ich würde das auch hoffen – dass was hauptsächlich dabei rauskommen würde, wenn er wirklich auspacken würde, was er für ein Stinkefinger ist, was er alles angestellt hat, was teilweise er auch bekannt ist, aber trotzdem – das würde vielleicht mal belegt – der hat – der ist eine eigene Preisklasse. Also Blatter hat das bestimmt immer wieder, das ist meine Vermutung, verstanden. Erstens hat er ja auch viel mehr Geld verdient in seiner Rolle. Ich meine, wir schätzen, dass es so irgendwie am Ende bei drei bis vier Millionen Dollar im Jahr war oder so. Dass er also gar nicht dieses Bedürfnis entwickelt hat, irgendwo persönlich sich zu bereichern, und wenn er irgendwo hinreisen wollte auf der Mission, ich hätte gerne den Friedensnobelpreis, dann gab es Möglichkeiten, dahin zu kommen. Und er konnte halt flanieren und er konnte sich groß tun und er konnte in Fernsehstudios sitzen und er konnte zu Veranstaltungen und er konnte Orden kassieren von zig Ländern und so weiter. Dem mangelte es an nichts und ich glaube, der hatte persönlich gar nicht diese kriminelle Energie. Bei Blatter ist das Problem wirklich, dass er das alles sehenden Auges zugelassen hat. Statt bei Herrn Lauber anzurufen und zu sagen, wollen Sie mal wissen, was hier eigentlich los ist. Ich kann das nicht, ich kann das irgendwie… Also was dieser Gondoner da angestellt hat, als Chef des Finanzausschusses und damit auch als mächtiger Mann, in bestimmten Dingen einfach sogar mächtiger als Blatter, das muss Blatter ja kapiert haben, was da los war. Damit ist er aber nicht dahin gegangen, wo man hingehen müsste. Also ich glaube, dass das Warner auch nicht so stark beurteilen konnte oder dokumentieren konnte, was da gelaufen ist. Aber ich mag falsch liegen, wie schon so oft im Leben.
Na ja, Sepp Blatter hat halt auch von den Besten gelernt. Also die Rolle von Horst Dassler, von Joao Avalanche in diesem ganzen FIFA-Komplex, da haben sich Strukturen etabliert, die durchgezogen wurden. Und wäre nicht die ISL, also der eigene Vermarkter, insorvent gegangen, weil die Schmiergeld-Forderungen so horrond wurden, dass man das nicht mehr gegenfinanzieren konnte, dann wüssten wir auch so viel weniger über diesen ganzen FIFA-Komplex. Und da kann sich natürlich ein Sepp Blatter hinstellen, kann sagen, also mein Name ist Hase, ich wusste davon gar nichts. Übrigens hat er direkt nach den Festnahmen in Zürich auch gesagt, ich wusste davon schon ewig, dass die US-Behörden das machen würden. Das war mit mir abgesprochen quasi. Völlig genügend, inzwischen deutlich dokumentiert, aber das ist einfach bei jeder Realität, das kann so nicht gewesen sein. Es gibt personelle Verflechtungen, die sind fast schon grotesk. Also ist jetzt ein anderes Thema, aber wenn man nur mal recherchiert, wo sitzen eigentlich so die Verwandten und besten Freunde von Sepp Blatter? Ach, mit denen hat er ja über TV-Rechte verhandelt, weil der war ja plötzlich bei Infront sein Lieblingsneffe und solche Dinge.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, da kann man ihnen direkt nichts wollen, das haben ja andere.
Genau, kann er nichts dafür, wenn die den einstellen, zufälligst mit Neffen.
Und ich glaube, diese Platini-Geldtransaktion ist der Klassiker in der Blatterwelt. Dass er da also zig Jahre nach dem angeblich ausgehandeltes Gehalt, wofür es dann auch gar kein Dokument gibt, aber das ist ja für die Vertragswirksamkeit nicht der entscheidende Faktor, bei der Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit wird es natürlich eine Rolle spielen. Aber dass er zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es interessant wird und es wieder um Bewerbungen geht und so weiter, weil Platini eventuell Ambitionen hat, auf den Posten auf dem Blatter sitzt, ein paar Jahre nach der abgeschmetterten Bin Hamam Bewerbung, in dem Moment wird das Geld ausgeschüttet. Und er behauptet, das behauptet er ja noch heute, also das sei alles völlig okay gewesen. Vielleicht hätte er das früher bezahlen sollen, aber ein Ehrenmann bezahlt seine Schulden. Ja und solche Tricks und solche Sachen am Rande der Legalität hat er sicherlich zuhauf drauf gehabt. Wenn mal Leute aus dem Interna wirklich bereit wären, zu erzählen, das wäre schon interessant. Und weiß dort auch nicht jeder alles. Also es gab ja jetzt zum Beispiel eine ARD-Dokumentation vor der WM oder zu Beginn der WM über Russland und da kam jemand vor die Kamera ein, Herr Koch glaube ich, der mal als Pressesprecher fungiert hat bei der FIFA. Und da freut man sich ja schon, dass da jemand mal was sagt. Aber es gibt auch andere Leute, die mal bei der FIFA gearbeitet haben. Es gibt einen Schweizer Parlamentsabgeordneten, der immer wieder vorgeführt wird. Oder es gibt Guido Tonioni, der ist sozusagen der ewige Zeitzeuge. Der Stänger der FIFA, der Harald Stänger der FIFA, der aber auch nie was Konkretes sagt. Der kann nur sagen, ja das ist auf jeden Fall verdächtig oder so. Und auch Herr Koch kann uns leider gar nichts sagen. Aber es gibt in diesem Organigramm Leute, die wussten was. Also, mir fällt jetzt gerade der Name. Und die hätten es auch belegen können. Zen Ruffinen fällt mir ein. Es gab diese Phase, wo der war der Generalsekretär.
Genau, der war dann Generalsekretär.
Der wollte dann mal ein bisschen den Vorhang aufmachen. Das hat auch nichts gebracht. Aber da gibt es genug. Das müssten allerdings die Schweizer mal wirklich genauer anpacken.
Da kommen dann die Schweizer Verhältnisse rein. Ich möchte an der Stelle aber einmal noch mal kurz den Horizont öffnen und dieses Zitat einspielen.
Man kann doch den Fußball nicht verkaufen. Der Fußball gehört nicht der FIFA.
Und ich wollte das Zitat deshalb ansprechen. Ich wollte keinen Lacher damit provozieren, sondern Sepp Blatter hat da ja recht. Der Fußball gehört nicht der FIFA. Und das möchte ich noch einmal ganz kurz, bevor wir dann jetzt weiter im Prozess durchrutschen, nochmal ansprechen. Wir werfen hier mit Millionensummen um uns herum, die als Strafen gezahlt werden, die als Bestechungsgelder gezahlt wurden. Da sind die 40.000 in so einem Umschlag auf einem Conker-Cuff-Treffen, damit Bin Hamam FIFA-Präsident wird. Das ist ein kleiner Klacks gegen die Summen, die wir hier nennen. Aber wir müssen uns immer klar machen, woher kommen diese Summen? Die Summen kommen von den Sponsoren, sie kommen von den Fußballfans. Und wohin sollten diese Summen eigentlich gehen? In die Fußballverbände. Also das, was sich die FIFA auf die Fahnen schreibt, nämlich dass man eine Basisarbeit fördern würde, dass man das Spiel Fußball, das hätte die Welt so toll, vereinen würde, dass man das nach vorne bringt und damit auch die Welt verbessert. Das ist ja nicht etwas, was ich jetzt gerade reininterpretiere, sondern diesen Anspruch trägt die FIFA in Person von Sepp Blatter seit Jahrzehnten vor sich her. Genau diesem Anspruch wird sie nicht gerecht, weil da Gelder verschwinden, die eben, womit du Tausende Millionen von Fußballfeldern über den ganzen Planeten platzieren könntest, mit denen du Entwicklungsarbeit machen könntest. Der Fußball hat ja eine Kraft, der Sport kann eine Kraft haben, die Welt zu verändern. Das ist ja nicht komplett gelogen. Du könntest allein, wie du im Bereich der Frauenrechte mit dem Sport Dinge erreichen kannst. Das haben wir jetzt ja auch im Verlauf dieser WM gesehen. Aber diese Gelder sind zum Teil eben nicht da, weil sie abgezweigt wurden. Und das ist schon, das muss man sich immer wieder vor Augen halten. Das sind, weil man denkt sich auch, naja gut, dann hat halt da Coca-Cola irgendwie Teile des Geldes, was aus dem Sponsoring kommt, das ist halt bei irgendwelchen Leuten gelandet, die sich davon dann ein wunderbares Leben gemacht haben. Aber man muss sich schon hin und wieder fragen, wo ist das Geld nicht gelandet? Und da landest du dann nämlich, wenn du es ganz plakativ machen willst, bei dem kleinen Jungen, der irgendwo in Pakistan kein Fußball spielen kann, weil er kein Fußballfeld hat.
Ja, und wir landen auch bei einer verschobenen Bewertung von Akteuren in diesem Ganzen. Und es ist gar nicht so, heute inzwischen gar nicht mehr so schwierig, auch auf deutsche Akteure aufmerksam zu machen. Es ist natürlich wichtig, bei dem Thema, bei dem wir sind, auf die Leute zu sprechen zu kommen, die uns geholfen haben, als Südamerikaner das Thema besser zu verstehen. Aber Personen wie Franz Beckenbauer, wie Uli Hoeneß und deren Verhalten sind genauso. Oder Niersbach. Es gibt genug Personen, die alle irgendwie durchgekommen sind bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt. Und warum war das möglich? Weil sie intern in der Lage waren, Dinge geschickt zu verschleiern oder wegzuerklären. Und weil sie dann als ein bisschen Druck kamen, konnten sie sich noch immer ein bisschen rausreden und erst als die Behörden dann wirklich mal ernst gemacht haben, kam es dann zu Ermittlungen, die uns allen geholfen haben. Das Image, dass jemand wie Hoeneß seitdem er da aktiv ist, als Manager verkörpert, ist einfach nicht korrekt. Und dass jemand, der dann nach so einer Geschichte wieder ins Leben zurückrehabilitiert wird auf eine Art und Weise, wie weit über das hinausgeht, was ich erwarten würde als jemand, der sich fragt, also wie weit sollte Rehabilitation gehen, als wäre nie was gewesen, das kann es ja wohl nicht sein. Oder wie Beckenbauer jetzt da irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch unangetastet durchkommt, das sind alles wichtige Fragen. Ich meine, ich glaube schon, dass das Image dieser Menschen teilweise beschädigt ist, aber es gibt Leute, die leiden unter solchen Dingen viel mehr. Also ich habe mal für eine Geschichte für den Deutschlandfunk mich mit dem Thema Korruption beschäftigt und da einen ehemaligen Beamten im bayerischen Finanzministerium interviewt, der heißt Wilhelm Schlötterer, der war bei der ersten Steuergeschichte von Franz Beckenbauer, als er glaubte, er könnte mit Hilfe der Schweiz sich um ein paar deutsche Mark drücken. Der war derjenige, der versucht hat zu verhindern, intern, dass das also weggedrückt wird auf die bayerische Art. Und der hat am Ende seinen Job verloren. Inzwischen hat er ein Buch geschrieben und der ist ab und zu auch in Talkshows oder sowas, wenn es um solche Dinge geht. Aber der hat mir dann gesagt, das hat mir nicht gut getan. Ich habe darauf bestanden, dass hier nach Recht und Gesetz vorgegangen wird und nicht etwa diesen prominenten Fußballspielern ein Pardon gewählt wird. Man muss das Gesetz auf alle gleichmäßig anwenden, sonst verliert man die Legitimität, gegen andere vorzugehen. Und das ist zwar ein sehr abstraktes Thema, aber für mich ein sehr wichtiges Thema, weil eine Form der selektiven Gnade vorab, wie auch immer, oder nicht richtig hingucken, ist etwas, was eine Gesellschaft nicht brauchen kann. Sie braucht bestimmte Grundsätze, wie zum Beispiel die Gleichheit vor dem Gesetz. Und wenn das nicht gewährt ist, und da ist der Sport eben insgesamt, und Fußball im Besonderen, eben genau an der Stelle. Fußball ist eben inzwischen so viele Millionen schwer, dass es da wirklich um einen Wirtschaftsfaktor geht und um einen gesellschaftlichen Faktor geht, den man nicht einfach in diese Spielzeugladenwelt abtun kann. Ich meine, das sieht man auch daran, welche Leute da im Hintergrund Karriere machen können. Ich meine, und es gibt die Größe, es gibt viele Überraschungen. Ich will das fast wirklich nicht weiter aufmachen. Aber wie da ein Richter im DFB-Vorstand arbeiten kann und im Zweifel eher nicht wie immer alles in Ordnung sagen kann, ist mir ein Rätsel. Der müsste eigentlich die Gesetze und deren Auslegung müsste er eigentlich gut kennen und also auch eine kritische Beziehung zu der eigenen Verbandsrealität haben. Aber das scheint nicht der Fall zu sein.
Nein, das scheint nicht der Fall zu sein. Aber immerhin gab es ja dann die Verhaftungen in Zürich und da müssen wir jetzt noch mal kurz klarmachen. Der Vorlauf waren vier Jahre, vier Jahre Ermittlungsarbeit und dann war man so weit, dass man sagen konnte, wir haben jetzt eine Liste von Beklagten und wir haben so viele Beweise, dass auch die Schweizer Behörden, die nicht immer kooperativ sind in so einem Fall, sagen, okay gut, wir helfen euch, die Inderschweiz festzunehmen und danach auch an die USA auszuliefern. Hat nicht immer geklappt, werden wir vielleicht noch gleich darüber sprechen. Aber das hat dann stattgefunden und zwar am 27. Mai 2015. Ich spiele noch mal die Collage, die du da zusammengeschnitten hast zu.
Das ist eine Bombe, die da heute geplatzt ist in Zürich.
In Zürich sind sechs Funktionäre des Fußball-Weltverbandes verhaftet worden. Die Verhaftungen erfolgen am frühen Morgen vor dem Zürcher Nobelhotel Burolac.
Genau. Und das war die Bombe, die eingeschlagen hat. Ab dann erst. Wir haben jetzt über ganz viele Dinge gesprochen, über einen Zeitraum, wo wir alle nur ahnen konnten, es gibt Ermittlungen. Zwischendurch gab es auch mal Berichte, die lautet, Chuck Blaser würde mit dem FBI zusammenarbeiten. Allerdings nicht in dem Umfang, wie man es jetzt wusste. Von Hawila wusste man damals überhaupt nichts, unserem Hotdog-Verkäufer, der unglaublich wichtig war. Und es gab auch noch andere Kronzeugen, die wir jetzt einfach mal aussparen. Es gibt ja genügend Literatur, die man dazu lesen kann. Und dann eben diese Verhaftungen. Und es konnten sieben Angeklagte festgenommen werden. Unter anderem Jeffrey Webb, von dem du schon erzählt hast. Das war unter anderem deswegen so wichtig und bedeutend, weil er sich natürlich als der Reformer im Konker-Cuff als Nachfolger von Jack Warner präsentiert hat, als derjenige, der jetzt da mal ordentlich aufräumt. Und Sepp Blatter hat ihn schon als zukünftigen FIFA-Präsidenten mal angekündigt. Also er war so ein bisschen der Kronprinz und auch er wurde da festgenommen. Deswegen war das eine große Sache. Es wurde noch später am Tag auch in den USA Aaron Davidson festgenommen. Der war Chef derjenigen Sportvermarkterfirma, die José Javilla, also unserem Hotdog-Verkäufer, gehört hat und war dann auch ganz wichtig. Ein Angeklagter hat sich noch abgesetzt nach Italien. Alejandro Bursaco, über den wir gleich auch noch sprechen, hat später ausgesagt. Er hat sich in Italien den Behörden gestellt und ist dann auch in die USA ausgeliefert worden. Ich mache mal einen kleinen Spoiler. Er hat dann Schmiergeldzahlungen in Höhe von 150 Millionen US-Dollar gestanden und musste als Strafe fast 22 Millionen US-Dollar an die USA zahlen und hat dann eben im Prozess ausgesagt. Also die manchmal wird einem schwindelig, wenn man sich mit den Summen beschäftigt. Und jetzt sind wir dann an der Stelle angekommen, wo wir sagen können, ok, worum geht es denn jetzt in dem FIFA-Prozess? Viele Dinge wurden angedeutet, viele Dinge wurden im dunklen recherchiert und jetzt haben wir zum ersten Mal eine Pressekonferenz, in der sich eben Loretta Lynch, unsere kleine US-Justizministerin äußert. Und wir hören noch mal kurz rein, was Loretta Lynch in dieser PK gesagt hat. Genau, also nachdem, was sie vorhin schon, haben wir vorhin schon eingespielt, was sie gesagt hat, wer alles betroffen ist. Geht es darum, Korruption aufzudecken und damit diese Practice of Corruption zu einem Ende zu bringen? Die Anklage lautete dann auf Erpressung, Betrug, Schmiergezahlung und Geldwäsche über zwei Jahrzehnte hinweg. Sie haben unter anderem in der Pressekonferenz allein die Kuppa America genannt mit 110 Millionen US-Dollarn an Schmiergeldern. Wie gesagt, ihr müsst euch immer nur überlegen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das sind nur die Schmiergelder, das ist nicht irgendwie Marketing-Rechte, es sind nur die Gelder, die, wie wenn ihr jetzt zu mir sagen würdet, ich finde den Rasenfunk zu toll, ich überweise den Millionen Euro, so ist dieses Geld zu behandeln, nur dass es dann oft auch nicht versteuert wird. Außerdem gab es auch aufgedeckt in dieser Anklage Schmiergeld für Stimmen zur WM-Vergabe und der FIFA-Präsidentenwahl sowie Schmiergelder von Nike an den südamerikanischen Fußballverband. Ganz eigenes, ganz großes Thema, da könnte man hunderte Sendungen zu machen, was da alles schiefgelaufen ist. Und das war dann die Bombe, die an diesem 27. Mai geplatzt ist. Und würdest du mir zustimmen, wenn ich sage, seitdem ist der Blick auf die FIFA ein anderer?
Ja, zum Glück. Weil alles andere war vorher so spekulativ. Und ja, also beispielsweise Andrew Jennings hat immer wieder sehr gute Ansätze gefunden, was vorzutragen. Auch rund um in der Zeit, als die Bewerbung, die jetzt dann in Russland, also für die WM, die jetzt in Russland ausgetragen wird, zum Beispiel England als Gegenkandidat da war. Und man konnte zum Beispiel erkennen, als es darum ging, dass Panorama nun journalistisch sauber und inhaltsschwer eine Sendung machen wollte, die also dieses System zumindest erklärt oder die Konfiguration erklärt. Da gab es intern in England, gab es schwersten Protest gegen die journalistische Arbeit von der BBC. Die wollten aus Sorge, dass das dazu führt, dass dann FIFA intern England als Schmutzfink dasteht. Die wollten das gar nicht auf dem Tisch haben. Das heißt also, das ist nochmal so ein Nebengeleis. Wozu führt Korruption? Es führt nicht nur dazu, dass die Dinge, die du jetzt zum Beispiel aufgezählt hast, passieren, sondern auch noch das Aufdecken von Korruption wird auch noch möglichst verhindert oder zumindest unterlaufen. Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass das eben in einigen Ländern ein wichtiger Faktor ist. Warum ist das nicht zum Beispiel in Südamerika ein Thema von sich aus gewesen, das zu Konsequenzen geführt hat? Die haben dort auch Ermittlungsbehörden, die haben dort auch Richter, die könnten auch einiges selber regeln. Aber da muss man eben, glaube ich, erkennen, dass – das ist ein Zitat von Schlötterer, den ich gerade erwähnt habe – die primitivste Form der Korruption ist, dass Geld gegeben wird und ein Vorteil gewährt wird. Aber es gibt eine indirekte Korruption, Willfähigkeit, der im Grunde überhaupt nicht beizukommen ist, die aber brandgefährlich ist. Dieses Milieu gehört eben auch in die Betrachtung mit reingearbeitet. Und wenn in dem Moment, wie jetzt diese Zürich-Geschichte, das so plakativ stattfindet und auch kein Medium auf der Welt sich dem entziehen kann, dann hat man plötzlich erstmal einen anderen Ansatzpunkt. Und wenn dann noch die ergänzenden Informationen, die dann später noch so dazu kommen, klarer machen – und das ist dann, habe ich ja gerade schon mal gesagt, irgendwann die Arbeit zum Beispiel der Staatsanwaltschaft, sich zu präsentieren und eine sehr ausgiebige Stellungnahme abzugeben und eine Anklageschrift vorzulegen, das ist ja das wichtigere Dokument, die sehr viel Genaues bereits mitliefert – dann kann man das nicht mehr einfach so wegdiskutieren, wie das von Schlotterer eben im Alltag des – ja, geht weder Korruption, nicht nur im Sport gesagt wird, dass diese Willfähigkeit, der man nicht einfach so bei kommen kann, die ist brandgefährlich.
Ja, völlig richtig. Vielleicht sieht man anhand des ganzen FIFA-Prozesses auch einfach nur, wie groß das Korruptionsthema weltweit ist auf allen Kontinenten und da kann man es mal nachvollziehen. Und vielleicht noch wichtig zu wissen – wir haben es ja vorhin schon thematisiert – es geht hier jetzt viel um Nordamerika, um die Karibik, um den südamerikanischen Fußballverband. Womit hat das zu tun? Das hat vor allem damit zu tun, dass die USA sehr, sehr genau darauf achten mussten, dass sie ihren Zuständigkeitsbereich nicht übertreten, damit auch die ganzen Auslieferungsgesuche, die Zusammenarbeit mit den Schweizer Behörden, dass das klappen kann. Und das hat James Comey, der ja später auch nochmal bekannter wurde, auch auf dieser Pressekonferenz schon sehr genau gesagt, wenn man genau hingehört hat. Ich spieß mal kurz ein.
Es ist ein Ehren, den US-Akturaten und den Bundesverfassungsvorsitzenden.
Genau, und das ist der wichtige Punkt. If you touch our shores, das heißt, sie haben genau die Dinge zur Anklage gebracht, die in einem Zusammenhang mit Treffen auf US-Boden, mit Verwendung von US-amerikanischen Banken zu tun hatten. Und als drittes Argument haben sie noch mit dazu genommen, dass auch der US-Markt, der wachsende US-Markt für Fußball wesentlich war, für Teile der Schmiergezahlung vor allem, natürlich im Conker Cup. Das heißt, das war die Argumentationsgrundlage. Und das ist, meine Meinung nach, der einzige Grund, warum wir hier die ganze Zeit über Conker Cup und auch ein bisschen über den kommenden Ball sprechen, also Südamerika und Nordamerika, weil das eben die Verbände waren, derer, die US-Behörden habhaft werden konnten. Aber das lässt nicht den Rückschluss zu. Alle anderen Verbände sind blitzsauber.
Ne, und die haben ja auch jemanden aus Guam irgendwann ausfindig gemacht, der mit dann nicht genauer bezeichneten Kuwaitis zusammengearbeitet hat, wo wir den Verdacht haben, um wen es sich handelt und wo man auch merkt, klar, der Globus ist rund und auch das Sportgeschäft ist rund. Und wenn man sich anguckt, was rund um das, was jetzt die französischen Ermittlungsbehörden bei dem Internationalen Leichtathletikverband mit M. Diak auf die Beine stellen an Wissen und Informationen, das geht auch in verschiedene Richtungen. Das betrifft dann nicht nur den Internationalen Leichtathletikverband, das betrifft das russische Staatstopping, das betrifft die Vergabepraktiken des IOC und so weiter und so weiter. Da kann sich auch eine Behörde, wie eine Staatsanwaltschaft in Brooklyn, auch total verlaufen und damit auch verzetteln. Ich würde gerne noch zwei Beobachtungen einstreuen. Ich glaube, es gibt zwei Facetten, warum die Amerikaner prädestiniert waren, sich dann wirklich hier damit zu beschäftigen. Nummer eins, wenn man sich anguckt, wie kommerzieller Sport in den USA durch die großen Ligen wie die NBA, die Major League Baseball, wie die NFL, National Football League, Eishockey sogar über die Grenzen hinweg bis hin nach Kanada rein, wie das dort organisiert ist und wie das dort auch nur ganz selten zu irgendwelchen Verdächtigungen führt. Also es gab mal in der NHL jemanden, der hat sich eine Besitzerschaft der New York Islanders quasi erschlichen. Der hat die Leute übertäubelt in der Liga, die sich genau angucken, wie viel Geld hat eigentlich jemand, der hier einen Club kaufen möchte oder so. Da gibt es also bestimmte Hürden und Verhaltensmuster, die ähneln mehr dem klassischen Prinzip, was man so bei Aktiengesellschaften kennen würde, also dem Anteilseigner pro Kopf oder pro Anteil der Mathematik. Wenn du mehr Anteile hast, hast du mehr zu sagen. Wenn du weniger Anteile hast, hast du weniger zu sagen. Unterm Strich, dass die Realität des amerikanischen Sportkommerses ist, von bestimmten Situationen abgesehen. Salt Lake City, die Bewerbung für die Winterspiele 2002 und der Korruptionsskandal minimal im Vergleich zu dem, was wir heute hier erleben. Aber auch da wurde damals USA intern aufgearbeitet. Man hat viele Mechanismen sofort gehabt, um etwas zu machen. Unter anderem in dem Fall auch das politische Element, sprich den Senat, der sofort eingestiegen ist, weil der Senat für die olympischen Sportarten eine wichtige Rolle spielt über die gesetzliche Verankerung, warum ist Sport so organisiert, wie es organisiert ist. Das ist ein Teil, das ist die Realität. Sport und Kommerz in den USA ist relativ verdachtsfrei, wenn es um solche Fragen wie Betrug geht. Das ist teilweise auch eingebaut mit in das System, in eine Liga, wo es keinen Aufstieg und keinen Abstieg geht. Und in einem Land, wo man also den Super Bowl kann man vergeben, mal nach Pasadena und mal nach Orlando oder sonst wo hin. Das ist alles harmlos. Es geht auch um Geld, aber das Geld wird nicht notwendigerweise zum Faktor für das Verhalten von Leuten, die kriminelle Projekte haben. Das andere ist, weil der Fußball in den USA aber nicht die große Rolle spielt, kann man auch der amerikanischen Öffentlichkeit gegenüber, tritt man nicht unbedingt so wie der hässliche Verteidiger auf, der jetzt anderen Leuten was vor Schienbein tritt.
Genau, du musst nicht ein Sommermärchen kaputt machen, um mal den Begleich zu nehmen.
Sondern man kann sich wirklich als, wie man hier vielleicht sagen würde, honest broker, so als ehrlicher Makler von bestimmten Interessen verhalten, wenn man das denn auch genau so dokumentiert und sauber abwickelt und nicht irgendwie so eine Machtspielkomponente hat. Und da sind eben in Amerika bestimmte Mechanismen. Ich meine, Loretta Lynch ist nicht länger Justizministerin, weil das System vorsieht, dass der nächste Präsident jemand anderen ins Amt bringt. In dem Moment, wo die Anklagen erhoben werden, liegt der Stoff bei einem Richter. Dieses Fass kann auch nicht mehr zu, diese Flasche kann nicht mehr zugemacht werden. Also das in dem Moment übernimmt ein anderer Teil der Justizbehörden. Und da gibt es so bestimmte, auch sehr transparente Elemente. Und insgesamt ist das amerikanische Justizwesen eben darauf aufgebaut, dass man auch sehr viel Publizität erlaubt, dass man also auch die Öffentlichkeit teilhaben lässt. Und nicht nur aus taktischen Gründen, sondern das ist der Anspruch. Ich möchte wissen, wie die Leute heißen, die da angeklagt werden. Ich darf das wissen. Ich möchte wissen, was die Polizei für Akten hat.
Genau, man kann die Anklageschriften runterladen.
Ja, und dadurch kommen die USA. Man sollte nicht verkennen, dass so im weltpolitischen Rahmen, ja, was, Weltpolizei und so weiter, die USA sind immer im Verdacht, mit imperialistischen Mitteln durch die Welt zu marschieren. Da würde ich auch als jemand, der hier lebt, bin ich da auch total kritisch und sehe das jetzt nicht, will das nicht verharmlosen. Aber ich glaube, das sind wichtige Kernbestandteile von einem Arbeitsprodukt, mit dem wir uns hier beschäftigen. Das passiert eben dann nicht unbedingt oder kann nicht überall passieren. Insofern fast ein Glücksfall, dass es sich so entwickelt hat.
Genau, und sie haben auch sehr, sehr genau drauf geachtet eben innerhalb ihrer Juristikation sauber zu bleiben und aber gleichzeitig damit ein Signal auszusenden. Also das haben wir vorhin schon bei Loretta Lynch gehört, die gesagt hat, sie wollen Korruption zu einem Ende bringen und auch James Comey hat noch mal gesagt, warum ist das eigentlich ein so wichtiges Thema? Das ist eine sehr wichtige Sache, um dieses gekidnappte Spiel von den Kidnappern zu befreien und eben ein Verhalten zu verändern. Change behavior, fand ich da einen wichtigen Punkt. Und so ist der ganze Prozess auch aufgebaut, auch mit der Öffentlichkeit, die es darum gibt. Es wurde eben allein in dieser Pressekonferenz schon ein paar Dinge genannt, die ich auch schon angesprochen habe. Schmiergeldzahlung rund um die Gruppe Amerika, Schmiergeldzahlung rund um Stimmen zur WM-Vergabe. Es hatten sich schon, als die Anklage publik wurde, hatten sich schon viele Individuen und zwei Unternehmen auch schon schuldig bekannt, haben wir auch schon nebenbei fast schon erwähnt. Also Chuck Blaser, unser Weihnachtsmann, der inzwischen verstorben ist. José Javilla, unser Hotdog-Verkäufer mit den TV-Sendern, auch inzwischen verstorben. Und eben die Warner Brothers, die noch auf ihre Strafe warten. Aber einer von beiden musste auch 1, 1 Millionen US-Dollar zahlen. Und ganz wichtig an der Stelle ist zu sagen, die USA, denen war auch wichtig dieses Geld ist nach allem, was ich jetzt recherchiert habe, nicht an den Staat geflossen. Beziehungsweise ja, es wurde an ihn gezahlt. Es geht jetzt aber nicht in die Staatskasse zurück, sondern es wird für Fußballprojekte eingesetzt. Und man kann sich darum bewerben, an diesen Strafen teilzuhaben. Das heißt, dass nicht der Vorwurf laut werden könne, die USA würden sich monetär bereichern wollen an diesem Prozess, hat zu der lustigen Fußnote geführt, dass Gianni Infantino als Nachfolger von Sepp Blatter sich beworben hat, um Teile dieses Geldes, um es für die FIFA zu verwenden, was natürlich per se ein bisschen obskur ist. Also es ist fast und zu wild, wie ich finde. Aber es ist ein wichtiger Punkt an der Stelle, das nochmal zu nennen. Jetzt ist die Frage, Jürgen, wie wollen wir die Angeklagten durchgehen? Also im ersten Schritt waren es 14 Personen. Später kamen nochmal im Dezember des selben Jahres mehr Leute dazu.
Okay, lass mich kurz reingrätschen. Also ich denke mal, der wichtigste Gedanke ist folgender. Weil die Justiz oder das Rechtswesen in Amerika und die Gesetze darauf aus sind, Leute dazu zu bewegen, zu gestehen. Notfalls ihnen auch weniger an Strafe zuzumessen. Aber nicht unbedingt Prozesse auf die Beine zu stellen, in denen dann auch über Wochen und teilweise Monate oder so die Dinge laufen. Das ist auch wieder eine amerikanische Spezialität. Haben wir halt eine Zahl von um die 40 Leute, die gestanden haben. Das hat zwar nicht gleich über Nacht funktioniert, aber angesichts der Optionen, die diese Menschen hatten und angesichts des Beweismaterials, mit dem sie konfrontiert waren und sicherlich auch mit Hilfe der Anwälte, die sie zu Rate gezogen haben. Und solchen Auflagen wie Kautionsauflagen, aber in den USA leben müssen, sich aufhalten müssen, das kann sehr teuer sein. Und im Grunde von seinem Privatleben in den anderen Ländern abgeschnitten zu sein. Motiviert zu sein, zu gestehen, das ist eine amerikanische Spezialität. Das heißt, wir haben nach der Anklagererhebung im Mai 2015, also diese nächste Schiene von Aktivitäten, die Leute dazu zu bringen, zu begreifen, es ist für alle Beteiligten besser, wenn ihr Dinge besteht. Und dann kommen wir alle hier weiter. Das heißt, für uns als Öffentlichkeit steht jetzt eigentlich, nachdem es diesen einen Prozess gab, in dem drei Leute gesagt haben, und die einzigen drei von den verhafteten und angeklagten, die einzigen drei, die gesagt haben, nein, wir sind unschuldig, wir haben nichts auf dem Kerbholz, gibt es nur noch das Thema, welche Strafe bekommen die Einzelnen. Wir haben durch den Prozess und dann eben auch dank eines Kollegen wie Ken Bensinger, der das begleitet hat und das intensiv auch dargestellt hat, haben wir auch als Öffentlichkeit eine ganze Menge an Informationen jetzt über den Fall und können uns auch wirklich sachgerecht irgendwo bedienen. Jetzt warten wir alle nur noch auf die Frage, was ist denn die eigentliche Preisklasse für das, was diese Menschen getan haben, abgesehen von den Schadenersatzerklärungen. Klammer auf, da ja einige inzwischen gestorben sind oder aber auch noch einige, die eigentlich ausgeliefert werden sollten, aber nicht ausgeliefert worden sind. Und noch eine Subgruppe von Leuten, die dann in ihren Heimatländern tatsächlich selbst angeklagt worden sind wegen Korruptionsdelikten. Ist es wahnsinnig wichtig, dass wir geständige Korruptionsverbrecher haben? Damit wir nicht irgendwie das diese Hängerpartie ist im Grunde gelaufen. Minus Schauplatz Schweiz. Das heißt, die Frage ist eigentlich jetzt nur und natürlich beschäftigt das in fast allen Fällen die Menschen am meisten. Was kostet sowas? Korruption im Sport, wenn man erwischt wird. Und würde das dazu führen, dass Leute zumindest aus Sorge vor einer Strafe, vor Jahren im Gefängnis sich demnächst anders verhalten und so weiter? Nicht, dass ich das wirklich glaube, aber das ist ja so ein bisschen unsere Denke. Wir sehen ja gerne Strafe als Präventivmaßnahmen, Abschreckung oder so. Aber da lässt sich jetzt im Moment noch gar nicht viel sagen. Wir haben zwei oder drei Leute, die haben bereits Strafzumessung bekommen. Irgendwas zwischen anderthalb Jahren und zwei Jahren. die anderen sind interessanter, die die bisher noch nicht ihre Strafe bekommen haben, sind die interessanteren, heikleren Fälle. Also jemand wie Naputh, der nun also nicht von den Geschworenen für schuldig befunden ist, ist ein schwerer Fall als jemand wie Jeffrey Webb, der aber gesagt hat, okay, ja, ich mache hier mit. Ich würde mal tippen, diese Preiskategorie, weil die Amerikaner sind oft auch unglaublich hart, wenn es um Gefängnisstrafen geht. Da gibt es nicht so eine deutsche Okay, du musst jetzt mal ins Gefängnis und dann wirst du rehabilitiert oder so. Das geht richtig zur Sache. Also da kann man jetzt nur spekulieren, aber einer der Gründe, warum ich darauf aufmerksam mache, ist wir wissen bisher diese Strafzumessungen deshalb nicht, weil es bestimmte taktische Momente gibt in diesem Fall, der dazu geführt hat, dass viele dieser Termine, die es bereits gab, dass Leute Strafen bekommen sollten, wurden immer wieder verschoben. Also Jeffrey Webb hat, glaube ich, schon viermal einen Termin verschoben bekommen. Das kann nur so funktionieren, solange nicht wirklich klar ist, ob die Aussagequalität und die Mitwirkungsqualität dieser geständigen Verschwörer viel gebracht hat, effektiv war, kann man auch nicht sagen, wie viel ist der Rabatt für das, was Sie da gemacht haben. Das heißt, ich tippe mal, dass so Leute – das ist so mein Gefühl, weil ich ja schon länger lebe und diese Sachen verfolge – ich tippe mal so jemanden wie Jeffrey Webb, muss mit fünf bis sechs Jahren Gefängnis rechnen, Naputh um sieben bis acht Jahre Gefängnis. Und wenn wir das dann wissen und wer weiß, ob ich recht habe, aber wenn das dann tatsächlich der Fall ist, dann wird die nächste Blendgranate wirklich hochgehen, wo man sagt, guck dir mal das an. Also nicht nur Leute werden im Bauer-O-Lac festgenommen, wo man irgendwie eines der besten Hotels der Welt, wo man da so in Seide gepackt wird, das kostet richtig. Das wird der nächste Punkt sein. Und die Termine, die jetzt im Moment bekannt sind, werden nicht notwendigerweise eingehalten, aber ich hoffe mal, also der nächste Termin, der jetzt im Moment angesetzt ist, ist der 17. August José María Marin, der ja schuldig gesprochen wurde. Und danach, der nächste Termin im August, ebenfalls für schuldig befunden, Juan Ángel Naput aus Paraguay. Da nehme ich mal an, das ziehen die vor, weil da ist die Aufgabe, was billigt man ihnen zu, ist einfacher. Es gibt keine Wenns und Abers. Die sind für schuldig befunden worden, das und das und das gemacht haben. Und dann gibt es bestimmte, auf Englisch nennen wir die Sentencing Guidelines, also für bestimmte Strafen gibt es bestimmte Anhaltspunkte für die Richter, den Strafrahmen zu nehmen. Und ja, dann werden wir hoffentlich ab August schlauer sein. Aber dann kleckert das noch so rum. Jeffrey Webb ist für den 7. September angesetzt. Finde ich sehr interessant. Als relativ prominenter Amerikaner in diesem Fall, Aaron Davidson, das haben wir vorhin schon mal erwähnt. Der ist für Oktober angesetzt. Boasako erst 2019. Im Februar 2019. Also der, der vielleicht auch am billigsten wegkommen kann, weil er sich als der Kronzeugigste von allen verhalten hat.
Also das war derjenige, der sich von Zürich erst nach Italien abgesetzt hat und dann nach Zuhilfe holen seiner Anwälte entschieden hat. Er stellt sich auf einer italienischen Polizeidienststelle. Er war eben angeklagt, aber weil er das Hotel Borulac verlassen hatte für ein Frühstück, kam er zu spät. Dann waren die Ermittler schon weg. Er hat dann noch anderthalb Stunden gefrühstückt im Hotel, hat noch mit anderen Angehörigen gesprochen. Da muss wohl ganz schön eine Aufruhr gewesen sein unter den FIFA-Offizellen, die da in diesem Hotel nächtigten. Und dann ist er ganz entspannt erst mal nach Mailand kutschiert worden und hat sich quasi nach Italien abgesetzt, wo er die zweite Staatsbürgerschaft innehat. Ziemlich grotesk eigentlich, dass der zu den 14 Angeklagten zählt. Aber erst mal so noch mal fast zwei Wochen den Leuten, den Behörden aus dem Weg gehen konnte, bis er sich dann gestellt hat und dann eben aber auch kooperiert hat ab da.
Wie dem aussieht, also das ist nach der gegenwärtigen Liste, der, also eigentlich sollte, ich hab einen übersprungen, eigentlich sollte am 15. Juli Darrell Warner, einer der beiden Söhne von Jack Warner dran sein. Mal gucken, ob das so läuft. Bisher war die Tendenz immer wieder, dass Sachen verschoben werden. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Meine Vermutung ist die, das liegt ja nun alles auf dem Tisch von einem einzigen, von einer einzigen Richterin. Und die muss natürlich durch jeden dieser Teilakten auch durcharbeiten. Die können ja jetzt nicht einfach nur so Pi mal Daumen. Okay, ich mach hier mal so ein bisschen, dann geht das hier ruckzuck. Wer zuerst kommt, der wird zuerst abgefertigt. Sondern das ist sicherlich wahnsinnig mühsam, bürokratisch fast, um das jetzt also in einem wohlverstandenen Sinne Recht zu sprechen. Das ist bestimmt eine Erklärung. Aber eben auch dieser taktische Teil. Und natürlich ist, also ich hab immer angenommen, dass Web warten muss, weil sie hoffen, dass sie Warner kriegen. Und dass Web dann zu Warner ganz wichtig wird. Wenn sie ihn jetzt wirklich mit einer Strafe belegen, gehe ich davon aus, dass sie fast Warner abgehakt haben. Dass sie den nicht mehr kriegen. Und das dürfte auch für Nicolas Leos gelten. Der ist nun auch wirklich schon nah am Verbleichen. Und ich tippe mal, dass sie einfach jetzt mal langsam alles zu Ende bringen wollen. Es hat einfach schon lange gedauert.
Es ist auch ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit, weil eben wirklich die Leute auch, es sind alles alte Männer, die sterben auch weg. Also Chuck Blazer gestorben, José Javilla, unser Hotdog-Verkäufer, ganz kurz vor der WM verstorben. Nicolas Leos, den du jetzt genannt hast, der sitzt in Paraguay, wehrt sich gegen seine Auslieferung, hat da Hausarrest, ist aber auch schon sehr, sehr alt. Und das ist insofern interessant, weil eben gerade diese alten Männer, die schon so lange in diesem System drin hängen, die sind auch diejenigen, die die längste Geschichte zusammen mit einem Sepp Blatter haben, zusammen mit einem Jérôme Walck, mit einem Juan Javelin, mit einem Ricardo Teixeira, auch ganz, ganz wichtige Persönlichkeit aus Brasilien in dem Zusammenhang. Das heißt, wenn man derer habhaft werden könnte, bevor man diesen Wettlauf gegen eigenes – wir wollen jetzt diesen Protest zum Ende bringen und eben auch biologischem Ente-Datum jedes einzelnen Menschen und Angeklagten – wenn man diesen Wettlauf da verliert, dann könnten auch, so wie es schon in ganz vielen Fällen geschehen ist, ja, Wissen, Beweise können dann auch einfach verschwinden mit den Personen, die dieses Wissen im Kopf hatten. Das ist, glaube ich, nochmal eine wichtige Komponente, die auch so ein bisschen zu eile dann anmahnt, weil das hat man in diesen Fällen, wo alte Menschen involviert sind immer wieder. Vielleicht kommt daher auch ein Teil der Gelassenheit des Sepp Blatters, das er ja auch sieht. Er ist zwar gesundheitlich etwas dünner und so weiter als früher, aber läuft da noch deutlich fröhlicher und physisch kräftiger durch die Welt als ganz, ganz viele Leute, denen schon Dreck am Stecken nachgewiesen werden konnte. Und da könnte es eben auch sein, dass das die Zeit spielt, glaube ich, für Sepp Blatter in diesem Fall. Muss man so.
Ja, aber zum Glück eben nicht für das, was er repräsentiert und sein persönliches Image. Also ich erinnere mich noch an eine Geschichte, dem müsste ich jetzt nachblättern. Ich habe mal für den Deutschlandfunk was gemacht über seine Begegnung mit dem Papst und wie man da so tat, als sei der Vatikan quasi dieselbe Zündstufe oder so. Ja und natürlich ist es nicht doof, dass dieser Papst auch noch sich für Fußball interessiert und mit Argentinien auch ein Land repräsentiert, in dem das verankert ist. Also hat er sicherlich auch ein Interesse daran, sich in diesem Thema einzubringen. Aber ich musste dann, das wurde halt fast eine kleine Satirebeitrag, ich musste dann an Don Camillo und Pepone denken an die Filmszene, die ein Fußballspiel austragen mit zwei verschiedenen Mannschaften. Und es auch um Betrug geht, wo dann Don Camillo in die Kirche eilt und sich bei dem dort ja, in dem Film auf jeden Fall, sprechenden Jesus beschwert, dass Pepone hätte also wahrscheinlich den Schiedsrichter bestochen und der allwissende Jesus in der Kirche sagt ihm nur, ja du hast doch auch bestochen, du hast nur zu wenig geboten. Das war für mich die reizvolle Replik auf das Ganze. Es ist halt Teil des Ganzen und war es auch sicherlich schon immer, aber das ist nun Ausflug relativ spät. In dem, was wir hier gerade besprechen, müssen wir vielleicht ja gar nicht vertiefen. Jedenfalls Blatters Ambitionen sind vorbei und auch wenn der darauf rumhackt und weint, also wir sprechen jetzt im Englischen gerne von einer Verbandung, einem Band und er dann darauf rumhackt, so nein, er sei nur suspendiert und natürlich ist das was ganz anderes und so. Also es wird immer diese Wortklauberei von ihm fortgeführt und solange er existiert und solange er bereit ist, mit den Medien zu arbeiten, so ein bisschen wie Lothar Matthäus ja auch ständig mit allen redet, die ihm über den Weg laufen und es gibt ja auch andere Typen, die das gerne machen, weil sie daraus einen Teil ihrer Wertschätzung oder wie sie sich selber Wertschätzen beziehen. Solange bleibt er natürlich ein Thema, auch wenn er uns allen nicht hilft, das Ganze zu verstehen, sondern nur versucht, uns bei der Verschleierung, also Leuten bei der Verschleierung zu helfen. Und das ist eines dieser schlimmen Erfahrungen, die wir jetzt heute beide zusammen gemacht haben. Man muss unglaublich viel arbeiten, um gegen diese Nebelmaschine anzutreten.
Das ist voll nicht irre. Und dann muss man noch ganz genau aufpassen, was man sagt. Ich habe vorhin ganz kurz mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ob ich eigentlich diese 19 DIN-R4-Seiten, die ich hier vorbereitet habe, in Teile online stelle, auf Rasenfunk.de. Dann dachte ich mir, da muss ich ja jeden einzelnen Satz durchgucken, ob da nicht was Justiziables drin steht. Denn man weiß ja, wie da dann auch die Mächte wirken. Ich glaube, das ist leider nicht drin, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das geht dann an der Stelle noch nicht. Also wir haben ganz, ganz viele FIFA-Funktionäre, die zum Teil schon geständig waren, die zum Teil angeklagt wurden, zum Teil festgenommen wurden. Eine Geschichte will ich kurz erzählen, einfach nur, weil ich sie interessant fand. Eugenio Figueiredo, der Präsident des Uruguayanischen Fußballverbands von 1997 bis 2006, natürlich auch Mitglied im FIFA-Exekutivkomitee, also dort, wo eben WM-Weltmeisterschaften vergeben werden, unter anderem. Das war derjenige, von dem ich vorhin erzählt habe. Der hat über eine 5-Jahresperiode 33.000 Pfund pro Monat an Schmiergeldern kassiert und sein Salär als Präsident des Südamerikanischen Fußballverbands zu dieser Zeit betrug aber nur 27.000 Pfund. Also nur, in Anführungszeichen, jetzt zu verstehen. Interessant da aber, was nach seiner Verhaftung geschehen ist. Das wird auch in dem Buch von Ken Bensinger eben beschrieben. Ein hinzugerufener Anwalt ist nach Zürich gereist und hat sich überlegt, wie können wir jetzt verhindern, dass der festgenommene Präsident des Fußballverbands Uruguay an die USA ausgeliefert wird, denn dann war das, was dann kommt, das war ja allen Leuten klar, nämlich das, was wir auch schon beschrieben haben. Entweder du bekennst dich schuldig oder unschuldig und dann geht es aber in einen Prozess und dir droht eine Strafe. Und da hat er sich Tipps geholt in der russischen Botschaft. Und die haben ihm tatsächlich auch einen hilfreichen Hinweis geben können und haben ihm nämlich einen Fall gezeigt, in dem es so war, dass die USA jemanden von den Schweizen ausliefern lassen wollten. Und dann aber, dessen Heimatland, in dem Fall war das Russland, ebenfalls eine Auslüferung beantragt hat. Und dann sticht das Heimatland häufig in der Entscheidung des zuständigen Richters, das eines anderen Landes. Und genau so hat man es dann gemacht. Und so hat es dann Eugenio Figeredo geschafft, dass er an Uruguay ausgeliefert wurde. Und seitdem versuchen die USA zwar noch an ihn ranzukommen, aber es ist bedeutend schwieriger. Und ich finde das deshalb bemerkenswert, weil ganz viele Dinge rund um diesen FIFA-Prozess eben mit den WM-Vergaben 2018 und 2022 auch zu tun haben. Immer so in weiteren Schleifen, die nicht so gut dokumentiert sind wie die ganzen Dinge rund um die südamerikanischen Turniere und die nordamerikanischen Turniere. Und da ist es dann schon interessant zu sehen, dass da Russland an dieser Stelle mit involviert war.
Mir ist noch etwas anderes aufgefallen bei dem, was du jetzt gesagt hast. Ich glaube, wir sind alle längst über den Punkt hinaus die Unschuldsvermutung in all diesen Fällen zu benutzen. Natürlich bin ich weit davon entfernt, einen Vorwurf zu erheben, einen konkreten Vorwurf zu erheben, weil ich diese Belege nicht habe. Das heißt, ich kann nur, ich muss diese Einschränkung machen. Ich weiß nicht alles und ich kann auch nicht alles, schon gar nicht alles beweisen. Aber ich kann beurteilen, dass fast alles, was diese Leute auf dem Kerbholz haben, in der Grauzone zur Kriminalität stattgefunden hat. Und damit ist für mich das Thema – und das ist leider auch immer wieder mal im Sportjournalismus mit auf – dass man also gefälligst die Unschuldsvermutung anzuwenden hat. Die habe ich überhaupt nicht anzuwenden. Ich habe, wenn es darum geht, zum Beispiel als Journalist zu arbeiten, ich habe nach deutschem Strafrecht und Presserecht bei der Berichterstattung über Verdachtsmomente, ich habe einen bestimmten Kodex anzuwenden, sonst begebe ich mich in die Gefahr, dass mich der von mir in diesen Verdacht gesetzte sich meldet und sich zu wehr setzt gegen meine Behauptung. Das ist schon wahr, aber ich habe keine Unschuldsvermutung anzubringen. Das gilt nur für Leute, die in einem Gerichtsverfahren arbeiten, wie zum Beispiel nach deutschem Recht spielt ja der Richter in der Strafprozessordnung eine wichtige Rolle. Der Vorsitzende Richter führt ja das Verfahren und führt auch sehr viele Befragungen durch. Eigentlich ist er der Hauptinterviewer in dem Prozess. Der kann natürlich nicht einfach davon ausgehen, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft alles sauber zusammengebracht hat und dass die Dinge, die vielleicht für einen Nicht-Schuld-Spruch sprechen, die kann er nicht einfach vom Tisch fegen. Nur für den gilt die Unschuldvermutung. Für mich gilt die nicht. Und ich will sie auch in diesem Kontext überhaupt nicht mehr anbringen. Ich will auch gar nichts mehr davon hören. Deshalb wollte ich nur darauf aufmerksam machen. Ich habe das bei dir jetzt ein bisschen rausgehört, dass du auch auf der Seite von denen angekommen bist, die sagen, guck dir mal diesen fallfige Redo an. Da wird halt rumtaktiert, um das Problem irgendwie zu umschiffen. Das ist zwar möglich, diese Verhältnisse gibt es. Es gibt auch Leute, die wissen, wie man geschickt Steuern hinterzieht und ich weiß nicht, was alles macht. Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich sagen muss, dieses Verhalten führt mich dazu zu sagen, man muss ja unschuldig sein, im Gegenteil.
Ja, eher im Gegenteil. Genau, deswegen habe ich es eher genannt, wenn sich jemand so sehr mit allen Mitteln rumlaviert. Und vor allem deswegen habe ich darauf hingewiesen, dass der Einbezug der russischen Botschaft, fand ich an der Stelle sehr interessant. Wenn wir einfach gleichzeitig – deswegen habe ich es quasi in Zusammenhang gestellt – sagen, es geht ja auch um Stimmen zur WM-Vergabe 2018. Ansonsten hätte man ja kein begründbares Interesse Russlands daran, dass ein urukwaianischer Fußballpräsident nicht an die USA ausgeliefert wird. Da ist doch irgendetwas komisch und deswegen wollte ich darauf hinweisen. Aber da fand ich eine richtige Einschätzung von dir. Ich finde, wir sind dann an dem Punkt angekommen, wo wir jetzt, glaube ich, viel umrissen haben, worum es in diesen Prozess geht. Du hast vorhin schon mal kurz damit angefangen, hol uns nochmal rein. Was ist denn jetzt der aktuelle Zwischenstand?
Ja, also die zwei Sockel, auf die wir achten müssen, das eine ist dieser richtig dicke, fette Sockel, das ist die Arbeit der amerikanischen Justiz und das andere ist halt die Arbeit der Schweizer Justiz. Und das ist halt ein eher dünnes Beinchen, das ist aus zwei verschiedenen Gründen dünn. Das eine ist wirklich der Codex, dass die Gesetze, die es in den USA gibt, die eben zum Beispiel diese Form der Bandenkriminalität, wie wir das im deutschen Rechtsrahmen nennen würden, also dieses mit den RICO-Gesetzen, da ist ganz viel Beweismaterial, aber auch Handwerkszeug für die Justiz, um damit umzugehen. Das ist auf der Schweizer Seite eben sehr, sehr dünn. Das geht mit der Personaldecke los und dann geht es noch viel stärker weiter über das, was das Schweizer Wirtschaftsstrafrecht alles nicht festlegt. Also die kennen im Prinzip, die haben das jetzt mal versucht, zu modifizieren, aber für die ist Korruption eigentlich von Bedanken her nicht strafwürdig. Das macht man halt, das muss man vielleicht auch verstehen, weil das Schweizer Modell, warum funktioniert die Schweiz wirtschaftlich so gut, lebt natürlich von unglaublich vielen Geschäften mit unglaublich vielen Leuten außerhalb der Schweiz. Das sind nicht nur die Banken, das sind natürlich auch andere Unternehmen, da gibt es ja Pharmakonzerne, es gibt Rüstungsunternehmen, bestimmte Maschinenbauunternehmen, die haben alle ganz viel mit dem Ausland zu tun und sehen erstmal nicht den Grund, warum sie für das Schmieren von Leuten bestraft werden können, wenn das doch die ganze Welt macht oder so. Das ist also das eine. Das zweite ist allerdings noch viel grotesker. All diese über 40 Weltsportverbände, die in der Schweiz domiziliert sind und damit also ein richtig großer Teil dieses Systems, über das wir hier reden. Also eben nicht nur das internationale Olympische Komitee in Lausanne und die FIFA in Zürich, sondern noch viele andere. Wie immer mal wieder zwischendurch kam ja zum Beispiel die UCI auf, Tour de France läuft ja gerade, Doping im Radsport, das ging natürlich auch irgendwo in der Schweiz. Spielt das auch im Grunde eine Rolle? Diese Organisationen sind nach dem Schweizer Vereinsrecht domiziliert. Das sind gar keine Firmen oder Unternehmen, wie wir vielleicht heute sagen würden. Das sind Vereine, eingetragene Vereine, mit all den Vorzügen dieses Status. Natürlich, wenn einer einen Gesangverein aufmacht und dazu braucht er, ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele Mitglieder, vier, sieben oder so, der will ja nur singen, der will ja nicht groß irgendwie Geld verdienen. Natürlich muss man den entlasten, dem kann man nicht die ganze Bürde des Wirtschaftsrechts mit Meldepflichten und ich weiß nicht was, zubilligen. Aber es geht schon mal allein um das Steuerthema. Sind solche Organisationen wirklich, sollten sie steuerbefreit sein? Sind sie natürlich. Die FIFA zahlt so ein bisschen aus Goodwill-Gründen auf der Ebene, vor allen Dingen der Kantonalebene in Zürich ein bisschen Geld. Das hat sicherlich damit zu tun, dass man damals auch bauen musste und wollte und bestimmte nehmen und geben Geschichten nötig waren. Da hat man dann mal signalisiert, okay, wir sind ja nicht so geizig und wir sind großzügig. Und der Schweizer Blatter in dieser Führungsrolle hat das sicherlich dann auch seinen Finanzausschusskollegen relativ leicht erklären können. Aber sie müssen nicht die volle Steuer bezahlen und würden den Teufel tun, das anzubieten. Das heißt also diese Frage, die ist für die Schweiz nach wie vor entscheidend. Müssen solche Organisationen mit Milliarden umsetzen, nicht wirklich anders erfasst werden und damit auch anderen Pflichten unterworfen werden, wie sie zum Beispiel normale Schweizer Unternehmen haben. Die Diskussion hat so noch nie richtig stattgefunden. Es gab rund um diese Phase, ich glaube, das begann 2011 mit dieser Geschichte mit Binamam und so. Es gab Versuche im Parlament in der Schweiz, ich glaube im Nationalrat heißt es, Dinge anzuschieben. Dann merkten aber andere Wirtschaftsvertreter, dass das sie auch betreffen würde, weil es gibt ja keine, es wurde zwar Lex FIFA genannt, aber es gilt natürlich nicht einfach nur für die Sportorganisation, sondern hat übergreifende Wirkung. Dann wurde das da ausgebremst von den Leuten, die das überhaupt nicht gut fanden und die hatten natürlich Lobbymacht. Das heißt, die FIFA hatte plötzlich Lobbypartner innerhalb der Schweiz, die eigentlich nichts mit ihnen zu tun haben. Das heißt, das ist weiterhin unbearbeitet. Wenn jetzt allerdings Lauber als Bundesanwalt dokumentieren kann, in was für einer Systematik wir uns befinden, möglicherweise gibt es einen umdenken. Man sollte bei den Schweizer nicht denken, dass sie nicht klug sind. Also das ist für mich – ich bin ja auch helvetikophil – ich mag die Schweiz und die Schweizer. Also alles, was ich eventuell als Kritik vorbringen würde, muss man bitte auch vor dem Hintergrund meiner Zuneigung zur Schweiz dann sehen. Ich bin auch Mitglied im Schweizer Journalistenverband Impressum. Das ist aber eine Baustelle, die ansteht. Zwei Säulen, habe ich gesagt. Die dicke Säule in den USA, die dünne Säule in der Schweiz. Das habe ich angedeutet. Ich glaube, alles, was man aus den USA jetzt in der nächsten Phase lernen wird, hat damit zu tun, wie schwer wird das Verhalten dieser Funktionäre und rechte Händler, wie schwer wird das bestraft, wie lange müssen die ins Gefängnis. In der Schweiz geht es erst einmal nur darum, ist das überhaupt justiziabel. Das wissen wir nicht, weil der zeigt seine Karten nicht, der gute Herr Lauber. Wir können hoffen, dass wenn Blatter Recht hat, dass dann Ende dieses Jahres, möglicherweise wurde auch taktisch die Weltmeisterschaft erst einmal abgewartet, dass dann Ende dieses Jahres tatsächlich was auf den Tisch kommt.
Dann wir uns vielleicht nochmal unterhalten.
Ja, dann gibt es den FIFA-Prozess, das Imperium schlägt zurück.
Ja, und das ist es für mich dann eigentlich. Weil den Erkenntniswert, den ziehen ja zig Leute auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise. Ich als Journalist beteilige mich an der Frage, wie kann man etwas aufdecken, aufarbeiten, erklären. Ich beteilige mich nicht unbedingt an der Frage, was kommt danach. Für mich kommt dann vielleicht das andere, das nächste Thema und dann ist es auch mal gut. Aber Gesellschaften und Verbände und so weiter, die haben natürlich weiter zu tun. Und all die Versuche, die man bei der FIFA erlebt hat, also mit irgendeiner Ethik, mit einem Ethikkodex zu arbeiten, diesen – ich glaube, der ist Kriminologe, der Piet – den reinzuholen als neutralen Menschen, der dann also bestimmte Flöcke einhauen soll und so. Das war ja alles Blatter-Musik, ja. Da wurde ja der arme Piet, der hat geglaubt, der kann da irgendwas wirklich verändern. Das hat er natürlich inzwischen wahrscheinlich längst eingesehen, dass es nicht geht.
Also da sollte der Compliance regeln, sollte der etablieren.
Die auf dem Papier ja auch existieren, aber dann eben nichts nützen. Oder ich habe mit Transparency Leuten gesprochen, die da auch mal eine Rolle gespielt haben und die auch irgendwie einfach die Hände hoch in die Luft geworfen haben und gesagt, hier kommen wir nicht weiter. Also das ist ein Thema für demnächst und für andere Leute. Da werde ich wohl irgendwie nicht beteiligt sein, weil das interessiert verfolgen, bin sehr pessimistisch. Weil wenn ich mir nur mal anschaue und ich glaube, die gegenwärtige Situation mit dem Deutschen Fußballbund, mit der Führungsgilde, die es da gibt, mit Fragen wie geht man mit Spielern um, wie geht man mit dem Konzept Mannschaft um, wie geht man mit Leuten um, die dort Verantwortung haben und sich dafür beworben haben, die wurden ja nicht dazu gezwungen, diese Jobs zu übernehmen, ist eine interessante Studie, in wie lassen sich solche Biotopen überhaupt in irgendeiner Weise verändern. Ich meine, stell dir doch mal aus, bei Bayern München gibt es, und du bist ja glaube ich Mitglied und Superfan, und ich weiß nicht alles, bei Bayern München gibt es…
Es ist ein bisschen weiter von der Tante Superfan zu sein, je mehr man über den Verein weiß, desto weniger. Aber ja, es gibt immer noch eine emotionale Nähe.
Stadler sitzt in U-Haft, aber ist Aufsichtsratemitglied. Aber korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege. Der Präsident hat irgendwie zig Jahre im Knast gesessen. Und er kann nur deshalb diesen Job machen, weil das deutsche Aktienrecht ist da in der Beziehung etwas huldvoll. Wenn der etwas längere Strafe bekommen hätte, die ihm auch zugestanden hätte nach der Aktenlage, dann wäre das vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr möglich gewesen. Also die brauchen alle ständig diese Art von Zäune, Gatter, Wachtürme, damit das nicht passiert, was wir da erleben.
Ja, und sie halten sich alle gegenseitig fest. Also die stehen alle arm in arm, so wie die Nationalmannschaften, während die Hymne gespielt wird vor dem Länderspiel. Und sollte einer von ihnen fallen, dann sorgen sie dafür, dass er wieder aufgerichtet wird, weil sie auch wissen, wenn zu viele fallen, dann bricht die Gruppe auseinander. Und dann passieren genau solche grotesken Dinge, wie das eben ein Fußballverein, der sagt, er würde Compliance-Regeln verfolgen. Ja, und der hat dann auf einmal straffällig gewordene Personen bei sich im Aufsichtsrat sitzen, äußert sich nicht mal dazu, dass andere von immer noch in Urhaft sitzen, stand dieser Aufzeichnung. Genau, das ist eben ein Schuldentwurf.
Du müsstest korrigieren, vielleicht willst du es auch dann eventuell rausschneiden. Also Stadler ist nicht straffällig geworden, er ist bisher nur steht nur im Verdacht.
Achso, ich meinte damit Uli Hoeneß. Genau, und Stadler ist derjenige, der in Untersuchungshaft sitzt, und das jetzt auch schon sehr lange. Genau, aber hat man da bisher was gehört von Seiten des Vereins, bei dem man im Aussichtsrat sitzt? Nein, da wird Ruhe gewahrt. Und das ist eben dieser Schulterschluss der Personen, die du siehst und den du jetzt eben auch hier erleben kannst. Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, und damit kämen wir so ein bisschen, wir reden ja schon indirekt darüber deine Einschätzung zu den zu den möglichen Folgen dieses Prozesses. Du hast jetzt ja schon diese beiden Beine aufgemacht, das US-amerikanische und das Schweizer, wo wir noch nicht so ganz wissen, ist es ein Holzbein oder wird daraus noch ein richtiges? Wir sind gespannt, was uns da Michael Lauber präsentieren wird irgendwann. In der deutschen Berichterstattung rund um das, was man jetzt in den Prozesstagen erleben konnte, also ab November 2017 lief der Prozess gegen drei Angeklagte, die sich als nicht schuldig bekannt haben – Naputh, Marin und Bruggo – ohne jetzt genau auf die einzelnen Personen eingehen zu wollen. Aber im Verlauf dieses Prozesses hat dann eben auch vorhin angesprochene Alejandro Bursaco, das ist derjenige, der sich nach Italien abgesetzt hatte und dann kooperiert hat mit den US-Behörden, der hat ausgesagt und hat ausgepackt und unter anderem ausgesagt, dass die südamerikanischen FIFA-Exil-Motivmitglieder für ihre Stimmen für die WM in Katar mindestens je eine Million US-Dollar erhalten haben sollen. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen ein Fokus der deutschsprachigen Medien, wenn es rund um diesen Bericht geht. Nämlich könnte es sein, dass die WM nochmal Katar entzogen wird, kann man da etwas nachweisen. Wie bewertest du denn aus deiner Sicht, die ja vielleicht ein bisschen andere ist, diesen Fokus auf die WM 2022?
Ja, ich denke, wir müssen den Fokus ein bisschen verschieben, weil seit der Vergabe selber, unabhängig jetzt mal von dem, was wir im Dezember 2017 erfahren haben durch die Aussage von Borsako, haben sich ja die Dinge weiterentwickelt. Und es gibt einen politischen Spannungszustand auf der arabischen Halbinsel, der auf den ersten Blick erst mal gar nicht nachzuvollziehen ist, der sich aber auf den Sport inzwischen massiv auswirkt. Das heißt, die saudiarabischen Interessen, die bislang sich im Bereich Sport und Medien nicht weiterartikuliert haben, zumindest mir da nichts aufgefallen. Sie haben halt versucht, eine gute Mannschaft auf die Beine zu stellen, aber das war es im Grunde auch. Du siehst auch kaum, in den letzten 20 Jahren, du siehst auch kaum Funktionäre aus Saudi-Arabien, das sind halt Kuwaitis und das sind Kataris. Die haben halt als kleinere, wenn auch Öl- oder gasreiche Länder, als kleinere Länder so diesen Softpower-Approach zu internationaler Politik entdeckt und versuchten halt seitdem mit Geld, ja, sich einen Stellenwert in der Welt zu verschaffen, der bedeutet, dass sie mitspielen können und dass man sie nicht einfach überrumpelt oder irgendwie platt machen kann oder so. Stichwort, das Verhalten Saddam Hussein Irak und wie der mit seinen Nachbarländern militärisch umgegangen ist oder umgegangen wäre. Was jetzt Saudi-Arabien da anstellt, es geht los mit diesem Boykott und dieser fast kriegerischen Haltung gegenüber Katar und die gleichzeitig ablaufenden Dinge, wie zum Beispiel, dass sie das sanktionieren, dass es einen Kontrast, einen Fernsehsignal Diebstahl gibt von einer in Saudi-Arabien sitzenden Fernsehfirma, die auch noch so heißt, dass klar wird, dass sie also die katarische Firma, B.In. heißt die, glaube ich, versucht zu schädigen. Dann der Versuch, über Infantino Geld reinzupumpen in die FIFA, um da eine Rolle zu spielen für Turniere, die man noch erfinden möchte, so wie du das ja vorhin beschrieben hast. Wie kommt man zu mehr Geld, indem man sich was ausdenkt? Da gibt es eine neue Dynamik und die kann sehr viel wirkungsvoller sein als die, sagen wir mal, von unserem auf Wahrheitsliebe und ethisch-moralischen Vorstellungen – fixierte Idee, die haben mit Bestechungshilfe diesen Zuschlag bekommen, die hätten das nie bekommen dürfen, das war die schlechteste Bewerbung aller Zeiten, deretwegen musste der Termin verlegt werden und so weiter und so weiter mit noch mehr Konsequenzen wie dem Fox-Fernsehdeal und der Vergabe 26 in die USA, der sicherlich auch als Reaktion darauf eine Rolle spielt, also diese ganze Kette von Ereignissen, die Frage, die du nicht beantworten kannst, oder vielleicht kannst du es, ich kann es nicht, versucht man jetzt nicht Katar auszukicken aus dem Ganzen, sondern irgendeine andere Lösung zu finden, die wieder so nach Sibylinisch, Salomonisch, was auch immer aussieht und die dann bedeuten würde, okay, wir zwingen die jetzt in ein 48er Turnier und dann ist völlig klar, das können Das können die gar nicht ausrichten. Also sucht man nach Partnern in der Umgebung und möglicherweise ist dann Saudi, Arabien und andere Nachbarländer in der Lage, das mit aufzufangen oder so. Da stell ich mir mal diese Entwicklung vor. Alles andere ist möglich, aber halte ich für unwahrscheinlicher, wenn ich mir angucke, wie dort laviert wird in dieser Welt.
Aber der Anspruch der US-Behörden jetzt bei der laufenden Anklage, To Change Behavior und To End Corruption – ich habe jetzt einmal James Comian, einmal Loretta Lynch zitiert – gibt es Anhaltspunkte, die dich glauben, machen lassen, dass das möglich ist aufgrund dieser jetzt laufenden Untersuchung?
Die kurze Antwort – nein. Also die Fähigkeit der amerikanischen Behörden innerhalb der USA und dann meinetwegen noch in der Nachbarschaft, irgendetwas durchzudrücken, die ist ja auch realistischerweise bei allem, bei aller Rhetorik, die ist natürlich völlig gering. Ich meine, wenn man weiß, dass die Morde in Mexiko mit amerikanischen Waffen begangen werden und dass die also wunderbar darüber fließen können und dann, aber die Amerikaner fühlen sich also unglaublich beleidigt und belastet, ja, weil es da jetzt Verbrechen gibt und so gleichzeitig sind das Verbrechen, die damit zu tun haben, dass in den USA Drogen konsumiert werden, die halt nur illegal in die USA gebracht werden müssen. Dann sehe ich natürlich überhaupt nicht, wie die Rhetorik der Amerikaner über das hinaus, was da jetzt an Fakten geschaffen worden ist, irgendeine Wirkung haben kann. Ich kann mir vorstellen, das habe ich vorhin ja schon mal gesagt, wenn klar ist, also die Preisklasse für Betrug, Geldwäsche und Manipulation und Korruption im Sport ist sechs bis acht Jahre Gefängnis, das wird einige Leute dazu bringen, nochmal nachzudenken, bevor sie irgendwas machen. Es wird andere Leute dazu bringen, zu sagen, okay, dann müssen wir es ein bisschen feintüfteliger hinkriegen, dann muss der Beschiss eben noch geschickter kaschiert werden oder so. Das ist immer gegeben und wie gesagt, ich hatte vorhin schon mal darauf hingewiesen, ich glaube, wenn die Schweizer wirklich anfangen würden, damit härter umzugehen mit dem Thema, dann könnte zumindest auf dem Papier könnten sich Änderungen abspielen, die vielleicht eine Rolle spielen. Also die Verfasstheit dieser Organisation und die Transparenz dieser Organisation und die Kontrollinstitutionen, die es geben muss, dass die dann eine Rolle spielen würden. Aber ich glaube, dass...
Dann würden ja die Verbände wahrscheinlich auch, also selbst wenn das käme, ja, dann wirst du auf wundersame Art und Weise erleben, dass auf einmal die FIFA-Hauptzentrale auf Trinidad und Tobago steht oder irgendwo anders. Also dann auf einmal entdecken sie, dass ihnen das doch alles gar nicht so wichtig war in Zürich.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Und das ist für die, die in der Schweiz über sowas nachdenken, eben immer auch dieser selbe Spagat, dass sie versuchen, einerseits so ein bisschen Leuten auf die Finger zu klopfen und auf der anderen Seite das Geschäftsmodell Weltsport in der Schweiz domiziliert, dass sie das nicht gefährden wollen. Es ist zwar kein riesiger Wirtschaftsfaktor, aber es sind ordentliche Zahlen. Da arbeiten Tausende von Leuten, viele von denen Schweizer, und das Geld, was man als Geldschöpfung dann reinholt in die Schweiz über, die zum Teil ja diese Fernsehrechte oder die Sponsorengelder, die Coca-Cola-Gelder dieser Welt, das kommt ja dann in der erst mal in die Schweiz rein. Es wird ja nicht alles dort ausgegeben, aber ist Teil des Wertschöpfungsprozesses. Und ja, da wird ein Spagat probiert, so ein bisschen Eier, Eier. Da kann man, also man kann nicht wirklich optimistisch sein und habe ich ja auch schon mal vorhin angedeutet, wenn man sich den DFB anguckt und wie der intern funktioniert, ist ein Lehrstück schlechthin. Nur Pessimismus, wenn es darum geht, zum Beispiel so was wie Demokratie zu installieren. Ich meine, das Verständnis, das ich von einer Organisation wie dem Deutschen Fußballbund habe, der immer behauptet, er habe irgendwie die meisten Mitglieder eines Sportfachverbandes in der Welt. Einen Scheiß hat der. Da sind ein paar Mitglieder, die nennen sich Landesverbände. Das sind die Mitglieder vom DFB. Da gibt es nichts wie Demokratie. Das ist alles irgendwie Seilschaftskonzept und die Bestallung von Leuten wie Niersbach, das ist mir halt am gegenwärtigsten, und die Bestallung von Leuten wie Grindel als dem Nachfolger, der nun irgendwie plötzlich irgendwie aus dem Hut ziehen musste. Es sind Beispiele dafür, wie dort solche Verantwortlichkeiten vergeben werden. Und selbst jemand wie Zwanziger, der als doch sehr lauterer Typ sich inszenieren konnte und sogar Jurist, der eigentlich auch mehr über das Verhalten von Leuten wissen sollte, bleibt am Ende zwiespältig. Kein Wunder, dass er jetzt da mit diesem Steuerstrafprozess, den es wahrscheinlich geben wird, in irgendeiner Weise direkt in Verbindung gebracht werden wird, weil er auch nicht so kompetent mit den Sachen umgegangen ist. Der hat doch auch auf irgendwas gesetzt, als es darum ging, die Sache aufzuklären. Ich habe ihn in Verdacht, als der Hauptinformant zu sein, der also diese Sachen ins Rollen gebracht hat mit der Sommermärchenkohle. Aber der war ja schon mal vorher irgendwie im Amt, als Präsident, als Schatzmeister von bestimmten Dingen. Der hat ja nicht in dem Moment reagiert, wo es vielleicht wichtig gewesen wäre, sondern reagiert später und versucht dann irgendeine Form von, wie auch immer motiviert, eine Form von Korrektur. Und gut, es hat Niersbach den Posten gekostet und nach allem, was wir hören, waren die beiden sich also nicht besonders wohl gelitten. Aber das kann ja nicht der einzige Ertrag sein, wenn man mit dem Gestus, mit dem Zwanziger immer aufgetreten ist, lebt. Aber ich meine, warum sollte ich jemanden, nur weil der so wie Papa gnädig klingt, warum sollte ich dem jetzt mehr Vertrauen und mehr Kompetenz zubilligen als all den anderen, die in diesen Jobs unterwegs sind.
Also ich strukturiere mal so ein bisschen, das worüber wir jetzt gesprochen haben, mit Blick auf, was heißt das alles für den aktuellen Fußball. Von Seiten der Justiz hast du sehr klar gemacht, dass der Reisen der Tiger-USA bei näherem Hinsinn schon auch ein bisschen zahnlos ist und bei der Schweiz wissen wir nicht, ob da überhaupt etwas sich tun wird. Dann haben wir jetzt gerade über Verbände gesprochen, über die bestehenden Strukturen in Verbände, auch schon über Dinge, die jetzt nach diesem Prozess passiert sind, mal mit Blick auf den DFB. Wir haben aber vorhin beim ganzen Blatter-Teil ja auch schon über die FIFA gesprochen. Man könnte über Gianni Infantino sprechen. Du hast jetzt das Thema mit dem Thema Saudi-Arabien, Katar haben wir ja gerade die aktuell vorliegenden Themen. Das lässt einen jetzt auch nicht gerade positiv darauf blicken, dass da ein großer wirklicher Reformwille oder eine Notwendigkeit zu Reform und Transparenz bestünde. Und dann hat man ja als dritten großen Akteur in diesem Rahmen die FIFA-Sponsoren, wo man vor allem damals direkt nach den Festnahmen dachte, Mensch, das könnte jetzt der Turning Point sein in diesem Sinne, dass eben die Adidas, die Coca-Colas, die Visas dieser Welt sagen, okay, also mit einem solch korrupten Gebilde möchten wir nichts zu tun haben. Wir ziehen uns als Sponsor zurück. Jetzt gucke ich mir die aktuelle FIFA- Partnerliste auf der Seite der FIFA an und sehe, naja, also da sind ein paar neue mit dabei, mit irgendwelchen chinesischen Akteuren, mit russischen Akteuren, mit katarischen, also mit Qatar Airways. Ganz komisch, warum die auf einmal der FIFA Geld zahlen. Da kann man ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr darauf hoffen, dass sich über diese Schiene etwas ändern wird, oder?
Ne, eigentlich nicht. Was wohl passiert ist, und die FIFA hat im Moment Geldprobleme, es hat wohl Absetzbewegungen gegeben. Und zumindestens, also die Kosten, die entstanden sind, um sich also substanziell zu verteidigen gegen all die Anklagen, die es gibt, sind nicht der entscheidende Faktor für das Geldloch bei der FIFA. Wobei die richtige Abrechnung, die korrekte Abrechnung, wohl erst nach der WM möglich sein wird, weil das ist so eben die Art und Weise, dass die erst alle vier Jahre, wenn das gesamte Geld reingekommen ist, dann wirklich genau wissen, was los ist. Aber es gibt klare Hinweise darauf. Es gab auch jetzt in dieser Dokumentation, ich glaube, das war die WDR-Dokumentation über die WM in Russland, da wurde jemand interviewt, der als – im Zeitungsgeschäft würde man die Anzeigenverkäufer nennen, ich weiß nicht genau, wie die diese Sponsoren, Sucher, diese Vermittler für, die dann arbeiten, also die haben Schwierigkeiten, überhaupt auch in die Tür zu kommen. Also es gibt ein unglaubliches Unbehagen, was natürlich damit zu tun hat, dass sich keiner, der neu in sowas einsteigen muss, viele haben ja langfristige Verträge, da da rein möchte in so eine Situation, die ja auch teilweise ungeklärt ist und man nicht genau weiß, wie es weitergeht. Aber gleichzeitig wird sich das weiter drehen, das Ganze, und dann kann sich auch die Dynamik ändern und in dem Moment, wo Infantino, den ich so einschätze, dass er nun wirklich versucht, Geld aufzutreiben, massiv, und diese saudiarabische Initiative zeigt das ja an.
Also, willst du noch mal ganz kurz vielleicht für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das nicht mehr vor Augen haben, kurz mit drei Sätzen reißen, worum ging es da bei dieser Initiative?
Ja, ein neues Turnier zu erfinden, das also langfristig angelegt ist und das mit unglaublich viel saudischem Geld, was wir am Anfang gar nicht wussten, Infantilnotat, so als dürfe er gar nicht sagen, woher das Geld herkommt.
Ich glaube 23 Milliarden US-Dollar habe ich so im Kopf jetzt gerade.
In der Größenordnung, ja. Und das wäre natürlich extrem positiv für das Konzept, okay, FIFA, wir sind eine Geldmaschine, wir müssen Geld reinholen. Denn wenn das nicht gelingt, kann es sein, dass solche Effekte, wie sie jetzt meinetwegen durch eine sportliche, doch ganz attraktive WM möglich sind. Aber was bedeutet das? Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo Länder wie Italien, wie Deutschland, wie die Niederlande, wie Brasilien, erstmal egal wann sie ausscheiden, nicht wirklich in den Genuss dieser Aura kommen oder so. Und, dass also eigentlich nur Putin und die russische Nationalmannschaft profitieren, vielleicht noch, je nachdem wer jetzt Weltmeister wird, Kroatien oder Belgien oder so. Aber das sind ja kleinere Einheiten, die können ja nur nicht wirklich viel auf der Weltkarte bewegen. Schön mal zu sehen, dass auch in Ländern mit weniger Menschen erfolgreich Fußball gespielt werden kann, aber das ist es auch schon. Also da hat es dann keine wirklich intensive, langfristige Wirkung. Also die Frage, die die FIFA beschäftigt, die wirklich nur an den Zitzen dieser Weltmeisterschaftsorganisation hängt, kann dieses Paket wirklich langfristig funktionieren. Und was wir nie wissen, in keinem Bereich des internationalen Sports ist, wann ist eigentlich die Sättigung für bestimmte Sportarten erreicht. Dahinter dem Hügel geht es irgendwo wieder runter. Wir können das in der langen kommerziellen Sportgeschichte der USA in bestimmten Beispielen ein bisschen begutachten. Da ist also die totale Überraschung, Baseball mal absolute Nummer eins gegenüber allem anderen, ist heute vielleicht noch die Nummer drei oder so. Und man kann auch erklären, wie das alles, welche Faktoren da eine Rolle spielen. Das liegt an der Sportart selber, das liegt an der Art, wie sie präsentiert wird. Das liegt aber immer auch daran, was gibt es noch für Sportarten? Können die Konkurrenz sein für das große, begrenzte, für den großen begrenzten Topf Aufmerksamkeit der Menschen, die bereit sind, einzuschalten oder Geld auszugeben oder so. Und wenn ich mir angucke, dass wir ja im Fußball in einer Phase sind, wo dieser Event-Aspekt für viele, die da jetzt sich selber aufnehmen im Stadion, wenn sie selber jubeln, ja, da war ja jetzt dieses eine Twitter-Video von so einem Vollidioten, der sich also umdreht und also um sich mit dem Hintergrundrasen in seinem Instagram-Selfie, also Video einzufangen und dabei schreit und ich weiß nicht was alles. Wenn das Stand der Dinge ist heute, dann kann ich mir doch nicht vorstellen, dass es dahinter noch eine Steigerung geben kann. Also, hilf mir, falls du was siehst.
Wir haben jetzt einmal die Justiz als möglichen Entscheidungsfaktor eher so ein bisschen ausgeschlossen. Wir haben die Struktur der Verbände ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich abzusehen, dass sich da, es ging ja nur, wenn da jetzt ein paar Nationen austreten würden und sagen würden, wir machen jetzt ab jetzt unser eigenes Ding, dann hätte die FIFA echt die Probleme. Ansonsten bleibt das in diesem Verband, wie es jetzt ist. Wir haben die Sponsoren, wo wir gesehen haben, es gibt Absetzbewegungen, aber immer noch sehr, sehr viel Geld im Fußball und wir haben die Fans so als letzten eventuellen Faktor, wo man sagen kann, okay, vielleicht ist das auch derjenige Treiber, der dann zu einer Veränderung führt, weil das Interesse zurückgeht. Und ich musste jetzt, während du dein Baseballbeispiel gebracht hast, die ganze Zeit an E-Sports denken. Das ist der einzige Sport, der rasant wächst gerade und der komplett neu ist und der vor allem auf eine unglaublich zukunftsrechtige Käuferschicht abzieht, nämlich auf junge Menschen. Und der ganz, ganz andere, ganz anders gestaltet ist als Fußball. Ich habe dazu auch mal eine eigene Folge gemacht für alle diejenigen, die sich dafür interessieren, was da eigentlich die Bundesliga-Vereine gerade im E-Sports- Bereich machen. Und da denke ich sehr viel darüber nach, ob das nicht vielleicht so das Ding sein könnte, was unter anderem auch den Fußball hinter sich zurückfallen lässt. Und das könnte dann wirklich einen Impact haben, wenn dann eben das Geld fehlt, mit dem man sich die FIFA- Präsidentschaftswahl erkauft hat.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Faktor, der ist schwer zu kalkulieren. Aber dass Spiele verschoben werden inzwischen weltweit, ist ein massives Phänomen. Natürlich können wir davon ausgehen, dass die Spiele auf der allerhöchsten Leistungsebene wahrscheinlich nicht betroffen sind, weil wahrscheinlich das Geld, das die Leute, die dort aktiv sind, verdienen, spricht vor allem die Spieler. Und wie die Schiedsrichterentlohnung aussieht, weiß ich im Moment nicht, aber die wird ja hoffentlich auch ein bisschen angehoben werden, dass da nicht so schnell Begehrlichkeiten entstehen. Aber selbst wenn eben auf der Ebene darunter, auf dieser, was wir klassischerweise Amateurfußball nennen, aber durch irgendwelche chinesischen Zocker, die irgendwo rumeiern im Internet, irgendwelche Spiele permanent in allen möglichen Ländern verschoben werden, wird der Fußball in seiner Ausstrahlung natürlich auch betroffen. Das geht nicht so weiter. Man kann nicht so tun, als gäbe es nur eine Leistungsebene top, ganz oben. Und die ist entscheidend, auch wenn sie halt das Geld erwirtschaftet. Wenn darunter die Unterbaukonstruktionen anfangen, Termiten sich einzuhandeln, dann ist das ein riesiges Problem und noch schwerer zu bewältigen als das, was man da oben in der Top-Welt machen kann. Da kann man eben die Technik herstellen, um diese Video-Schiedsrichter einzusetzen oder Kameras für alles Mögliche benutzen. Das geht ja alles in den anderen Bereichen des Fußballs nicht. Ich sehe zum Beispiel eine ganz gefährliche Entwicklung aus diesem Bereich. Mit dem habe ich mich auch natürlich beschäftigt und deshalb kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die Termiten, die ich gerade mal genannt habe, aus allen möglichen Richtungen kommen können und dass die Organisationseinheit Top-Fußball, Commerz-Fußball gar nicht gewappnet ist, weil sie sich nicht selbstkritisch mit solchen Dingen beschäftigt.
Stattdessen den Wettanbietern an den Hals wirft, die ganz ganz wichtig im Sportvermarktungsbereich sind. Die pumpen ja unglaublich viel Geld via Sponsorings in den Fußball hinein und der Fußball wirft sich da relativ unkritisch einer Branche an den Hals, würde ich schon sagen, die eben genau das, was du da beschreibst, ja erst möglich macht. Und trotz aller Vorsichtsmaßnahmen und Dinge, die es da gibt, um eben Wettbetrug Einheit zu gebieten, es trotzdem noch stattfindet.
Und wir wir leben fast alle so, wie wir sozialisiert sind, egal mal in welcher Generation. Wir leben alle von bestimmten Mythen dieses Fußballspiels. Das hat was mit der Schlichtheit des Spiels zu tun. Das hat das mit zu tun, dass die meisten Regeln im Regelkodex sich mit Maßen und Gewichten beschäftigen und nicht mit wie kann man so ein Spiel reglementieren oder so. Das sind ganz wenige Regeln, die die Abseits- und Faulregeln und wie lange ist das Spiel und so. Das sind alles die Vielzahl der Regeln. Man braucht nur einen Ball, man braucht nur eine eben, vernünftige Fläche oder so und ein paar Tore, zwei Tore. Das ist alles relativ schön konzipiert am Anfang und hat natürlich auch deshalb diesen riesigen weltweiten Erfolg. Das Exportprodukt Fußball aus England schwappt ja nun gegen Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts, Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts in einer unglaublichen Geschwindigkeit in all die anderen Länder. Ganz erstaunlich eigentlich, aber natürlich auch wieder erklärlich, weil durch die Kolonialmacht- Stellung der Briten gab es natürlich auch ganz bestimmte Transmissionsriemen, aber wie dem auch sei, wir können uns nicht festhalten an dem Mythos Fußball an 1899 oder wann auch immer die Elfmeter-Regel als die einzige wirklich große letzte Erfindung eingebaut worden ist.
Aufhebung der Rundpassregel war die letzte große Änderung, aber ja, das Spiel in seinen Grundfesten besteht jetzt schon sehr, sehr lange, das stimmt.
Gegen den Elfmeter, gegen die Einführung des Konzepts Elfstrafstuhls, das finde ich schon radikal, aber egal. Das kann man irgendwie inszenieren bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt und kann das also in dieser Event-Konzeption machen und irgendwann ist da die Luft raus. Meinst du das? Ja, und zwar…
Bleibt nicht das Spiel immer das Spiel? Also ich kann ja die FIFA und alles ganz fürchterlich finden und deswegen habe ich ja trotzdem Lust im Park mit Leuten zu kicken.
Ja, aber du bist bereits sozialisiert.
Okay, guter Punkt.
Geh an die nächste Generation. Du hast ja gerade die E-Sport-Thematik mit eingebracht. Geh an die nächste Generation. Es gibt jetzt 20- bis 30-Jährige, die kümmern sich ganz wenig um das Fernsehprogramm oder so. Ja, es gibt Tendenzen, die das Verhalten, das Freizeitverhalten der Menschen beschreiben. Wie das gerade läuft. Weniger Bücher, was weiß ich auch immer. Also es gibt immer immer Gründe zu fürchten, dass das, was wir alles schon kannten oder schon gut fanden, nicht mehr diese Rolle spielen wird, die es mal gespielt hat. Und dann hat der Top-Fußball ein riesiges Problem. Er lebt schon jetzt nicht mehr wirklich von den Fans. Es gab eine Zeit, da war der Verkauf der Eintrittskarten das entscheidende wirtschaftliche, die entscheidende wirtschaftliche Basis. Die Luftblase entsteht in dem Moment, wo man davon nicht mehr lebt. Gleichzeitig steigen die Gehälter der Beteiligten, hauptsächlich der Spieler, aber auch der anderen Leute. Und die kann man, das kann man doch nur auffangen, wenn man das alles wieder runterfährt. Bezahlst du dann den Lokakus dieser Welt weniger und machen die mit?
Ja, in dem Moment gerät das ganze so ein bisschen ins Banken, indem man die TV-Rechte nicht teurer werden. Also wer sich dafür interessiert, kann das Tribünengespräch zu TV-Rechten im Fußball anhören. Ich glaube, das war Nummer vier oder Nummer ja, ich glaube, Nummer vier der Tribünengespräche. Ab der Sekunde würde etwas wieder in eine Rückwärtsbewegung kommen, weil das ist gerade der wichtigste Einnahmefaktor weltweit für alle Fußballverbände national, wie jetzt auch eben die international größeren Verbände.
Also das behaupte ich nicht. Ich weiß, ich habe kein Gläser, wie nennen wir das, ein Looking Glass auf Englisch.
Die Glaskugel des Hellseers.
Das habe ich nicht. Und vor allen Dingen, es kann auch ganz langsam passieren. Das muss nicht schnell sein. Aber ich glaube, wir haben heute in diesem globalen Kontext und in dem auch diese unglaublich großen Firmen als Sponsoren sich beteiligen. Auch die Medienkonzerne sind sehr, sehr riesige Konzerne und die Konzentration auf dem Bereich ist auch sehr ausgeprägt. Also wir haben heute eine Situation, in der bestimmte Veränderungen relativ schnell passieren können, wenn sich die Gewichte wirklich deutlich verschieben. Dazu müsste man immer rauskriegen, haben Konsumenten, die sich für sowas interessieren, eventuell interessante Alternativen. Im Moment sieht es nicht so aus, dass Fußball im Weltmaßstab von irgendetwas anderem, einer anderen Sportart verdrängt werden könnte. Ich glaube, Basketball hat längst auch seinen Zenit fast erreicht. Die werden es nicht sein. Nennen wir eine andere Sportart, von der man glauben könnte, dass sie Fußball, was die Grundbegeisterung angeht, verdrängen könnte.
American Football?
Nur im Medienkontext. Also da haben wir ja festgestellt in der Spiegel, dass letztes Jahr ermittelt, dass die Mediennutzung speziell im Fernsehen in Deutschland ist American Football Platz zwei. Mit verschiedenen Ausgangsüberlegungen. Also erstens ist Fußball selber sowas von Nummer eins, dass also alles andere darunter ist einfach relativ klein. Aber ich glaube, da siehst du ein Beispiel, dass eine fürs Fernsehen ungeheuer gut konsumierbare Sportart existiert, die sich auch am Fernsehen auch eigentlich so viel interessanter anzunehmen, als im Stadion anzufangen. Was ja für Fußball und Eishockey überhaupt nicht gilt. Ich meine, das ist völlig verrückt, zum Beispiel bei Eishockey. Kleine Scheibe und du denkst, oh ja, die Kamera, die kann dir jetzt helfen, das Spiel zu verstehen. Was für ein Irrtum. Eishockey, selbst wenn du da im 18. Rang sitzt oder so, du kriegst einfach die volle Ladung Eishockey, nur wenn du in die Halle gehst. Aber das ist eben, glaube ich, das wird nicht viel bewegen. Also American Football wird nicht mehr Leute bewegen als die, die nach was Neuem suchen, nach was Interessantem anderen suchen, die Affinitäten haben zu Amerika und den Sportarten dort. American Football wird innerhalb der nächsten 20 Jahre an was ganz Anderem kaputt gehen, nämlich an den Gesundheitsproblemen, an den Gehirnschäden der Leute, an den Versicherungen, die da nicht mehr versichert, die nicht mehr versichern wollen und den Eltern, die nicht mehr ihre Kinder spielen lassen werden, bis sie 18 sind und so weiter.
Was ja witzigerweise, ironischerweise gerade dem Fußball in den USA sehr hilft, dass die Eltern eher sagen laut allen Studien, geh mal zum Fußball als zum American Football, weil da die Verletzungsgefahr so groß ist.
Ja, also es kommt natürlich darauf an, welche Verletzungen man lieber...
Ja, aber da wird ja beim Fußball noch nicht so draufgesehen.
Kreuzbänder, wenn die nicht so wichtig sind.
Ja, es ist nicht so schlimm wie der Kopf. Und zwar ist das ein großes Thema im Fußball, aber es wird noch so totgeschwiegen, dass das, glaube ich, im Bewusstsein vieler noch nicht angekommen ist. Wie gefährlich Gehirnerschütterung, Kopfverletzungen sind, die im Fußball gar nicht so unregelmäßig vorkommen, aber da guckt man gerade noch drüber hinweg. Aber wir landen jetzt, wir kamen vom FIFA-Prozess, wir kamen von der Frage, welche Folgen könnte dieser Prozess haben und sind jetzt in einer Dystopie gelandet, in der wir auf einmal über die Vormachtstellung des Fußballs in globaler Perspektive diskutieren. Das zeigt ja schon irgendwie, wie groß die Themen sind und warum man dann manchmal auch ein Tribünengespräch von fast epischer Länge braucht, um das Ganze aufzuarbeiten, finde ich. Also, ja, wir sind vom Kleinen ins Große gekommen und trotzdem läuft ja der FIFA-Prozess noch. Darf ich dich dann hin und wieder mal für einen Kurzpass anrufen, wenn die nächsten Schritte da passiert sind, beim FIFA-Prozess, wenn es dann die ersten Strafmaßzuweisungen gibt?
Ähm, gerne. Ich bin ja im Thema drin. Ich werde das auch weiter verfolgen und auch mit dem Impuls, dem mir ja nun einfach mal irgendwie zu eigen ist. Ich habe das ja jetzt nicht erwähnt. Ich bin ja von Herkunft kein Sportjournalist. Ich würde auch nicht notwendigerweise, auch heute noch, obwohl ich sehr viel mit Sport zu tun habe, mich nicht gerne so bezeichnen, nicht weil ich was gegen die Berufsbezeichnung hätte, sondern weil ich glaube, dass da die Betonung falsch liegt. Weil es geht mir eben seltener um den Journalismus über den Sport, sondern über das, was daran eben Wirtschaft, Recht, Chemie, Medizin und so weiter ist. Weil es eben nicht Tischfußball ist. Es ist nicht so, dass man einfach sagen kann, hier sitzen ein paar Leute und die kann man hier über dem Platz herrcheln sehen. Da ist eben viel mehr dahinter. Das ist auch weiterhin so meine Überlegung. Ich möchte gerne so viel wie möglich darüber herausfinden und verarbeiten und hoffe, dass ich dann die Plattformen habe, auf denen sich das dann auch darstellen lässt. Dies hier, was wir heute gemacht haben, ist allerdings wirklich eine totale Ausnahme oder eine totale ungewöhnliche Situation. Das hätte ich mir noch vor ein paar Monaten nicht ausgemalt, dass ich mal in ein Gespräch komme, in dem wir so ausführlich und so konzentriert und trotzdem auch so, ich glaube, sehr informativ zu so einem Thema was sagen können, weil die Kunst – und das möchte ich am Ende dann nochmal sagen – die Kunst liegt ja nicht nur darin, dass du jemand findest, der dir vielleicht ein paar Antworten auf Fragen geben möchte, sondern dass du so ein Gespräch auch so gut vorbereitest und so viele Geländer mit einziehst, dass man das Gefühl hat, ja, wir verlieren jetzt auch nicht den Faden, was bei so einem Thema unheimlich leicht passieren können. Und wir können zumindest hoffen, dass es Menschen gibt, die diese fast vier Stunden, die wir jetzt schon sprechen, auch tatsächlich sich einverleiben, vielleicht nicht an einem Stück, aber vielleicht in ein paar Phasen oder ein paar Etappen. Und deshalb bin ich sehr froh, dass du das möglich machst, weil deine Arbeit ist ja minimum genauso wichtig wie das andere, was wir so in unserem Metier machen und deshalb nochmal am Ende für Rasenfunk alle Daumen hoch.
Ach, danke schön. Aber Jürgen, es geht ja auch nur, weil Leute wie du, du hast zum einen den Impuls gesetzt, in dem du gesagt hast, Mensch, wir könnten darüber doch mal was machen und das hat mich auch dazu gebracht, mich da in dieses Thema so reinzuwöhnen und ohne die Gäste würde ich hier überhaupt nichts gehen und ohne die ganze Vorarbeit, die ganz, ganz viele andere Journalisten gemacht haben, ginge das alles nicht. Es gibt definitiv jetzt Leute, die das hier jetzt bis zu diesen fast vier Stunden gehört haben. Das ist das Schöne. Deswegen lohnt es sich auch, sich diese Zeit zu nehmen. Wir erreichen damit eine Zielgruppe an Hörern und Hörern, die fast so wie Schwämme das aufsaugen, was wir hier gesagt haben. Und das ist toll, weil deswegen lohnt es sich für uns beide, dass wir uns nicht nur die vier Stunden nehmen, sondern die zig Stunden vorher Vorbereitung ja auch. Aber ohne Gäste wie dich, die entgegen allem, was man im Journalismus als freier Journalist ist, ist schwierig genug, sich durchzuschlagen und sich dann ohne Honora vier Stunden hinzusetzen. Und ich meine, wie viele Mails haben wir geschrieben vor dieser Sendung? Also ohne Leute wie dich ging es schon auch nicht. Das muss man jetzt schon auch mal vornehmen.
Es ehrt dich auch, dass du das wirklich immer wieder erwähnst. Ich habe das ja schon mitbekommen, dass du da in der Beziehung auch sehr genau darauf achtest, dass du das verstehst, dass das nicht so selbstverständlich ist. Nee. In der, also die Mechanik des Machens, wenn ich das mal so als Kunstbegriff so einführen darf, die mir immer wieder durch den Kopf geht, das ist alles schön und gut, dass es Leute wie mich gibt, aber wenn es nicht Leute wie dich gibt, die es wirklich dann machen, dann entsteht eben nichts. Und das habe ich gerade selber gemerkt. Also es ist schwierig. Ich versuche ja zum Beispiel jetzt meine eigenen Bücher selber rauszubringen und da gibt es niemanden, der mich trägt oder der mich treibt oder so. Ich muss mir selber in den Arsch treten. Und weil ich das muss, dauert es auch länger, als ich vielleicht geistig irgendwie damit rechnen würde. Das heißt, ich habe einen hohen Respekt vor diesem Teil der Arbeit und natürlich noch mal weiter gebündelt oder weiter konzentriert in der Frage, okay, redet man nur rum, füllt man nur Luft oder so mit irgendwelchem Zeug oder hat man tatsächlich das Gefühl – und das ist eben das Gefühl, nachdem wir jetzt so am Ende unseres Gesprächs sind – dass man was Brauchbares zusammengetragen hat und erklären konnte. Und dann hat es sich ja auch gelohnt.
Ja, das hoffe ich auch.
Nicht nur Zeit vertreibt für Leute, die vielleicht was anderes tun sollten. Also noch mal Daumen drücken für den Rasenfunk, wenn es Leute gibt, die das noch nicht unterstützen. Ich glaube, es gibt Möglichkeiten, das zu tun. Und wenn sich das dank deiner Energie und deines Durchhaltevermögens wirklich so etabliert, dann würde ich sagen, ich bin froh, dass ich schon relativ früh von dir wusste. Dann kann ich das auch mal irgendwann erwähnen in irgendwelchen Gesprächen.
Du kanntest das, bevor es cool wurde. Ja, schauen wir mal. Und es bin ja nicht nur ich alleine, es steckt ja noch der Frank-Helm-Schrotthelmi mit drin, der mir gerade als Sparringspartner bei Themenvorschlägen unglaublich wertvoll ist, weil der mich auch manchmal einbremst, weil ich durchaus mich manchmal an zu große Themen zu früh ranwaage. Und dann sagt er, du magst bei deinem, so wie du Sendungen vorbereitest, schaffst du das nicht. Und da muss ich ihm dann manchmal auch recht geben. Von dem hier habe ich eben erst erzählt, als die Recherche schon lief, als ich die Bücher bestellt hatte. Ich hatte schon sechs Bücher bestellt und dann habe ich ihm geschrieben, übrigens, es wird ein Tribünengespräch geben, weil du so Lust und Zeit hättest. Und da konnte ich jetzt aber nicht mit dabei sein. Da war dann keine Bremse mehr möglich. Aber an der Stelle kann ich dann mal darauf hinweisen, auf die Literatur, die ich jetzt empfehlen würde rund um diesen Themenkomplex für die Leute, die Lust haben, da jetzt noch tiefer mit einzusteigen. Also es wird in den Shownotes ein paar Links geben. Gerade isbn.com hat eine ganz tolle Übersicht der beteiligten Akteure, die auch relativ aktuell ist. Der Tod von José Javilla ist noch nicht mit drin, aber den Rest haben sie ganz gut up to date. Und dann würde ich vor allem das Buch Red Card von Ken Bensinger empfehlen. Deswegen habe ich es auch schon zweimal erwähnt. Das arbeitet eben diesen ganzen US-Prozess nochmal auf. Ist auf Englisch erschienen, aber sehr gut lesbar und so wie halt die US-Amerikaner schreiben recht. Manchmal fragt man sich, kann er das denn wirklich gewusst haben oder ist das jetzt hier so ein bisschen wie Seehofer, der an seiner Eisenbahn baut, wenn es ihm schlecht geht und im Nachhinein kommt raus der Journalist Vani in diesem Keller. Aber es ist sehr gut lesbar, deshalb sehr spannend geschrieben. Red Card – How the US blew the whistle on the world's biggest sports scandal. Da habe ich ganz, ganz viel rausgezogen. Dann unbedingt empfehlenswert – Thomas Kistner mit FIFA, Mafia, die schmutzigen Geschäfte mit dem Weltfußball – Thomas Kistner sowieso einer derjenigen deutschsprachigen Autoren, die man da unbedingt gelesen haben muss. Im Blog von Jens Weinreich findet man unglaublich viele unglaublich detaillierte Artikel, die man auch viel besser versteht, wenn man die anderen Bücher vorher gelesen hat. Das kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung, der schon seit 2008 glaube ich bei Jens Weinreich mitliest, behaupten. Und Andrew Jennings – Dirty Game – war auch noch ein Buch, was ich zur Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung gelesen habe und an der Stelle empfehlen möchte. Es gibt noch ein paar weitere, die packe ich in die Show Notes, aber die drei sind jetzt die, die ich auch alle komplett gelesen habe und deswegen jetzt hier vorbehaltlos empfehlen kann. Und plus die Links, die noch zu sagen sind. Und wer weiß, vielleicht wird ja der bekannte Journalist Jürgen Kalwa, der anscheinend selbst versucht, Bücher zu verlegen, auch mal was publizieren zu dem ganzen Themenkomplex.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Also das Nächste, was ich machen werde, wenn ich das hier anfügen darf, wer es bis jetzt durchgehalten hat, der kann ja auch noch diese Information verkaufen. Schon lange angekündigt und immer noch nicht ganz fertig ist ein Buch über den Lance Armstrong Fall mit dem Titel Nichts als die Wahrheit. Und da geht es mir darum, etwas aufzuarbeiten, was eben auch in der Berichterstattung zu kurz gekommen ist. Das sind die Leute mit einzuarbeiten, die eine Rolle gespielt haben bei der Vertuschung, aber auch die Leute, die geholfen haben, es aufzuklären. Und das lebt ganz stark davon, dass ich eine Audiobook-Version mache. Die ist eben auch die mühsame Geschichte, in der ich die vielen Interviews, die ich mit allen möglichen geführt habe, außer Lance Armstrong, der wollte halt nicht mit mir reden, also Floyd Landis und David Walsh und anderen, dass ich halt in diesem Audiobook diese Töne drin habe, weil das darf ich alles verwenden und da habe ich keine rechten Probleme und das wird ein ungewöhnliches Audiobook und ich glaube, ich werde das dann auf jeden Fall mal vorlegen, sobald das dann fertig ist. Ich bin auch fast fertig, also geschrieben ist es. Und das nächste wird sein, ein Dirk Nowitzki-Projekt, über den es zwar auch schon Bücher gibt, deutscher Sprache, aber ich habe den halt begleitet von seinem allerersten Magazin- Interview, das ich mit ihm geführt habe in seinem ersten Jahr in Dallas. Und dann über die Jahre und bestimmte Aspekte, also das ist dann halt weniger eine Nachbesinnung. Also das Armstrong-Buch ist mehr so nachdenken über und diskursiv und das ist mehr mit der Kelle schöpfen aus dem Fundus dessen, was ich schon gemacht habe im Laufe der Jahre, aber mit der Idee zu zeigen, dass man bei einer so langen Karriere von jetzt ja über 20 Profijahren, also da geht es jetzt in sein 21. Jahr, dass man in so einer langen Karriere natürlich verschiedene Phasen hat und auch den Titel für dieses Buch gibt es schon, das heißt So weit, So gut und das soll natürlich weniger, das ist distanziert, aber nicht jetzt, also der Versuch, Herr Nowitzki komplett neu zu erklären und kritisch zu beleuchten, sondern wirklich mehr so ein Füllhorn aus der Überlegung, okay, wie ist aus jemandem, der selber sehr unsicher war in der Zeit als 18- 19-jähriger, wie ist aus dem dann über die Jahre was geworden und das spielt natürlich dann auch andere Figuren eine Rolle, auch in dem Fall kann ich davon profitieren, dass ich mit Leuten wie seinen Agenten und Mentor gesprochen habe, Holger Geschwindner und dem Trainer, der ihn nach Dallas geholt hat, Don Nelson und so weiter und da gibt es ja verschiedene Einblicke, aber auch das muss ich mal schauen, wie das im Audiobook-Format ein bisschen interessanter wird, da habe ich nicht so viel Ausgangsmaterial, vielleicht wird es ein klassischen Vorlese, ein Vorlese-Buch werden, mal schauen, vielleicht, und dann habe ich weitere Ideen für später, aber Aber die FIFA, glaube ich, das wird es nicht sein. Ich glaube, das überlasse ich gerne Kollegen, wie Benzinger zum Beispiel, der wirklich schon von Anfang an mit der Überlegung eingestiegen ist, ein Buch draus zu machen. Ich habe mit ihm auch mal zwischendurch telefoniert und kenne so ein bisschen seinen Gedankengang und Werdegang. Das heißt auch, dass jemand dann sehr zügig arbeitet. Das ist etwas, was Leuten wie mir nicht vergönnt ist. Ich kann nicht einfach mich so ausklinken und muss halt gucken, wie ich das alles so nebenbei mache.
Als Freier muss man ja seine Aufträge nebenher noch abarbeiten.
Es ist halt meine Beobachtung, Zustand, Bücher in Deutschland, speziell Thema Sport. Die Bereitschaft auf der Verlagseite, sich um solche Themen zu kümmern, ist relativ gering. Die Kosten-Nutzen-Analyse geht ganz schnell nach dem Motto, was kann man davon verkaufen? Da wird eine Fan-Literatur blind produziert und möglicherweise auch erfolgreich verkauft. Das weiß ich nicht. Alles andere hat da gar keinen Platz. Das heißt, man ist dazu gezwungen, einen eigenen Weg zu finden. Dann kann man nur hoffen, dass man heute über Social Media und andere mögliche Kanäle einen Weg findet und ein gewisses Echo produziert. Den Testballon werden wir jetzt erleben. Das wird interessant.
Der Testballon wird sein, dass alle Leute, die bis hierhin gehört haben, bitte at American Arena auf Twitter schreiben, wenn sie dir auf Twitter zugegen sind, wie sie diese Folge gefunden haben und dass sie dir unbedingt folgen. Denn dann bekommt man von diesen anderen Projekten auf jeden Fall etwas mit. Das können wir als Testballon machen.
Followers sind willkommen.
Sehr gut. Ich würde sagen, Jürgen, dann machen wir diese Geschichte hierzu. Vielen Dank. Jürgen Kalwa, zugeschaltet aus New York. Mensch, diesen Satz wollte ich schon immer sagen. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Wir können ja solche Sachen hinkriegen.
Absolut. Diese moderne Technik, sie ist einfach wunderbar. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke wie immer für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Meldet euch im Forum, wenn ihr Nachfragen habt. Unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de. Unterstützt uns, wenn ihr denn möchtet. Und lasst euch nicht unterkriegen, auch wenn das Ende dieser Folge etwas pessimistisch war. Fußball ist trotzdem ein interessantes Thema. Und wir werden halt immer wieder auch mal in die kritischen Ecken gucken, hier im Rasenfunk. Dafür ist er ja da. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit. Bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch. Macht's gut. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.